MEETING TO ORDER WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM YET OF SO WE WILL START
OFF AS A SUB COMMITTEE -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF BILLS -- ON THE
AGENDA TODAY SO.
I JUST WANT TO ADVISE ALL OF OUR
AUTHORS. TO TRY TO KEEP THEIR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES
EACH.
PER WITNESS ALL THOSE WHO ARE
COMING UP FOR THE PUBLIC TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
YOUR NAME.
AND THEN WHETHER YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT THE BILL.
OR IF YOUR TWEENER I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE SOME OF THOSE -- TOO
SO BUT LET'S TRY TO KEEP THIS IN
THE INTEREST OF MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON THEIR BILLS AND THAT
WE HEAR FROM EVERYONE.
WANT TO KEEP THAT ON TRACK AND
WE WILL START OFF WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS
[inaudible] FIVE BILLS -- AND
WE'LL START WITH MR GLORIA.
THANK YOU SIR -- GOOD MORNING --
PRESENTATION BY ACCEPTING
ADMINISTRATION DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS TAKEN OUT OF THEIR
WORK.
THE WHOLE I GUESS WE GOT A PAUSE
HERE WHAT WE GOT GOING ON PEOPLE.
AT HOME MISTER CHAIRMAN CANNOT
HEAR MY VOICE THAT -- APOLOGIES.
ALL AGES THAT TO ADD.
OKAY WE'RE ALL SET UP HERE A
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
THERE I DIDN'T PRESS PRESS THE
BUTTON -- HE ALWAYS WAS.
THAT RECEIPT.
YES PLEASE PROCEED
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU
SIR -- I DON'T START -- BY
ACCEPTING THE MINUTES DESCRIBED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND TAKE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL.
A MEMBERS AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL STRENGTHEN LONG STANDING
LAWS AIMED AT PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S WILD AND DOMESTIC
HORSES FROM SLAUGHTER.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT VOTERS
PROP PASSED PROPOSITION SIX
WHICH MADE THE SLAUGHTER OF
HORSES FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION AND
THE SALE OF HORSE MEAT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION ILLEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA.
BOB SIX ALSO PROHIBITS FORCES
ZEALOT SITTING HORSES OUT OF OUR
STATE FOR SLAUGHTER TO OTHER
STATES OR COUNTRIES FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
DESPITE THIS EXISTING STATE LAW
COURSES IN CALIFORNIA CONTINUE
TO BE ACQUIRED AT AUCTION OR
THROUGH SALES THE END UP IN THE
SLAUGHTER PIPELINE.
THIS ISSUE WAS PUT ONTO OUR
RADAR LAST FALL WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BEGAN ROUNDING UP.
WILD HORSES ON FOREST SERVICE
LAND IN PROPOSED PUTTING THEM UP
FOR SALE WITH WITHOUT LIMITATION.
I WHICH MEANS THEY COULD END UP
BEING SLAUGHTERED. TWENTY TWO OF
OUR FELLOW LEGISLATORS INCLUDING
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
IN ATTORNEY GOOD GENERAL HABIA
BUT SERRA.
ASKED THE BUT PUT THE FOR FOR
SERVICE ON NOTICE AND THUS FAR
WE HAVE HELD OFF ON SUCH SALES.
BUT THE THREAT TO HORSES REMAIN.
LAST YEAR APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND AMERICAN HORSES BOTH
DOMESTIC AND WILD WERE TRUCKED
TO CANADA AND MEXICO WITH THEIR
CRUELLY SLAUGHTERED FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA'S DO ALL WE
CAN TO PROTECT OUR FORCES FROM
SUFFERING THE STATE.
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT WILL
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
COURSES IN THREE WAYS.
FIRST IT WILL MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
IT IS UNLAWFUL FOR ANY PERSON TO
HAVE IMPORT EXPORT CELL BY GIVE
AWAY HOLD OR ACCEPT ANY COURTS
FOR SLAUGHTER FOR ANY COMMERCIAL
PURPOSE PURPOSE.
SECOND YOU'LL CREATE A FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVE TO PURCHASE
SUPPORTS FOR SLAUGHTER BY
REQUIRING THAT ALL HORSES SOLD
AT PUBLIC OR PRIVATE AUCTION BE
SOLD AT A PRICE THAT IS ABOVE
THE CURRENT SLAUGHTER PRICE.
THIRD IT WILL ACQUIRE ANY PERSON
PERSON'S PARTS IN OF COURSE AT A
CALIFORNIA LOOK OR PRIVATE
AUCTION TO BE TO SIGNED A SWORN
STATEMENT ACKNOWLEDGING AND
GREEN TO COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
PROHIBITING THE SALE OR RESALE
OF COURSES FOR SLAUGHTER FOR ANY
COMMERCIAL PURPOSE WITH ME THIS
MORNING MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN IS
THE TO TESTIFIED SUPPORT ISSUES
AND WHY AMERICAN HORSE CAMPAIGN.
AND MAKING GAINS THE MAYOR OF
THE OXEN HORSES RESCUE.
BUT PLEASE WITNESSES A SUPPORTER
REMEMBER WE GOT A TWO MINUTE
TIME YEAH I LOVE IT HERE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GALLAGHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN WILD HORSE
CAMPAIGNS THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS AND SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOLLOWERS AND
SUPPORTERS NATIONWIDE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MR GLORIA AND
CO AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WALDRON BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
CERVANTES CHOI A KALRA LEVINE
SENATORS CHIANG PORTANTINO AN
HERTZBERG.
THE IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL DID
COME FROM THE MODOC NATIONAL
FOREST THREATENING TO SELL WILD
HORSES WITHOUT LIMITATION ON
SLAUGHTER THAT WOULD BE THE
FIRST TIME THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SOLD WILD HORSES
WITHOUT LIMITATION ON SLAUGHTER.
SINCE THE WILD HORSE ACT WAS
PASSED TO PROTECT THEM IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE THE
SITUATION HIGHLIGHTED THAT MANY
CALIFORNIA HORSES ARE STILL IN
DANGER OF SLAUGHTER DESPITE PROP
SIX PASSED BY VOTERS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT MAKING FOR
SLAUGHTER FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION
A FELONY UNDER STATE LAW.
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT WILL A LINE
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH THE FEDERAL
PROHIBITION ON SELLING WILD
HORSES FOR SLAUGHTER.
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT IT IS
UNLAWFUL FOR ANY PERSON TO HAVE
THE IMPORT EXPORT CELL BY
GIVEAWAY HOLD OR ACCEPT ANY
HORSE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
SLAUGHTER FOR ANY COMMERCIAL
PURPOSE IT WILL REQUIRE A
MINIMUM BID FOR ALL COURSES SOLD
AT AUCTIONS SAID ABOVE THE
CURRENT SLAUGHTER PRICE.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
APPROACH OF CALIFORNIA
THOROUGHBRED OWNERS MAKING IT AN
ECONOMICAL FOR KILL BUYERS TO
OPERATE HERE.
AND IT WILL UPDATE THE SIGNAGE
WARNING AT AUCTIONS ABOUT THE
LEGALITY OF FOR SLAUGHTER AND
REQUIRE ANY PERSON PURCHASING
HORSES AT AUCTION TO SIGN A
SWORN STATEMENT AGREEING TO
COMPLY WITH STATE LAW.
WE'RE WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WANT TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S HORSES ARE SPARED
THE MISERY OF TRANSPORT AND
SLAUGHTER AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDRESSING ANY ISSUES THAT.
MAY ARISE AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS AND
URGE YOU RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
AT GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
GALLAGHER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
AND SPECIAL THANKS TO SOME WOMEN
GLORIA -- FOR INTRODUCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
I RUN OPTION HORSES RESCUE
EIGHTY CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
BASED IN LOS ANGELES AND I'VE
BEEN ON THE FRONTLINES RESCUING
IN NETWORKING MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED HORSES.
FROM CALIFORNIA AUCTIONS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN MY
RESCUE WORK IS TAKING ME TO
SEVEN AUCTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
DESPITE THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIX
THE PURCHASE OF HORSES FOR
SLAUGHTER CONTINUES TO BE
BUSINESS AS USUAL FOR LOW AND
HOARSE TRADERS.
MANY FINAL HORSES TO KILL BUYERS
WHO SELL THEM TO A THIRD PARTY
OUT OF STATE.
THE THIRD PARTY THAN SHIPS THE
HORSES OUT OF THE COUNTRY TO BE
SLAUGHTERED IN MEXICO OR CANADA --
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO OUR WORSE IS AT
THESE AUCTIONS THE HORSES THAT
ESPECIALLY BREAK MY HEART ARE
THE LESSON HORSES CAMP PORTS IS
EVEN THERAPY HORSES.
ONCE LOVED INCLUDED ON THEIR
DUMP WHEN THEY BECOME TO OLDER
TO STORE AND SENT TO AUCTION
THEN BETRAYED BY THE VERY PEOPLE
LEAVE TIRELESSLY WORKED.
FOR INSTEAD OF A SAFE RETIREMENT
OR AT THE VERY LEAST HUMANE
EUTHANASIA THESE POOR WORSE IS
ARE LEFT TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES
AT AUCTION.
THERE WERE SINCE PAST THEIR
PRIME WITH VARYING ISSUES AND
THEY'RE HEARTLESS WE SOLD
WITHOUT HESITATION MOST WIND UP
ON THE SLAUGHTER TRACK ANY
SOURCES DID DESERVE SO MUCH MORE --
THIS BILL IS A MODEST APPROACH
TO REDUCING THE NUMBER OF COURSE
IS GOING TO SLAUGHTER AND I
BELIEVE IT WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
AT THE MINIMUM BID REQUIREMENT
FOR HORSE SOLD AT AUCTION WILL
CREATE A SAFETY NET AND MAKE
COURSE TRADING FOR SLAUGHTER.
FAR LESS ECONOMICALLY VIABLE THE
GOAL IS THAT THE PRICE EXCEEDS
THE KILL BUYERS ABILITY TO MAKE
A PROFIT.
AFTER FACTORING IN
TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
THE SWORN STATEMENT IN BETTER
SIGNAGE WILL PUT PEOPLE ON
NOTICE ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA LAW
AND THE EXPANSION TO SLAUGHTER
FOR ANY COMMERCIAL PURPOSE.
WHICH WILL PRECLUDE ANY PRE
HENCE OF COURSE IS GOING TO
SLAUGHTER FOR NON HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
AS I'VE SEEN ON A MONTHLY BASIS
AT THESE AUCTIONS CALIFORNIA
HORSES TRULY NEED YOUR HELP.
I SINCERELY URGE YOU TO PASS AB
ONE TWENTY EIGHT AND I THINK YOU
AGAIN.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND AGAIN HIS NAME ORGANIZATION
IN OPPOSITION -- SUPPORT.
GOOD.
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE SAME.
A IN THE SAME VEIN SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY LEWIS FROM FAIRFAX
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT?
BRIAN AGREE FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
BRENDA GEHRY FROM DVIS
MELISSA HOUSES SNOW FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LINDA MIDDLE SOURCE ON BEHALF OF
PETER POP BACK IN IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS IN SUPPORT.
LILY KIRBY FROM DAVIS CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
PATRICIA EASILY MEADOW VISTA
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
BRANDY LEAVE MEADOW VISTA
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
KAREN LAFFEY FROM LARKSPUR
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS JIM MCBRIDE I'M WITH
CONNECTION EARTHLY.
SPEAKER SLEEVE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARGARET KIRKPATRICK FROM
TRUCKEE CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
DEBBIE MEREDITH FROM SUKMA
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AMELIA PERRIN FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
SUSAN KIRKPATRICK FROM TURKEY
CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHOICE PALADE FROM BUT WHAT
CALIFORNIA IN A VOICE SUPPORT
THE BILL.
DONE WHAT THEY SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
TERRY LEAVES FROM OUT TO
CALIFORNIA I VIGOROUSLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AS WELL.
FREE THERE ARE THREE GUESTS WILL
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ERIN HEALTHY ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT COYOTE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FIND A TOMLINSON PROJECT COYOTE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL WILDLIFE
REHABILITATED AS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
OKAY CYBER URINE TO CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JACKIE DAY SEPARATE CHECK A
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
MARY VENABLE BOYD RANCH SANDRA
FELL I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JENNIFER CROSS MILL VALLEY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JACOBY MARINO SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
YOUR GARCIA OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KAREN GARCIA OF SACRAMENTO
DEB ACOSTA NEVADA CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PIPER CRYSTAL FALLS IN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE SYDNEY DANCE THING COULDN'T
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THE BILL.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG EL SERENO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND ARE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LESLEY GOLDBERG EL SERENO I
REPRESENT COMPASSIONATE BAY AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TERRI BARNATO COLFAX CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
DO NOT LET ANYONE TELL YOU THAT
SCIATICA.
THE FIRST OKAY.
GOOD AND PROCEED.
AGAIN TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS -- ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND WE ARE OPPOSED IN
WITH AMENDED ON MISTER GORE IF
AB -- ONE TWENTY EIGHT AS WHAT
WAS -- PUT TOGETHER IN A LETTER
THAT WAS DELIVERED DID TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MONDAY AND AND CONVERSATIONS
WITH US STAFF LAST WEEK -- WE DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR COMMITTEE STAFF CHAIRMAN
GARCIA THE SPONSORS -- TO
ADDRESS ONE OF OUR LARGER
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL WHICH WAS
SECTION SIXTEEN AND AND
MODIFYING PENAL CODE SECTION
FIVE NINE SEVEN NO IS A RELATED
TO THE SPECIFIC TRANSPORTATION
OF ANIMALS DESTINED FOR
SLAUGHTER WE APPRECIATE THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
AND CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS OF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD HOWEVER.
THERE ARE STILL TWO BERRIES
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
EXISTS WITH THE EXISTING BILL --
HAVE DRAFTED -- FUNDAMENTALLY ON
WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY IS A A
LOT OF CONVERSATION AND
CONCERNED ABOUT PROPOSITION SIX
AND THAT THE EXPANSION FOR ANY
AND EVERY COMMERCIAL PURPOSE WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE INITIATIVE
ESSENTIALLY CREATED A LOOPHOLE.
THE FACT IS THAT PROPOSITION SIX
IN AN OF ITSELF THE EXISTING
PROPOSITION THE EXISTING LAWS
THE LOOPHOLE THERE IS NO
ENFORCEMENT.
PROPOSITION SIX IS NOT ENFORCED
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY FORCES
WERE STILL ARGUABLY BEING TAKEN
TO SLAUGHTER.
HAD CALIFORNIA PROVIDED
ENFORCEMENT HAD CALIFORNIAN THE
VOTERS ACTUALLY WANTED TO HAVE A
FINER PENALTY FOR VIOLATION
GREATER THAN THE PRICE OF AN
IPHONE I THINK THAT WE WOULD
HAVE SEEN.
MUCH MORE ENFORCEMENT ON THE
ACTIVE FORCES BEING TAKEN
ILLEGALLY OUT OF CALIFORNIA ON
THAT WE DON'T UNDERSTAND IN MY
MEMBERS DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH EXPANDING THE PROHIBITION
TO ANY COMMERCIAL PURPOSE WHEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SHOWN.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS THAT
WE HAVE NOT EVEN ABLE BILL WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO ENFORCE.
THE FACT THAT HORSES ARE STILL
BEING TAKEN FOR SLAUGHTER FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
IN TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION SIX ONLY
TO INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE EVER BEEN
CHARGED.
WITH POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF
THAT INITIATIVE AND NONE OF THEM
HAD SERVED ANY JAIL TIME
[inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
EXCUSE ME IN ADDITION THE OTHER
COMPONENT OF THIS LEGISLATION
THAT CAUSES SOME CONCERN AND
DEFINITELY SOME POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IS WHAT
THAT RESERVE PRICE FOR THAT
MARKET PRICE WILL BE.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY WELL KNOWN
AT LEAST TO THE SPONSORS AND AND
TO THE AUTHOR FOR OFFICE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT THERE
ISN'T REALLY A MARKET RATE
THAT'S A MARKET RATE THAT'S
DETERMINED BY EITHER THE UNITED
STATES IS WHAT THE PRICE PER
POUND.
MAYBE FOR FOR STATE AND NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S A PROBLEM AS
WELL BUT SPECIFICALLY IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SETTING A RESERVE
AT A PRICE FOR AUCTION.
THESE AUCTIONS SIR DISTINCTLY
TWO PURPOSES THE FIRST PURPOSES.
THE ONE WHICH IS I THINK THE
INTEREST OF OF THE SPONSOR IS
WELL IF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE TRYING TO SAVE AND RESCUE
THESE HORSES IT IS TO PROVIDE
THESE HORSES WITH THE BETTER
CHANCE AND SECOND CHANCE OF LIFE.
THE OTHER PURPOSE OF THIS IS
UNFORTUNATELY THE REALITY THAT
SUMMER FINDING THEIR WAY THROUGH
THIS WATER PIPELINE.
IF IN FACT WE ARE PUT
ESTABLISHING A MARKET RESERVE A
MARKET CAP.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE HORSES WHEN
THAT RESEARCHERS AT MET?
DO THEY GET ABANDONED DO THEY
GET LEFT BEHIND ARE THEY STILL
TURNED OVER TO SOME OTHER ENTITY
FOR SLAUGHTER OR ARE WE ACTING
AS A DISINCENTIVE FOR RESCUES.
AND SANCTUARIES OR ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUAL INTERESTED IN BUYING
THE HORSE TO ADOPT THAT HORSE I
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION IF WE ARE
MOVING TOWARDS ESTABLISHING A
MARKET PRICE.
WHAT THAT MAYBE AND SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT
COULD COME ABOUT -- I'VE TAKEN
UP MOST OF MY TIME -- WE ARE
AGAIN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED --
WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR NO VOTE
TODAY WE WOULD ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
TO LAY OFF THIS WEEK CAN YOU TO
WORK WITH THE BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE GONNA STEPS A
QUORUM REAL QUICK -- BETTER
QUICK TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GALLAGHER HERE.
BIGELOW.
CHOI HERE.
CHIU.
KELLY YOUR FRIEDMAN.
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA.
GLORIA HERE [inaudible]
COLOR [inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SALAS WOULD.
AND I WANT TO WELCOME MISTER
REAVIS SAID AND BELIEVE THE
SUBSTITUTION IN TODAY.
ON THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL GO TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS ANOTHER GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN LEVEL --
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
POLITICAL ANIMALS I AM ALSO
TESTING NOT TESTIFYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HORSEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION -- AND FRIENDS OF
ANIMALS.
POLITICAL ANIMALS VIEWS THE
ORGANIZATION THAT CREATED.
WROTE.
AND CAMPAIGN FOR PROPOSITION SIX
SO WE WERE PRESENT.
AT THE CREATION OF THE PREVIOUS
WITNESS SAID SOMETHING WITH
WHICH WE DO AGREE -- AND THAT'S
THAT.
BLOOM WITH PROPOSITION SIX HAS
BEEN ENFORCEMENT.
AND WE WOULD ASK OF THAT ALL OUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL IS
SUPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
WE WOULD ASK -- FIRST OF ALL
THAT THE BILL ACTUALLY FOCUS ON
ENFORCEMENT -- WE HAD EARLY
ENFORCEMENT SUCCESSES WHEN PROP
SIX WAS -- IN ACTED -- WORKING
WITH THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
LOCKYER AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT
J. GOALS FROM KERN COUNTY -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ACTUALLY INSPECTED.
TRUCKS AS THEY WERE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA AND SURVEYED AS TO
WHETHER THEY WERE BOUND FOR
SLAUGHTER AND WAS ABLE TO TURN
THOSE BACK.
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING --
WE THEN WENT TO SEE IF WE COULD
GET THE HIGHWAY PATROL TO DO
THAT BECAUSE FOOD IN AG FRANKLY --
LOST INTEREST WE THINK A BILL
THAT HAS LANGUAGE IN IT.
THAT DIRECTS THAT ALL HORSES
BEING TRANSFERRED OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
MUST BE INSPECTED AND CERTIFIED
AND CLEARED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO SLAUGHTER.
BY EITHER FOOD IN A BAG OR THE
HIGHWAY PATROL -- THAT IS A HUGE
PIECE WE THINK THE OTHER PIECE
THAT GIVES US PROBLEMS WITH THIS
BILL.
IS THE CONFUSION IN THE BILL
OVER -- THE MISDEMEANOR COUNT.
OF FOR SLAUGHTER OF HORSES FOR
ECONOMIC PURPOSES.
FIRST OF ALL CURRENTLY WE ARE
UNAWARE OF OTHER ECONOMIC
PURPOSES FOR WHICH SLOW HORSES
ARE SLAUGHTERED.
THEN FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION --
BUT IF THE LAW WERE TO GET IT OR
IF ECONOMIC PRACTICES WERE TO
EVOLVE OR DEVOLVE.
OF WHERE -- HORSES WERE
SLAUGHTERED FOR OTHER HUMAN
CONSUMPTION TO US THERE IS NO
EXCUSE NONE AT ALL. FOR MAKING
THAT A MERE MISDEMEANOR WHICH
REALLY BECOMES A LICENSE FEE FOR
SOMEONE WHO SEES AN ECONOMIC
BENEFIT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT.
THE OLD THE PENALTY LANGUAGE
SHOULD TRACK THE FELONY LANGUAGE
THAT COULD CURRENTLY EXISTS WITH
PROPOSITION.
SIX WE AFTER A LOT OF BLOOD
SWEAT AND TEARS ON THE FLOOR. TO
ENACT PROPOSITION SIX MANY OF
THE ANIMAL ESTABLISHMENT GROUPS --
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES PETER STATE OUT OF THE
PROP SIX CAMPAIGN EVEN THOUGH
THEY LATER CLAIM CREDIT AFTER IT
PASSED -- BUT WE ARE VERY
CONSCIOUS OF ANY.
UNINTENDED -- UNDERMINING OF OF
PROPOSITION SIX AND WE ARE WE
ARE AT A LOSS TO UNDERSTAND WHY
SLAUGHTER OF HORSES FOR ECONOMIC
PURPOSES IS A MISDEMEANOR.
BUT SLAUGHTER OF HORSES FOR
HUMAN PURPOSES IS A FELONY THEY
ALL SHOULD BE FELONIES -- A AND
THE OTHER PROBLEM THAT THAT
CREATES LIVES IN THE CURRENT
LANGUAGES IT DOES CREATE.
A CONFUSION -- I KNOW THAT
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT SAYS THAT THE PENALTY
PROVISIONS FOR ECONOMIC
SLAUGHTER WILL NOT APPLY TO
SLAUGHTER.
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION -- BUT
THAT VERY AMBIGUITY STEEL
INVITES MISCHIEF BY THOSE WHO
WANT TO UNDERMINE -- PROP.
SIX MR LEVEL I GOTTA WERE OVER
TIME HERE SO I WAS GONNA READ
MAY FROM ASIA VOTE FOR ANOTHER
FORTY OKAY.
OF WHAT JUST ONE FINAL NOTE YES
GO AHEAD I DO WANT TO APOLOGIZE
TO THE AUTHOR FOR OUR LATE
OPPOSITION BUT WE ONLY FOUND OUT.
ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
BILL LAST WEEK BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
TOWARD ENACTING A BILL THAT
REINFORCES PROP SIX RATHER THAN
ONE THAT INADVERTENTLY MAY
UNDERMINE IT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR.
THEY JUST ALL FILLED WITH
CALIFORNIA ALLEN SAYS HE DID NOT
HAVE THE BILL BUT I DO WANNA.
THANK YOU I DO WANT -- TO THANK
THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR TAKING
COMMITTEE MINUTES AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR DRAFTING THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
TRANSPORTATION PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL I ALSO DO WANT TO SAY VERY
BRIEFLY -- THAT -- WILD HORSES
ON THE MODOC NATIONAL FOREST ARE
1000% OVER.
THE APPROVED MANAGEMENT LEVEL
THAT SET UNDER THE NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY ACT AND SO
WE ARE OPEN TO WORKING WITH
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
OBVIOUSLY CONGRESS TO POOR
SERVICE.
AND SPONSOR THIS BILL TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON MANAGEMENT
BECAUSE ARE SIGNIFICANT
ECOLOGICAL DAMAGE THAT IS DONE --
WITHOUT ADDRESSING A PROBLEM SO.
THE AUTHOR AND YOU KNOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER OLD BILL OR ANY
OTHER.
OPPOSITION OKAY I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
OBVIOUSLY THIS BILL IMPACTS ON
MY DISTRICT A VERY CLOSE TO MY
HOME.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE ANY MEMBER
THAT WANTS TO COME TO MY
DISTRICT AND SEE THE WHEN WE ARE
FACED WITH IT IS BASICALLY.
IT'S CRAZY THAT WE HAVE AS A
MISTER ALL FILLED -- MENTION WE
HAVE A 1000% MORE HORSES ON OUR
RANGE.
THAT WERE ANTICIPATED TO BE
THERE AND WE ARE IN A DILEMMA
WITH.
THEM STARVING THEY'RE ALL KINDS
AND WE'VE WE'VE TRIED YES MA'AM
COMMON SEE HAPPEN AND SO --
THERE THERE'S STARVATION THERE
OVER POPULATED THEY ARE DOES
DEVASTATING THE LANDSCAPE AND SO
WE ARE IN A IN A PROBLEM THE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS SPENT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON ADOPTION PROGRAMS.
THROUGH THE NOT ONLY THE DOUBLE
THIS GARDEN BUT THE SUSANVILLE
WILD SANCTUARY AND SO THE THE
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS THAT --
I THINK IT'S WELL INTENTIONED
BUT IT'S GOING TO PUT YOU HAVE
SOME PROBLEMS -- FOR ACTUALLY
MANAGING A COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO
DO IT SO I WILL BE OPPOSING THE
BILL TODAY I KNOW THE AUTHOR.
IS TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
I THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO
A PLACE WHERE WE PROTECT --
NOLLIE THAT HOPEFULLY THE
HABITAT AND THE DEVASTATION IS
HAVING IT THERE BUT TO GIVING US
A PATHWAY TO GET THESE HORSES
ADOPTED IN IN A PIPELINE THAT
WHERE.
IT'S MAKES SOME SENSE BUT THE
STATE WE'RE IN TODAY IS
COMPLICATED BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INVOLVED IN
THIS PROCESS ALONG WITH.
TRYING TO MAKE DECENT POLICIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO -- I WOULD
ENCOURAGE -- AUTHOR TO WORK WITH --
THE CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION --
AND TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS WHO ARE TRYING
TO AUCTION THEIR HORSES --
NATURALLY THROUGH A PROCESS
WE'RE GOING FROM -- NOT FOR
CONSUMPTION -- MAKE OF IT SO
THAT USABLE AND WORKABLE FOR THE
PEOPLE ACTUAR IN THE INDUSTRY SO --
HOW WE OPPOSE YOUR LEGISLATION A
AND I ENCOURAGE COME OUT ON THE
GROUND AND I CAN TAKE YOU TO
PLACES WHERE YOU?
THERE'S THERE'S THEIR
DEVASTATING THE RESOURCE NUMBER
ONE AND IT'S DOES NOT A NATURAL
STATE WHERE THERE'S ABILITY BILL
TO USE THE RESOURCE AND AND MAKE
IT TO SOMETHING THAT IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY -- SETS FREE
INSENSITIVE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
IS.
OKAY AND SO THAT IS A DO PASS
WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON THE
AUTHOR I HEARD YOU STATE YOUR
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
CORRECT.
YES SIR OKAY -- SO MOVED AND
SECONDED -- DID YOU HAVE A
COMMENT.
YEAH GO AHEAD.
SO THERE WILL BE A LITTLE OFF
TOPIC BUT I WANTED TO JUST PICK
YOU BACK ON SOMETHING THAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY SAID I'M
I'M A LONG TIME FOR SOONER AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW LIFELONG HORSE
OWNER AND ADOPTING HORSE OUT AS
MUCH HARDER THAN ADOPTING A DOG
OR A CAT OUT.
IT TAKES A SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO THE TURKEY OF KEEP FORCES AND
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS.
IS JUST PRICE OF HAS BEEN GOING
UP -- AS WE CHANGE OTHER CROPS --
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD ALL THINK ABOUT IS IF WE
REALLY CARE ABOUT GETTING THESE
HORSES ADOPTED OUT IS FINDING
WAYS TO BRING THE COST OF SOME
OF THAT HORSE OWNERSHIP DOWN
SOMEHOW.
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE LOSING A LOT
OF LAND -- IN A LOT OF PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE COULD KEEP COURSES
IN THE PAST EVEN NO I REPRESENT
RANCHO BURBANK AND RANCHO
GLENDALE AND WE'RE LOSING YOU
KNOW EVERY DAY WE LOSE ANOTHER
COURSE KEEPING HOUSE SOMEBODY
PUTS A SWIMMING POOL IN THE
BACKYARD TAKES A STABLE OUT THAT
NEVER COMES BACK.
AGAIN SO MAYBE THERE'S SOME YOU
KNOW LAMBLEY JUST SOMETHING FOR
US ALL TO THINK ABOUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
WE REALLY WANT TO GET THESE
HORSES ADOPTED THANKS.
ALL RIGHT TO THE MR GLORIA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
DODD WILL COMMIT TO THE
COMMITTEE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THE LEGISLATION AS
GOOD AS CAN BE -- PROCEDURE
CONSIDERATION RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR.
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT WILL
MATTER CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
ABSTAINED.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING CHIU
KELLY.
KELLY NO.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I'D
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA HI
GLORIA I KALRA.
COLOR I'D THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO
SALAS WOULD.
OKAY ONE WILL BE A FIVE VOTES ON
THAT WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL ON IT
FOR OTHER MEMBERS COME ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA RIGHT
NEXT UP WE HAVE A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL.
MOVING ALONG IN OUR SPECIAL
ORDER [inaudible]
AND ALSO.
IS JOINT AUTHORS SENATOR CAFIERO.
WELCOME BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THE REAL QUICK I WANT TO TAKE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHILE WE
HAVE MEMBERS HERE SO CAN WE CALL --
MOVED AND SECONDED BY MISTER
BIGELOW MISTER DALLI.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHTY TO NINETY TWO QUIRK.
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO BIGELOW.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY FIVE GIPSON.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN A WOOD.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN FRIEDMAN.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FOR FORTY NINE O'DONNELL
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN EACH GARCIA.
ARE ALL DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B. C.
THIRTY TO DALLY.
WITH RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER AYE YEAH BUT THE
EAGLE LOGO THREE BILLS HELLO HI.
BOY.
CHOI AYE.
CHU.
VALLEY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA.
GARCIA I GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
COLOR I GLORIA GLORIA I THREE OF
US.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO IF
IT IS ON SALAS WOODS IS AGAIN
COMMITTEE. NINE TWO ZERO ON OKAY
NINE ZERO THAT IS ON CALL.
AND WE THE SERVER VOEPEL GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED AND JUST KEEP
IN MIND WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
TODAY'S SOLAR ADVISE ALL THE
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES ACTUALLY
TWO WITNESSES. TWO MINUTE CHEECH
SO YEAH.
MR VOEPEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY AT PRESENT.
AB FIVE TWENTY SEVEN RELATING TO
ALLIGATORS AND CROCODILES AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY
DESCRIBE PRODUCTS DERIVED FROM
NON ENDANGERED ALLIGATOR AND
CROCODILE PARTS OR PRODUCTS.
USING THOSE PARTS WILL BE
PROHIBITED FOR SALE IN OUR STATE
AS OF JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THE PRO WHO
BISSCHEN HAS BEEN EXTENDED BY
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION AND AB FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN SIX TO PROVIDE
ANOTHER TEN YEAR EXTENSION TO
THAT PROHIBITION.
SIMILAR TO AB TWENTY SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH PASSED THIS COMMITTEE
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENTS A BOTH ALLIGATOR
CROCODILE CONSERVATION EFFORTS
AND ANY USE OF ALLIGATORS AND
CROCODILES FOR LEGITIMATE
FARMING A MEDICAL RESEARCH
PURPOSES.
HAVE OCCURRED SINCE THE LAST
EXTENSION WAS PASSED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AS OUR WITNESSES
HERE WILL POINT OUT ADVANCE IS A
BIT MADE AN INFLAMMATION OF BEST
PRACTICES WITH AN ALLIGATOR
FARMS AND MAJOR IMPROVEMENTS
BOTH AND FARMING EFFORTS AND IN
THE WILD.
ALLIGATORS OR CROCODILE PRODUCTS
WHICH ARE ALLOWED INTO THE US IT
IN THE CALIFORNIA OR NEITHER
ENDANGERED NORTH THREATENED BY
EITHER THE INTERNATIONAL UNION
FOR CONSERVATION OF NATURE OF
THE ENVIRONMENT.
OR THE U. N. ENVIRONMENT WORLD
CONSERVATION MONITORING CENTER.
FURTHERMORE WHILE POPULATIONS OF
ALLIGATORS IN THE US ARE
THRIVING.
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN SURVEY BY THE
LOUISIANA DEPARTMENT OF
FISHERIES AND WILDLIFE ESTIMATED
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER TWO
MILLION ALLIGATORS LIVING IN
LOUISIANA.
THE LEGITIMATE ALLIGATOR FARMING
INDUSTRY IN THE U. S. PROVIDES
MANY JOBS AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE STATES
WHERE ALLIGATOR FORMING OCCURS
ADDITIONALLY IT SUPPORTS MANY.
RETAIL JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
FAILURE TO PASS THIS BILL WE
HAVE MANY NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
ONE CONSERVATION EFFORTS THAT
HAVE HELPED ALLIGATOR A
CROCODILE SPECIES ACHIEVE THEIR
RECOVERY WILL LOSE IMPORTANT
FUNDING.
SUPPORT PROVIDED BY THE FARMING
INDUSTRY MANY JOBS IN THE STATES
WHERE FARMING OCCURS WILL BE
SEVERELY THREATEN AS WELL AS THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF THOSE
FARMS.
RETAIL JOBS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
BE THREATEN PLUS TAX INCOME.
IMPORTANT SOURCES OF RESEARCH
FOR BOTH CROCODILIAN AND HUMAN
HEALTH A LIGHT ON WILL BE EITHER
LOST OR NEGATIVELY IMPACTED.
FINALLY THE ANALYSIS FOR A. B.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN POINTS OUT THE
NEED FOR A SUNSET.
VERSES A TOTAL ELIMINATION OF
THE CURRENT BAN.
AS RECENTLY AMENDED A. B. FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN DOES JUST THAT.
AND I WILL.
RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT THIS FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
TODAY WITH ME.
IS THE PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL.
THE GOOD SENATOR CABALLERO.
AS WELL AS DOCTOR GRAHAM WEBB.
DIRECTOR OF WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
INTERNATIONAL IN A WORLD
RENOWNED EXPERT IN THE
CONSERVATION OF CROCODILIAN THIS
AND DIRECTOR OF WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT INTERNATIONAL AND
DOCTOR HAVEA.
NEVER AS VETERINARIAN FOR THE
STATE OF LOUISIANA'S DEPARTMENT
OF WILDLIFE AND FISHERIES.
SIR CABALLERO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN AND
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS TRULY A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
IN EXPLORING THE ISSUE I WAS
PERSUADED BY IMPORTANT FACTS
RELATING TO THE AMAZING RECOVERY
OF ALLIGATORS IN THE UNITED
STATES ESPECIALLY IN THE STATE
OF LOUISIANA WHERE A MAJORITY OF
THE FARMING OCCURS.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES THE
STATE OF LOUISIANA ESTABLISHED A
PROGRAM REGULATING THE FARMING
OF ALLIGATORS IN AN EFFORT TO
SAVE.
AND MAINTAIN WETLAND HABITAT FOR
THE ALLIGATORS THAT PROGRAM HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SURVEY BY THE
STATE OF LOUISIANA ESTIMATED
THAT THERE WERE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND ALLIGATOR NESTS IN THE
WILD HE SIX HUNDRED AND 50%
INCREASE SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE THAT WAS A
SURVEY THAT ESTIMATED THE WHILE
POPULATION TO BE AT ALMOST TWO
AT TWO MILLION AND IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE REGULATED
FARMING PROGRAM RESULTED IN
FORTY NINE THOUSAND ALLIGATORS
BEING RETURNED TO THE WILD.
THE ABOVE NUMBERS POINT TO A
VERY SUCCESSFUL SUCCESSFUL
GOVERNMENT PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERSHIP IT IS HELP THE
SPECIES NOT ONLY. TO SURVIVE TO
FLOURISH AND FAILURE TO PASS
THIS BILL WILL CLEARLY RESULT IN
A THREAT TO THAT PARTNERSHIP BY
IMPACTING THE ABILITY OF THE
FARMS TO SURVIVE ECONOMICALLY.
IT'S ALSO KEY TO NOTE HOW
IMPORTANT ALLIGATORS HAVE BECOME
FOR HUMAN MEDICAL RESEARCH THERE
ARE A VARIETY OF REASONS FOR
THAT DEVELOPMENT.
FIRST ALLIGATORS HAVE A NATURAL
DEFENSE AGAINST BOTH CANCER AND
BACTERIAL GROWTH.
SECOND THEY ALSO HAVE IMPORTANT
BIOLOGICAL TRAITS THAT CAN SHED
LIGHT ON WAYS TO HELP HUMAN
TREAT HUMAN CONDITIONS.
AND THIRD ALLIGATORS ARE AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF HIDE HI HI
EL HYALURONIC ACID YOU'VE ALL
HEARD THAT ON TV RIGHT -- A
COMPOUND THE GREATLY ENHANCES
THE HEALING OF WOUNDS YOUMANS.
HUNDREDS OF UNIVERSITIES AROUND
THE WORLD INCLUDING MANY RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE USING
ALLIGATORS IN HUMAN MEDICAL
RESEARCH SEARCH. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
A BI FIVE TWENTY SEVEN AND AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND SO WE HAVE.
TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE ORDER EITHER
OKAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JOE LAYING
REPRESENTING PEACH.
WHICH IS PROTECTING ENVIRONMENTS.
ANIMALS COMMUNITIES AND HABITATS
REAL QUICKLY WE HAVE TWO
WONDERFUL EXPERTS HERE AND THEN
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I WOULD
SPEAK FOR THIRTY SECONDS.
ON THE RESEARCH EFFORT THAT THE
CENTER CUBBY -- JUST OUTLINED
OKAY [inaudible]
GOOD.
PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS IS.
CRIME WAVE AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE BANG I WILL TO TESTIFY AND
ALSO FOR THE BILL'S SPONSORS
THIS IS REALLY AN IMPORTANT BILL
FROM A CONSERVATION POINT OF
VIEW.
I AM HERE FROM NORTHERN IN
CHARLOTTE BUT REPRESENTING.
THE STRUGGLE SPECIALIST GROUP OF
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION FOR THE
CONSERVATION OF NATURE -- THE
CORAL SPECIAL SCRIPT WHICH I
CHAIR HAS SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR MEMBERS FROM SIXTY FOUR
COUNTRIES.
AND WE ARE DEALING WITH CRIMINAL
CONSERVATION ISSUES JUST AROUND
THE WORLD ALL THE TIME AND EVERY
DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
THE IMPERSONAL QUALIFICATION
I'VE GOT A PHD DAYS SAY OF
WRITTEN.
I HAVE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SCIENTIFIC PAPERS AND QUITE
DEFINITIVE BOOKS ON CALL AT ALL
AN ALLIGATOR MANAGEMENT.
I'D LIKE TO POINT A AT THE
CALIFORNIA ROLLED OUT DOESN'T
HAVE A RESIDENT POPULATION OF
CROCODILES HAS PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE.
INCREMENTAL CONSERVATION IN THE
SIXTIES WHEN IT.
IT WAS NOT A LEGISLATION WILL
WHITE A BIT CROWDED HOUSE IT WAS
LIKE ASTRIDE A ONE OF THE ONLY
COUNTRIES TO BAN TRIED.
AS A MECHANISM.
FOR GETTING THINGS IN CONTROL.
THAT IS CONTROLS TIME THEY CAME
WITH THE CONVENTION ON
INTERNATIONAL TRADE IN
ENDANGERED SPECIES WHICH CAME
INTO FORCE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS
WHAT EVERYONE WAS HOPING FOR
FINALLY THEY BE INTERNATIONAL
CONTROL.
SINCE SAUDIS TIMING TO BANG BUT
ALSO -- IN MANY COUNTRIES JUST
BLOSSOMED UNDER.
WHY IS MANAGEMENT?
AND THERE AND NOW.
EXAMPLES NOT JUST IN LOUISIANA
WHICH IS ONE OF THE CLASSIC
EXAMPLES IN MANY OTHER COUNTRIES
IN A I'M COUNTRY.
THE CROWD -- POPULATIONS OF
GONNA TWENTY TIMES IN ABUNDANCE
A HUNDRED TIMES IN BY A MASH.
AND THE EAST AND THE PUBLIC IS
PUTTING UP WITH THEM WHICH IS
BIZARRE BECAUSE THEY GET TWICE
THE SIZE OF ALLIGATORS.
THEY WAY YOU SIX MADE IS A LONG
WAY TIME.
AND EIGHT PEOPLE EVERY TIME THEY
GET AN OPPORTUNITY YET THE
PUBLIC LIKES AND BECAUSE THEY
WELL MANAGED EVERYONE IS
BENEFITING INCLUDING INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE [inaudible]
AND SO.
I GUESS THE ONE THING THAT WE
WANT THE WORLD TO SLANT DURING
THIS PERIOD.
IS THAT.
TRIED.
REGULAR IS HIGHLY REGULATED
TONIGHT IT'S REGULATED IT ALSO
TO TEASE ILLEGAL TRIED IS AT THE
LOWEST LEVEL TO DAVE OF THE
LEGAL TRIED IS REPLACE THE LEGAL
TRIED.
AND THIS IS A WIN WIN SITUATION.
AND PUTTING.
THE MAKE SUNSET IN CLOSE IS THE
PERFECT -- AND RESPONSIBLE --
WAY TO HELP CONSERVATION THE
LIVELIHOODS OF PEOPLE IN MY
OPINION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ON VIRUS
I'M I PROFESSIONALS ILLEGAL
MEDICINE A LOUISIANA STATE
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF THE TERM
MEDICINE I'M A VETERINARIAN I
ALSO HAVE A PHD IN THE TURNER
SCIENCES -- I AM A DIPLOMAT OF
BOTH THE AMERICAN AND THE
EUROPEAN COLLEGE AS A LOCAL
MEDICINE -- WITH A SPECIALTY IN
REPTILE MEDICINE I'M FOR THE
LAST EIGHTEEN YEARS -- I HAVE
BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING
THE RESEARCH OP PROGRAM AS WELL
AS A VETERINARY CARE PROGRAM OF
THE ALLIGATOR INDUSTRY -- IN
LUCIANA.
DURING THIS TIME WE HAVE --
CREATE A BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES ARE GUIDELINES THAT
ESTABLISH DAY HUMANE CARE ON
WELFARE OF THE ANIMALS IN
CAPTIVITY OUR ANTI FOG THE
AMERICAN THE TERM MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OF EVEN ABOUT THAT
SOME OF OUR GUIDELINES. FOR SOME
OF THEIR OWN GUIDELINES WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR ALLIGATORS AND
GROUP OF DEALINGS -- WE HAVE A
VERY ACTIVE ONGOING --
SCIENTIFIC A RESEARCH PROGRAM ON
THE LOOK NOT ONLY AT THE HEALTH
OF THE CAPITAL TO GET US IN THE
FARMS BUT ALSO WHILE POPULATIONS
ALLIGATORS.
AND YOU KNOW THE 10% OF
ALLIGATORS ARE BEING RELEASED
BACK TO THE WILD EVERY YEAR I'M
NOT 10% IS A BIG PART OF WHAT
HELPS -- THEY WHILE POPULATIONS
REBOUND -- TO THE RECORD NUMBER
SO WE HAVE BEEN TO A WELL OVER
TO MILLIONS -- WE HAVE A VERY
VERY HEALTHY RIPOFF STABLE --
YOU KNOW POPULATION A WHILE THE
GATORS IS A VERY STABLE NATURAL
RENEWABLE RESOURCE -- THAT WE
WORK WITH -- I'M THROUGH
COLLABORATIONS WITH WITH SOME OF
THE FROM A LOT OF FROM FISHERIES
ALICE YOU THE UNIVERSITY FINALLY
GET A FARMERS WE HAVE AN ON
PRESIDENT THE COLLABORATION OF
INDUSTRY AND THE FROM STATE
AGENCIES WORKING TOGETHER
TOWARDS A COMMON GOAL -- I'M
THIS HAS BEEN -- RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR SUCCESS ALI GET A FARM IS
DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
EXCESS OF ALLIGATORS -- I'M ON
THE REBOUND THEY HAD IN NATURE --
THERE'S PLENTY OF EVIDENCE OUT
THERE -- TO SUPPORT THAT A
SUGGESTS THAT -- AND AGAIN THE
NUMBER THAT.
ARE GETTING AT THE END OF OUR
SOME HERE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU MISTER LANG IF AT ALL
AND TOLD YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN REAL
QUICKLY IS BOTH AUTHORS HAVE
NOTED -- MEDICAL RESEARCH HAS
FOUND SOME REALLY AMAZING
DISCOVERIES RULING TAG
ALLIGATORS.
NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF THEIR
RESISTANCE TO CANCER AND
BACTERIA BUT ALSO THEIR ABILITY
TO REGENERATE TISSUE GROWTH AN
ORGAN GROWTH.
WHY IS THIS A BILL IMPORTANT TO
THAT MEDICAL RESEARCH?
BECAUSE IT'S THE LEGITIMATE
FARMING OPERATIONS AND THAT
WILDLIFE REFUGES THAT THEY
SUPPORT THAT PROVIDE BOTH THE
ALLIGATOR EGGS AND THE ALLIGATOR
SPECIMENS FOR THAT RESEARCH.
MINUS THE COMMERCIAL APPLICATION.
THE PRICE OF ALLIGATOR SPECIMENS
TO USE IN THAT RESEARCH WOULD
LIKELY INCREASED DRAMATICALLY
AND IN ALL THIS SPEAK QUICKLY
ABOUT MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES YOU KNOW I'M
INVOLVED IN RESEARCH. TO FIND A
CURE FOR MY DAUGHTER'S GENETIC
MUTATION.
IN THAT RESEARCH WE HAVE TO USE
LABORATORY MICE.
THERE IS NO COMMERCIAL OPERATION
SUPPORTING THE RAISING OF MICE
AS A RESULT WERE WERE LIMITED TO
BUYING THOSE MICE FROM
LABORATORIES THAT RAISE THE MICE
SPECIFICALLY FOR RESEARCH.
AND THE COST ORIGINALLY WAS
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MOUSE THAT THAT GIVES YOU THE
SENSE OF WITHOUT THE COMMERCIAL
APPLICATION OF THE FARMS.
THE SOURCE FOR THE REAGENTS FOR
THIS TYPE OF RESEARCH WOULD BE
VERY VERY EXPENSIVE -- FINAL
POINT IN TALKING WITH SOME OF
THE MMBERS.
THERE HAS BEEN A QUESTION RELIEF
REGARDING THIS BILL RELATIVE TO
HOW DO WE ASSURE DURING THIS TEN
YEAR EXTENSION.
THAT IN FACT THE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE IMPORTED INTO CALIFORNIA ARE
ONLY THOSE THAT RESULT FROM
LEGAL TRADE THAT'S COMPLIANCE
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL TREATY --
WE ARE OPEN TO DISCUSSING THAT --
ME IN CLEARLY WITH THE CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS IF THAT BE IF THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT MOMENT.
WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE AUTHORS
WE WOULD BE OPEN TO ACCEPTING
THAT AS A WAY TO ASSURE DURING
THIS TEN YEAR PERIOD THAT.
THE ONLY PRODUCTS THAT COME IN
ARE THOSE THAT ARE COMPLIANT
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL TREAT.
I THANK YOU MISTER LAYING IN A
APPRECIATE THAT IT'S NHà
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR PERSONAL.
CONNECTION TO THIS AS WELL I
THINK IS IMPORTANT IN.
AND HOW THIS IS HELPING WITH
WITH MEDICAL RESEARCH AS WELL.
THE OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
THIS BILLS.
BASED ON SOUND SCIENCE IN THE
STATE OR YOU GONNA USE OF THE
RESOURCE AND IT ALSO HAS GOOD
WETLAND HABITAT BENEFITS SO WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MATT GRAY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF LOUISIANA
DEPARTMENT OF WILDLIFE AND
FISHERIESTHE SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SHE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL OF IRAQ
RIGHT CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION MANY OF OUR ACADEMIC
AND RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS RELY
ON THIS SOURCE -- TO DEVELOP
SOME OF THE THERAPIES THAT
THEY'RE CREATING SOME INSTRUCTS
PORT THANK YOU.
IN THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN IF YOU'D
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND OVER ON BEHALF
OF THEIR HEARING ALL HIGH AND WE
MAKE THE VACCINE FOR WEST NILE
FOR ALLIGATORS AND CROCODILES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PLEASE COME ON
UP.
SURE [inaudible]
PRESIDENT.
YEAH GO AHEAD AND LET'S CLEAR
THE TABLE HERE IS WE HAVE ENOUGH
ROOM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING.
I'M JUDY MAY INCLUDE SO FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA BANNED THE SALE OF
ALLIGATOR CROCODILE BACK IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOR THE NEXT
THIRTY SIX YEARS THAT WAS GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA BUT THEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX THE STATE OF
LOUISIANA GOT A TEMPORARY
EXEMPTION SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER.
THAT EXEMPTION WOULD LAST UNTIL
JANUARY TWENTY TEN THEN
LOUISIANA CAME BACK TO
CALIFORNIA AGAIN I GOT AN
EXTENSION FOR THEIR EXEMPTION
AND TELL THIS COMING JANUARY.
AND HERE THEY ARE AGAIN TRYING
TO INFLUENCE OUR LEGISLATURE FOR
THEIR SPECIAL INTERESTS.
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO REPRESENT
THE SUPERMAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WANT OUR LAWS
OF HELD.
AN INDEPENDENT POLL EARLIER THIS
YEAR SHOWED THAT WHEN
CALIFORNIANS WERE ASKED IF THEY
WOULD SUPPORT A BAN ON IMPORTING
EXPORTING ARE SELLING AN EXOTIC
HEIGHTS AND PRODUCTS MADE FROM
ANIMALS. 75% SAID YES AND FOR
THOSE OF INTEREST DEMOCRATS
VOTED EIGHTY TWO POINT FIVE NO
PARTY PREFERENCE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT EIGHT AND REPUBLICANS AT
FIFTY EIGHT POINT.
SEVEN SO PLEASE JOIN US VOTE NO
ON THE VOEPEL BILL AND YES ON
THE MAIN SHOWING BILL COMING UP
NEXT.
GOVERNOR'S WHAT SCHWARZENEGGER
FELL SHORT OF CALIFORNIANS
COMPASSION FOR ANIMALS MY GROUP
SPONSORED A BILL IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE CARRY BY PEDRO NAVA.
THAT WOULD HAVE CLAMPED DOWN ON
PUPPY MILLS SCHWARZENEGGER
VETOED IT LATER IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE DID A BILL THAT
EVEN WENT FURTHER WHAT PATRICK
O'DONNELL THAT KICKED PUPPY
MILLS OUT OF PET SHOPS.
AND NOT ONLY WAS IT SUPPORT IT
WOULD BIPARTISAN VOTES AND
SIGNED INTO LAW IT HAS SINCE
BEEN CELEBRATED AND COPIED
AROUND THE GLOBE LAST YEAR WE
PROVE ONCE AGAIN WE'RE
CALIFORNIA AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD WANTS TO BE ON PROTECTING
ANIMALS.
BY GETTING SENATOR GALGIANI IS
BILLS OF SIGNED INTO LAW THE
CALIFORNIA CRUELTY FREE
COSMETICS ACT.
THAT IS NOW GLOBAL LANDMARK
LOUISIANA'S TIME IS UP PLEASE
HELP US TO DEFEND AND RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC
PROTECTIONS FOR THESE AND HOLES
AND SAY NO TO THIS EXTENSION AND
YES TO OUR EXISTING LAWS.
THANK YOU.
THIS MORNING MY NAME IS HANNAH
SHINE I'M THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
INVESTIGATIONS FOR PEOPLE FOR
THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF ANIMALS.
WHICH HAS OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR AFFILIATES HAVE
INVESTIGATED ALLIGATOR CROCODILE
FARMS ON THREE CONTINENTS.
I PERSONALLY TRAVEL TO ZIMBABWE
TO DOCUMENT FIRSTHAND THE
CONDITIONS AT TWO MASSIVE
CROCODILE COMPLEXES.
I ALSO HELP DIRECT AN
INVESTIGATION AND AN ALLIGATOR
MILL IN TEXAS WHERE ONE OF OUR
FIELD OBSERVERS WORKED.
PETER ASIA I WITNESSES VISITED
MULTIPLE CROCODILE OPERATIONS IN
VIETNAM.
THESE WERE ALL MAJOR FACILITIES
THAT SUPPLIED SKINS FOR BRANDS
LIKE OUR MEN'S AND LOUIS VUITTON.
EACH FACILITY CONFINED ANIMALS
IN GRAHAM BARREN AND TOTALLY
UNNATURAL CONDITIONS.
IN VIETNAM AND MANY CROCODILES
LANGUISH IN CELL SMALLER THAN
THE LENGTH OF THEIR BODIES.
THE OPERATION IN TEXAS KEPT
ALLIGATORS AND DARK WAREHOUSES
IN PITS OF PUTRID WATER THAT
REEKED OF RANCID EXCREMENT.
OUR OBSERVER STRUGGLED NOT TO
VOMIT AS HE STOOD THIGH DEEP IN
THE MURKY CESSPOOLS FEELING
AROUND FOR YOUNG ALLIGATORS TO
PICK UP.
WORKERS THERE WERE SUPPOSED TO
SHOOT THE ALLIGATORS IN THE
SCHOOL WITH A CAPITAL CAPTIVE
BOLT GUN TO RENDER THEM
INSENSIBLE BEFORE SIGHING INTO
THEM WITH BOX CUTTERS.
BUT DURING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
SLAUGHTERS THIS WAS NOT DONE.
AND THEY CUT INTO ALLIGATORS
NEXT AND SHOVED A ROD UP THEIR
SPINAL COLUMNS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
PATH OR SCRAMBLE THEIR BRAINS.
THE MANAGER HIMSELF STAB FOR
CONSCIOUS ALLIGATORS WITH A
KNIFE TO DISLOCATE THEIR
CERVICAL VERTEBRAE AS THE
SUFFERING ANIMALS FAILED AND
STRUGGLED.
IN VIETNAM WORKERS ELECTROSHOCK
CROCODILES IN ORDER TO
IMMOBILIZE THEM.
PACKED INTO THEIR NECKS AND
RAMROD'S DOWN THEIR SPINES.
NOT EVEN ATTEMPTING TO DESTROY
THEIR BRAINS FIRST REPTILE
EXPERT CLIFFORD WARRICK HAS
STATED THAT THESE METHODS CAUSE
SEVERE STRESS.
TRAUMA AND PAIN.
CROCKETT ALIENS ARE RESILIENT
INTELLIGENT ANIMALS WHO SUFFER
IMMENSELY WHEN THEY'RE CONFINED
MISHANDLED AND SLAUGHTERED
PLEASE DO NOT ALLOW THE TRADE OF
THEIR SKINS AND REJECT AB FIVE
TO SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISS VERY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE WHICH ALONG WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND OUR DC IN THE SIERRA CLUB
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THERE ARE MORE
THAN TWENTY SPECIES OF
ALLIGATORS CROCODILES CAME IN
SYNC AERIALS PROTECTED UNDER
SITE EASE THE CONVENTION ON
INTERNATIONAL TRADE IN
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
THE PROTECTED EXPLICITLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE THREATENED BY ILLEGAL
TRADE THE SPECIES ARE ALSO IN
DECLINED THREATENED BY EXTREME
HABITAT LOSS AND OVER
EXPLOITATION.
CODE SIX FIFTY THREE OH IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S DO NOT CONTRIBUTE
TO THE SEXPLOITATION OF THESE
IMPERIL WILD ANIMALS THROUGH
TRADE.
AND WE BELIEVE AB FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN WHEN UNDERMINE THAT POLICY.
OWN AND SAY THIS CHANGE ALLIES
ACCEPTABLE BECAUSE IT WOULD ONLY
ALLOW FOR THE COMMERCIAL SALE OF
FARM ANIMAL PARTS AND SKINS.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PRODUCTS MADE
FROM FARM TO WILD CAUGHT ANIMALS
THE ANALYSIS INDEED QUOTES IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN USING US
FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE RULING
THAT STATED QUOTE.
SMALL PARTS AND PRODUCTS OF
CROCODILIAN LEATHER ARE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DISTINGUISH MADE
INTO GOODS THAT'S HAMPERING THE
IDENTIFICATION OF LEGAL
ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS FROM THOSE OF
ENDANGERED OR THREATENED POCKET
ALIENS PROBLEMS WITH
IDENTIFICATION COULD INCREASE
ILLEGAL TRADE IN ENDANGERED
CROCODILIAN PRODUCTS AND QUOTE.
MENTION ALSO THAT AB NINETY SIX
CALIFORNIAS IVORY AND RHINO --
BAND PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITED THE SALE OF TASKS AND
TEETH FROM OTHER SPECIES OTHER
THAN ELEPHANTS WALRUSES HIPPOS
OTHER SPECIES BECAUSE THE LOOK
ALIKES BECAUSE ENFORCEMENT
CHALLENGES ON OUR COVER FOR THE
ILLEGAL TRADE.
A NEW ANALYSIS FROM DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE OF WILDLIFE SHIPMENTS
COMING FROM LATIN AMERICA SEIZED
BY THE UNITED STATES OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS REVEALS A
TRAFFICKING IMPACT OF
TRAFFICKING CRISIS IMPACTING
CROCODILES.
AND THE NEED TO STEP UP
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THE TRADE IN
THEIR PARTS THE ANALYSIS FOUND
THAT CERTAIN SORRY EXCUSE ME
THAT CAME IN A CROCODILE SKINS
ARE AMONG THE MOST COMMONLY
SEIZE ITEMS.
AND WE'RE TWO OF THE FIVE MOST
ILLEGALLY TRADED ANIMALS ANOTHER
TEN YEAR EXTENSION IN THE SALE
OF FARMS PARTS SUGGEST THAT WE
BELIEVE THE CRISIS AND ILLEGAL
WILDLIFE TRADE THAT IS FUELING
THE EXTINCTION OF THE SPECIES IN
THE WILD WORLDWIDE.
HAS BEEN ADDRESSED IT HAS NOT IF
ANYTHING
CALIFORNIA-DRIVERS-PAY-UNDERFUNDED-STATE-PATROL-PENION
ARGUMENTS WERE MADE IN FAVOR OF
THAT LEGISLATION HERE WE HAVE
SERIOUS EVIDENCE OF A THREAT TO
THE VERY EXISTENCE OF SPECIES
THAT ASSOCIATED WITH THESE FARM
REPTILES TO BE SLAUGHTERED IN
MADE INTO LUXURY PRODUCTS.
IF THERE IS INDEED SOMEONE THEY
MEDICAL BREAKTHROUGH THAT
RESULTS IN AN FDA LICENSED
PHARMACEUTICAL THEN A BILL COULD
SEEK TO NEARLY ADDRESS THAT.
IF YOU CAN VOTE TO PART MAMMALS
FROM BEING TURNED INTO FOR
PRODUCTS YOU CAN VOTE TO PROTECT
CROCODILES AND ALLIGATORS FROM
BEING TURNED INTO WALLETS AND
SHOES.
AND PROTECT THEIR EXTINCT AGAIN
SIR EXTINCTION IN THE WILD OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU ARE
HANDLED BOTH SIDES THERE BUT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO KEEP ON TRACK
GUYS HERE.
SO OTHER WITNESSES IN PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
THE CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE AB
FIVE TO SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PERFECT.
HI MY NAME IS STACY SANDERS FROM
GRASS VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE AB.
FIVE TO SEVEN I'M JENNY KEATING
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL AND I SUPPORT
THE STATEMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUES -- REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND PIZZA
THANK YOU.
I'M KAREN GARCIA FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
EIGHTY FIVE TO SEVEN WHEN THE
BRAMBLE SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICELESS
OPPOSE THIS.
BILL.
ASHLEY LEWIS ON BEHALF OF PIZZA
AND ARE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ELSE RETURN
CALIFORNIA IN BEHALF OF
COMPASSIONATE BAY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
DEBBIE MEREDITH SUCK ONE OF
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG EL CERRITO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE IN OUR MANY
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
WE OPPOSE.
IN THE MIDDLE FOURTH I'M HERE
FOR SECOND A VEGAN SOCIETY WAS
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS I'M HERE
FOR PIZZA.
IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND POP
BACK.
YOUR GARCIA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JACOBY MARINO SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
GENOMIC PRIDE RANCHO CORDOVA.
WITH CONNECTION AFRICA WITH.
IN CONNECTION WITH WE STRONGLY
OPPOSES
TERRY LEAVES OUT THE CALIFORNIA
OPPOSITION.
MARGARET KIRKPATRICK TURKEY
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DONNA ANNE SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
PIZZA MEMBER OPPOSE.
SUSAN KIRKPATRICK I POSES BILL.
KAREN LAFFEY LARKSPUR CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FIVE TO SEVEN FREE THERE ARE
THREE GUYS FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA YOU'LL BOTH THIS BILL.
ERIN HELGI WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FUNDED TOMLINSON PROJECT KOTV
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF WILDLIFE
REHABILITATED OPPOSE THE SPELL.
CRYSTAL MARLON ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERSHIP OF CAROL MISSILE DIE
ON BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY
LEGISLATIVE FUND OPPOSE.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE.
SUSAN SIDNEY DENT FRANKLIN
VILLAGE OPPOSING THE BILL.
HOPO HANNEKE ELK GROVE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THANK
YOU.
DEBORAH CLAUSON ABOUT A
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED.
MELISSA FROM DAVIS CALIFORNIA.
DISTRICT LEADER OF THE HUMANE
SOCIETY AND I OPPOSE.
LILY KIRBY HUMANE SOCIETY I
FROM DAVIS CALIFORNIA.
MARIE O'DONNELL FROM GRASS
VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
TERRI BARNATO COLFAX CALIFORNIA
AYE OPPOSED.
BRIAN A CREE FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL FROM JANE ON
CHAIN NEWS NETWORK WE STRONGLY
IT SHOULDN'T EDITORIAL IN
OPPOSITION.
K. CYBER URINE TO CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
BRENDA KERRY DAVIS CALIFORNIA I
OPPOSE THIS BILL STRONGLY.
PATRICIA EASILY MEADOW VISTA
OPPOSE.
JANET CURVAS SAID DAVIS
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED.
SHERIN MONTU FAVORS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
SAYS IN MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY -- BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SO.
BEFORE WE GET TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS IS IT APPEARS THAT WE
HAVE AN AMENDMENT.
BEING PROPOSED BY THE AUTHOR IS
THAT CORRECT.
YEAH SO I'M I'M.
IT IS SO THE COMMITTEE KNOWS I
THINK YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF IT
THERE'S A PROPOSED AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD ADD PRODUCTS SOLD IN
THIS STATE PRIOR TO THE
PROHIBITION CONTAINED IN THIS
SUBDIVISION WHICH ARE MADE OF
WHOLLY OR IN PART FROM
ALLIGATORS ACROSS IT AS SHALL BE
ACCOMPANIED BY A DISCLOSURE THAT
READS AS FOLLOWS THIS PRODUCT
WAS MADE USING MATERIALS SOURCED
IN FULL COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE PROVISION OF THE
CONVENTION ON INTERNATIONAL
TRADE IN ENDANGERED SPECIES.
SO THAT IS WHAT THE AUTHOR IS
PROPOSING AS A MEMBER OBVIOUSLY
WE WOULD HAVE.
HE OF THERE HAVE TO BE IN A MAN --
PROPOSED MOVE AS AMENDED -- TO
PASS THAT BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID ALL.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
YES.
MR BIGELOW.
YEAH -- WELL LET'S LET'S TAKE
THAT ON FIRST WHAT IS SOCIETIES
AND FIRST EXPLAIN THAT TO US --
AND THE SECOND PART WOULD BE.
HOW IS SOCIETY'S HELP THE
POPULATION WORLDWIDE?
MAYBE YOUR EXPERTS IN THAT FIELD
COULD.
HELP.
US UNDERSTAND THAT.
REQUEST PERMISSION TO BRING ON
EXPERTS YEAH YEAH ABSOLUTELY.
COME FORWARD SIR.
DOCTOR I FORGET YOUR LAST NAME
MELISSA.
DR WEB YES GO AHEAD [inaudible]
BUT IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES AND
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND INTO THE
NINE NINE SIXTY NINE OH FORTY K.
TO BEG CROCODILES AND I WOULD.
JUST HANDED IS A RESOURCE THAT
NOBODY CARED A BIT.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES IT
BECAME APPARENT THAT THE HEAD TO
CHALLENGE THE ARE YOU SEE AN LED
THE CHARGING THIS.
IT DROPPED THE DICK AN
INTERNATIONAL CONVENTION ON
TRIED. TO CONTROL TRIED.
IN SOME OF THE SPECIES THAT WERE.
IN TRIED BUT NOBODY CARED A BIT
THAT EVENTUALLY LED.
TO THE SAUDIS CONVENTION THE
TEXT WAS AGREED IN WASHINGTON
AND NINE SEVENTY THREE IT CAME
INTO FORCE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IT HAS A
HUNDRED NINETY THREE PARTIES.
AND HAS A A VERY COMPLEX SO.
TO SYSTEM WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITIES INVESTED IN THE
PARTIES THEY ALL HAVE TO HAVE A
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN A
SCIENTIFIC AUTHORITY.
WHENEVER THERE'S AN EXPORT BY
HALF THE ISSUE.
NOT AYE ME AN EXPORT PAYMENT.
BUT A DECLARATION THAT IT'S NOT
DETRIMENTAL TO THE SURVIVAL OF
THE SPECIES IN THE WILD.
SELECT COMES A OUT FROM THE
EXPORTING COUNTRY IN THE USUALLY
THE IMPORTING COMPANY.
HAS TO ISSUE AN IMPORT PERMIT
INDICATED SATISFIED SAY THERE'S
SOME INCREDIBLY KEYS OF
LEGISLATION.
THE ANY OTHER THING WHICH TODAY
IS FOR PERSONAL PRODUCTS IF YOU
GOT A WALLET OR BUILT.
MATCH COUNTRIES AGREED TO THE
PERSONAL PRODUCTS RESOLUTION
WHERE LED TO HAVE FULL PRODUCTS
SHE KNEW PERSONAL THE TO CARRY
YOU CANNOT SEND THEM YOU CAN
CARRY WITH THEM.
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE
TREATY AND EXPLAINED
UNBELIEVABLY SUCCESSFUL WILL ONE
THANK YOU MISTER REGULARLY OF
SOME ADDITIONAL QUESTIONING I DO --
SO.
ELABORATE ON HOW.
SITE EASE HAS HELPED THE
POPULATION AS A WHOLE WORLDWIDE.
WITH CURRENT ALSO WHAT HAPPENED
IS THE WHEN MAD DEPLETED.
A LOT OF PEOPLE VERY HAPPY
ESPECIALLY WITH THE BIG BIG
SPACIOUS.
BECAUSE THEY VERY DIETERS TO
LIVE WITH AS THE CROW STARTED TO
RECOVER.
AND STARTED TO ATTACK PEOPLE IN
A TACKLE OF STOCK AND AND THE
THE SIRIUS PREDATORS THE CHANGE
SHOULD EITHER THEY THEY THEY
DON'T.
NOT THE OLD THING IT SURELY THE
NATURE.
THE USE PROGRAMS WERE BROUGHT IN
TONIGHT.
SOME OF THOSE ANIMALS VALUABLE
TO THE PLATE LIVE AFTER LEAVE
WITHIN SAID IT.
AND IT'S BEEN AN UNBELIEVABLE
SUCCESS STORY IT'S COUNTER
INTUITIVE TO SOME PEOPLE.
THE USE OF AN ANIMAL GIVES
PAVILION CHANGES TO TOLERATED MY
PUT UP WITH A BIT.
EL POPULATION THE ALLIGATOR
POPULATION THEY'VE GONE UP.
TWENTY TIMES IN ABUNDANCE AND A
HUNDRED TIMES IN BY MANAGED TO
SIGN TIME TIGERS OF GONE DOWN.
ANOTHER 50%.
IT IT'S JUST PEOPLE.
IN MANY COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
AND ECONOMIC INCENTIVE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT THING SO I ON THE
NUMBERS IN AUSTRALIA.
THE NUMBERS IN AND TRY TO WIN
FROM CHIMING IN IN THE NORTHERN
CHARACTER ON FROM WENT FOR IRAN
STREET SAY HOURS AND TWO HUNDRED
SALES IN ANIMALS AND THE BOY AND
MANAGE THE THREE THOUSAND A LOT
OF THEM LITTLE SMALL ANIMALS
THERE'S A LITTLE GROUP OF ADULTS.
HAVING BABIES THAT POPULATION IS
NOW BACK AT CARRYING CAPACITY IN
A DEVELOPED COUNTRY WITH THESE
ANIMALS.
IF IF IF YOU GUYS SWIMMING IN
THE RIVER NEXT TO WHERE I LIVE.
YOU'LL BE KILLED 1100% IT'S A
MATTER WHETHER IT HAPPENS IN
FIVE MINUTES TEN MINUTES YOU'LL
NEVER GET THE FIFTEEN DAYS OF
THAT VERY DIFFICULT ANIMALS TO
DEAL WITH THAT SO IS ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND NOW.
AND THEN IN LOUISIANA WHAT'S THE
REBOUND BEEN THREE BANDS BUT AT
THE SAME THING I HAD ABOUT A
HUNDRED SALES AND AT AT THE TIME
ST LOUIS CAME IN THAT DAY ABOUT
TWO MILLION OF IT TWENTY TIMES
INCREASE IN ABUNDANCE.
AND I WOULD SIGH I WOULD GUESS.
A SEVENTY OR 80% INCREASING BY
MAGIC NOT A 100%.
AND FLOOR THERE'S BEEN A SIMILAR
SITUATION ALSO FLOOR AND OTHERS
WELL OVER TWO MILLION NOW SO
IT'S NOT ONLY LUCIANA BUT THE
PROGRAMS ALSO IN FLORIDA ON SOME
OF THE OTHER STATES -- THIS ALL
THESE TWO MILLION IN FLORIDA AND
IN LOUISIANA YES SIR OKAY
[inaudible]
SO.
YOU WOULD SAY THAT ALLIGATOR
FARMS.
HAVE BEEN GOOD FOR THE
POPULATION.
SO LET ME ASK THE QUESTION --
ALLIGATORS AND CROCODILES
ENDANGERED.
SO THAT THERE ARE SOME SPECIES
THAT ARE IN DANGER HOWEVER -- A
LUMBER A LOT OF THEM ARE NOT
ENDANGERED ANYMORE.
THE ONLY REASON TO HAVE
RETAINING SOCIETIES IS BECAUSE
SCIENCE HEALTH REGULAR THE
COMMERCIAL TRAITS AS AN
ADDITIONAL STATE MEASURE -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE POPULATIONS
NEVER GO BACK TO THE OLD DAYS --
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE INSIDE IT
DOES NOT MEAN THEY'RE THREATENED
OR AND THEN YOUR WHAT SO EVER.
ALLIGATORS WERE THE LEAST THAT --
IN THE SEVENTIES THAT THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN IN DANGER -- ON A CAR
NOT ENDANGERED OR THREATENED.
SOTALK TO ME ABOUT THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT.
WHAT IS ENDANGERED WHAT IS
LISTED AS ENDANGERED CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT?
A BILL OR WHAT HAS BEEN DELISTED
OUR LEAD DRAMA DRESS ACCORDING.
TO THE WHAT CONSTITUTES AN IN
DYING COULD CROW IS ONE THAT THE
POPULATION IS PLAYING HARLEY
DEPLETED.
THE ONE CITY IN THE COMBINATIONS
OF COUNTRIES AND PRODUCTS THAT
ARE.
STILL CONSIDERED INDICTED.
I WON SAID USUALLY HAVE NO
COMMERCIAL VALUE AND DIED.
DâN APPEARING TRIED IT'LL NONE
OF THE TRIED AND SPECIES ARE
EARLY.
IN DYING FEED.
H. THAT'S THE CHALLENGE FOR US
IN THE CRIMINAL SPECIALIST
GREATLY CHARITY GET THE
INCENTIVES TO CONSERVE THE
SPECIES THAT.
ALL RIGHT SO I HAVE NOT A
COMMERCIAL VALUE THAT NOBODY'S
INTERESTED IN NINE OF THE INJURY
AS YOU'RE INTERESTED IN WRITING
ANY MONEY FOR THEM THEY THEY
THEY IT'S A COMMANDER IS CAN
UNDER MATT HEY I'LL BE A I'LL BE
A GET THE RESOURCES.
TO IT'S NOT THE ANIMALS THAT ARE
IN TRIED THAT ARE THE PROBLEM
[inaudible]
REGULAR [inaudible]
SO MAYBE.
NOT SURE IF THE AUTHORS ARE ARE.
THE BEST ANSWER THIS BUT MAYBE
I'LL.
DIRECTED TO YOU AND YOU CAN
FIGURE OUT WAS THE BEST.
WE SENT EXTENDED THE SUNSET AS
IT WAS OF THE SPOKEN ABOUT HERE.
AT TO WAIVE THE BAN ABOUT FOUR
YEARS AGO AND HERE WE ARE ONCE
AGAIN.
CAN SOMEBODY TELL US WHAT THE
IMPACT ON ALLIGATORS OR
CROCODILES HAS BEEN.
AND WHAT WOULD WHAT WE LEARNED.
CAN ANYONE TELL US WHAT HAVE WE
LEARNED.
SO ALL I CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
THAT SO -- SINCE THE LAST TIME
THAT THE SONGS THAT WAS PASSED --
AGAIN WE HAVE IT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE BEST PRACTICE MANAGEMENT. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE BEEN TRADE
AND HUMANE -- ON WELFARE -- OF
THE ANIMAL SYSTEMS BEEN LOOKED
AFTER -- THERE'S SLAUGHTER AND
EUTHANASIA GUIDELINES -- THE
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN THE
INDUSTRY ON A FIVE DAY AMERICAN
THE TERM MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HAS
INCLUDED SOME OF THOSE
GUIDELINES WITHIN SOME OF THEIR
OWN.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS -- THERE'S
ONGOING SCIENTIFIC STUDIES --
BYE BYE ALL USING THIS ON ON
FLORIDA THAT ADDRESSES THE WILD
POPULATIONS AS WELL AS DOING A
RESEARCH STUDY ON THE HEALTH OF
CAPTIVE ON WAS ON IT WAS OUR
BEEN RELEASED TO THE WALL RIGHT
NOW WE'RE CURRENTLY SOMETHING
THE FOR THE SEASON TO MAKE SURE
THAT I HAVE.
AND THE THINGS THEY CAN AFFECT
THE WALL POPULATION SOURCE MADE
A BIG PUSH FOR SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH AND DATA TO MAKE SURE
THE THAT A STATEMENT OR KNOW
THAT FROM THE WALL POPULATION
THE SITE IS NEEDS WHICH HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THERE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN APPROVED.
THAT CONTINUES TO BE THE SAME
WAY AND WE GOT IT ALL THE DATA
TO SUPPORT THAT.
THANK I THINK MISFIRING YOU ALSO
HAD A RESPONSE -- YEAH WHY DID I
KNOW -- WAS GOING TO SAY DID YOU
DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHORS DID YOU WANT TO RESPOND
TO THAT AT ALL.
AND IF NOT WE CAN GO TO MISS
HEARING.
OKAY MISS PERIOD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN I WOULD DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE ANALYSIS
WHICH I THINK SPECIFICALLY
STATES THE CURRENT STATE OF
AFFAIRS WITH RESPECT -- TO
GLOBALLY HOW THE SPECIES ARE
BEING HANDLED UNDER SADIE'S
TWENTY OF THE TWENTY THREE
SPECIES IN THE ORDER COCKATIEL
YES SEVEN ARE ENDANGERED AND FOR
OUR VULNERABLE ACCORDING TO THE
IUCN RED LIST WHICH ASSESSES
CONSERVATION STATUS OF SPECIES
AT A GLOBAL LEVEL -- I WOULD
ALSO POINT BACK AGAIN TO THE NEW
REPORT THAT WE JUST ISSUED
SHOWING ILLEGAL TRADE FROM LATIN
AMERICA IN SPITE OF SOCIETIES IN
SPITE OF PROTECTIONS WE ARE
STILL FINDING A HUGE ILLEGAL
WHILE LIVING TRAFFIC ILLEGAL
WILDLIFE TRAFFICKING NETWORK AND
THESE SPECIES ARE AMONG THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THAT.
OUR TRAFFIC ILLEGALLY SO THAT'S
IN VIOLATION OF CITIES AND OTHER
LAWS EIGHTY PER 86% OF THE CAME
IN ITEMS THAT WERE FOUND WERE
SOURCE FROM THE WILD. 96% OF THE
CROCODILE ITEMS ARE SOURCE FROM
THE WILD SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS A LEGAL THERE IS A
LEGAL COVER CREATED BY THE FARM
TRADE AND FARM ANIMALS IT WILL
CONTINUE TO DRIVE.
DEMAND FROM THOSE PRODUCTS FROM
ANIMALS THAT ARE IT RATE THAT
ARE IN THE WILD AND IT WILL
CONTINUE TO FOSTER THIS ILLEGAL
TRAFFICKING ACROSS THE GLOBE
WHICH IS THE THIRD LARGEST THE
LEGAL INDUSTRY.
AFTER GUNS AND DRUGS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THAT THE
LEGAL TRADE AND IN YOUR YOUR
FRIEND OF THE ILLEGAL TRADE BUT
THE LEGAL TRADE HAS LED TO THE
REBOUNDING OF THE SPECIES IN
AUSTRALIA IN THESE TWO STATES
RIGHT WERE INTERESTED ON HOW
THEY'RE DOING ON A GLOBAL LEVEL.
AND AGAIN WE BAND OVER MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS YOU HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT THOSE THEY HAVE
REBOUNDED IN FLORIDA LOUISIANA
AND AUSTRALIA CORRECT.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME I ADMIT THAT
THEY SET THE CLAIM THAT THAT'S
NOT THE SAME AS ALL THE NATIONAL
FIND A WORRY THEMSELVES ABOUT.
THE HOW ARE THE SPECIES ARE
FARING ON A GLOBAL LEVEL AND IT
IS IT IS IN THE INDISPUTABLE
THAT A TRADE IN AN ANIMAL
SPECIES WILL DRIVE THE TRADE IN
THAT SPECIES REGARDLESS OF
SOURCE.
SO IF WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THE SPECIES ARE DOING GLOBALLY
AND CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE TAKING
OUR SUNSET RESPONSIBILITIES
SERIOUSLY AND CHECKING IN ON
THIS.
WE WOULD SUBMIT THAT THIS IS A
BAD IDEA BECAUSE THERE IS
SHOCKING EVIDENCE THAT THESE
CONTINUES TO BE SPECIES THAT ARE
TRADED ILLEGALLY AROUND THE
GLOBE.
CAUSING THEIR PERIL ONE ONE READ
AND UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR POINT
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S OUT HARD FOR
YOU TO ADMIT IS THAT WHERE WE
HAVE HAD LEGAL TRADE THAT IN
THESE AREAS THE POPULATION HAS
REBOUNDED SIGNIFICANTLY THOSE
ARE THE FACTS.
MISTER KALRA.
NUMBER LOWERED OF FINISH UP WITH
COMMENTS SUGGEST YES MISTER
BIGELOW THANK YOU JUST ONE MORE
AND I DON'T KNOW IF VIDEO ONCE
AT THIS TABLE.
BUT COULD SOMEONE ADDRESS THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE ABOUT
THE GAINS IN TECHNOLOGY AND
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERY.
FROM THE ALLIGATORS AND
CROCODILES AS WE KNOW HOW.
THEY HAVE AN ODD AN IMMUNE
SYSTEM.
THAT DOES THAT.
REQUIRE MEDICINE.
THEY HEAL THEMSELVES.
CAN SOMEONE ADDRESS THE FACT OF
THE VALUE AND WHAT THAT
POTENTIALLY MEANS TO US IN
GAINES.
IN THEEND FOR THE HUMAN SOCIETY
WHAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
TRULY BENEFIT SINCE THE
CROCODILES ARE ON A RECOVERY.
THEY WERE ABLE TO CHAU
SUSTAINABILITY.
AND NOW HOW WE CAN USE
[inaudible]
SOME KNOWLEDGE TO ACTUALLY HEAL
OURSELVES MAYBE IN FIND CURES TO
THINGS THAT WE NEVER DREAMED UP.
I CAN ADDRESS THAT AUSTIN SO ON
THEIR SUCH AN EVENT TO GET ON
THE SANTA MARK MERSHON THE HOUSE
OF THE AMERICA THE WORK LOOKING
AT THE ANTI MICROBIAL PROPERTIES
OF THEIR BLOG -- THERE'S A
NUMBER OF THIS TOGETHER YOU MAY
JUST SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE
TO SAID THAT -- NUMBER
INVESTIGATORS IN THE STATE ONLY
SEE ANOTHER LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE -- YOU KNOW
BEING A MINOR SPACES HAS BEEN
RECENTLY THAT ALL THOSE AVENUES
HAVE BEEN LOOKED AT IN IN
ALLIGATORS -- THERE'S BEEN
SIMILAR RESEARCH CONDUCTED
SADDAM ON THE FOR EXAMPLE THEY
CAN REGENERATE LIMBS -- SO THE
DODD BIOMEDICAL RESEARCH THAT'S
CAUGHT IN ITS RESEARCH CUTTING
EDGE SCIENCE -- WE'RE IN THE
VERY VERY EARLY STAGES SO THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO GROW WITH THE
ALIENS RIGHT NOW -- THE
PRELIMINARY DATA IT'S EXTREMELY
PROMISING -- TO ANSWER A
QUESTION WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT WORK AND CONTINUE TO
OPEN AVENUES FOR THAT TO HAPPEN
SO WE DON'T HOLD BACK THAT
DIVIDE MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF MEDICINE TO WHICH
HE WANTS.
SO WHEN YOU'RE DOING THAT
RESEARCH YOU DON'T HAVE TO YOUTH
AND ICE THOSE ANIMALS DO YOU.
OUT FOR SOME OF THAT RESEARCH
YES BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO HARVEST
THE ORGANS OF THE EVENT ON THE
RESEARCH AND SOME OF THOSE
RESEARCH SITUATIONS THEY HAVE TO
HARVEST THE FRIEND CELLS FROM
THE ORGAN SO THEY HAD TO HAVE TO
BE EUTHANIZED.
IN SOME CASES IN SOME CASES IT
NOT ALL CASES NOT ALL CASES
CORRECT OKAY BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE A DONOR AND THAT WOULD BE.
POTENTIALLY A SOURCE POINT.
SO THAT'S A GOOD THING CORRECT
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW AS
KATHY MISTER KALRA I THINK THIS
YEAR -- I YOU KNOW I I DO WHEN
I'M LOOKING AT FOR FOR COUPLE
THINGS COMMITTEE IS HEARD OF A
NUMBER OF THOSE ALREADY THE
SESSION -- END OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THAT POINT TO A
DIFFERENT DIRECTION AT LEAST OF
THE MAJORITY -- HAS BEEN HEADING
AND WE JUST HEARD AB FORTY FOUR
RECENTLY -- BUT REGARDING OF THE
FOR THE BANNING OF FOR A CERTAIN
KINDS OF FOR WE HAD A BILL A
LAST TO THE END OF THOSE A LOT
OF CONVERSATION IN THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS SUBSEQUENT
TO IT ON CHAU BE HUNTING AND WAS
DIFFERENT.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHETHER
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
HELP -- VERSUS HUNTING PROGRAM
SENDING LICENSES -- BUT HOW DO
AS A VERSES ENVIRONMENTAL
TOURISM -- AND WHAT HAS A
GREATER IMPACT -- AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY IT'S ABOUT.
WHAT?
CALIFORNIA VALLEY'S ARMOR OR CUT
DIRECTION CALIFORNIA'S GOING IN
AND I THINK THAT THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE MEMBERS OF IT AGAIN NOT
EVERYONE CLEARLY WE DEFINITELY
HAVE VERY VIGOROUS DEBATE IT'S A
GOOD THING THAT WE DO -- BUT I I
THINK THIS COULD THIS COMMITTEE
HAS A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
AS TO THE DIRECTION THAT WE
SHOULD BE GOING IN AND I LOOK AT
THE ANALYSIS.
YES THERE HAVE BEEN RESTORED
POPULATIONS BUT WHY THOSE
POPULATIONS NEEDED RESTORED
BECAUSE IT WAS OVER HUNTING AND
LOSS OF HABITAT.
AND SO THAT'S WHY THERE WAS A
PROBLEM TO BEGIN WITH.
NOW THE POPULATIONS HAVE BEEN
INCREASED AGAIN IF HUNTING IS
CONTROLLED AND THE HABITATS
PROTECTED THERE WON'T BE A NEED
FOR THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
AND SO -- WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
NUISANCE PERMITS -- SO THAT
HUMAN POPULATIONS ARE ENDANGERED --
NOW THERE'S NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILD ANIMAL WHICH NO
ONE IS DISPUTING IS A WILD
ANIMAL -- WILL CONTINUE TO
THRIVE BECAUSE WHAT CAUSED ITS
DEMISE WAS THE FACT THAT AS WAS
MENTIONED -- BY SOME OF THE
EXPERT TESTIMONY OVER DECADES
DON'T REALLY CARE WHAT WAS
HAPPENING THE ALLIGATOR.
ALLIGATORS UNTIL THE ROUND THE
SIXTIES AND THAT'S WHERE WE SAW
THE DIP IN THE THE THE DRAMATIC
DIP IN THE POPULATION BECAUSE
OVER HUNTING.
AND SO OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES AND AND DECIDE HE'S
PROGRAM'S BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES THERE'S NOT A NEW THING
SO PUTTING A LABEL SAYING THAT
THERE'S APPROVED BY SITE IS WELL
THAT'S BEEN THE CASE FOR MANY
DECADES -- BUT MY MY BUT THE
POINT BEING IS THAT THE ONLY
REASON WHY THERE WAS A
PREDICAMENT AND IS A PREDICAMENT.
REGARDING -- IN SOME SOME AREAS
OF THE WORLD THAT DON'T HAVE.
OF THE THE DESIRE TO BE POPULATE --
THERE'S BEEN A DESTINATION
BECAUSE OF THE RETAIL DEMAND AND
THE AND THE AND THE THE THE THE
EXPORTING INTO.
NATIONS LIKE THE US AND OTHER
PLACES THAT HELLO BY THE THE
RETAIL PRODUCTS.
AND SO.
I THINK BOTH IN TERMS OF
PROTECTION OF THE SPECIES THIS
IS TO SUGGEST THAT THE ONLY WITH
THIS PIECE TO BE PROTECTED AS OF
THIS PRACTICE CONTINUES EXIST.
I'VE I I DON'T SEE THAT AS A AS
A FACTUALLY CORRECT STATEMENT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT.
THE THE GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
NOW COULD PUT IN PLACE MUCH
STRONGER HUNTING PROHIBITIONS WE
COULD PUT IN PLACE.
HABITAT PROTECTIONS AND THE
LASTING ALSO ON HABITAT IS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SURVEY DOES
INDICATE A DRAMATIC INCREASE
THANKFULLY FOR THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE SURVEYS EXEMPT
PERCENT.
CLEARLY SHOWS THAT THE
INTENTIONAL ACTIONS -- BUTTON
THAT THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE BY
LOUISIANA AND OF FLORIDA.
APPARENTLY I HAD BEEN WORKING.
BUT BUT IF YOU NOTICE A 12% DEPT
DUE.
TO TROPICAL STORM CINDY AND I
MENTION THAT BECAUSE HABITAT AND
THE PROTECTION HAPPEN HAS WILL
BE MUCH MUCH MORE DIFFICULT I
THINK WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
PROTECTION OF THE HABITAT.
AND THE RESTAURANT AND AND NOW
THE POPULATION'S BEEN RESTORED --
CONTROLLING AND AND ENSURING
THAT THERE'S NO HUNTING EXCEPT
FOR NUISANCE.
AT THOSE TWO THINGS ARE DONE I
THINK THAT THE THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN REALIZED
OVER ABOUT A HALF PERCENT FORTY
TO FIFTY YEARS.
AND I'M GRATEFUL TO THOSE THE
INSTITUTE THE PROGRAM AND
GRATEFUL TO THOSE THAT DID THE
HARD WORK TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
BUT THERE'S NO NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA -- TO DO ANYTHING BUT
ALLOW OF THE ALLOW THE SUNSET
TWENTY TWENTY AND LET'S MOVE
FORWARD -- AS A STATE IN THAT
DIRECTION SO I WILL WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THIS TIME IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER ELABORATION
REGARDING THE ABSOLUTE NEED FOR
MEDICINAL PURPOSES -- THEN THAT
SHOULD BE THE FOCUS OF THE BILL
AND WE CAN WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT THANKS.
MR GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WHICH WE I THINK WE ALWAYS DO A
BIT MORE BILL FACTOR AROUND HERE
AND JUST PUSH THINGS ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER BUT DON'T ACTUALLY OF
A CONVERSATION.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE I
FIND MYSELF -- BE ABLE TO RELATE
TO BOTH SIDES OF THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE I APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE AND WHICH WE
SEEM TO BE A BARE MINIMUM FOR
EVEN ENTERTAINING OF DISCUSSION.
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT
WHATEVER EVER WAS IMPORTED
FOLLOW THE STRICTEST OF OF OF
RULES ALTHOUGH THIS HEARING
MAKES A GOOD POINT ABOUT.
THIS DOESN'T EVEN WITH THIS IN
PLACE ARE STILL TREMENDOUS TRADE
FOR WHICH WE SHOULD ALL HAVE
CONCERN AND SHOULD NOT BE
COMPLACENT -- THAT SAID -- I I
THINK THERE'S OTHER SORTS OF
METRICS THAT I THINK ARE WORTHY
OF DISCUSSION OF AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT THERE ARE.
YOU LEARN THANK YOU THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL READY TO LEARN SOMETHING
NEW EVERY DAY RIGHT SO THERE'S
TWENTY COMING HERE TWENTY THREE
WAS IN THE CANADIAN HOUSES.
DIFFERENT SPECIES OF ALLIGATOR
SOME OF WHICH ARE IN DANGER SOME
OF WHICH ARE AT RISK RIGHT.
AND I WONDER WHY WE WOULD BE.
FOR CONSISTENCY'S SAKE
SUPPORTING THE IMPORTATION OF OF
AT LEAST PORTIONS OF THIS -- OF
CROCODILES AND ALLIGATORS THAT
ARE ENDANGERED -- THAT THAT
WOULD SEEM TO BE.
NOT SOMETHING WE'D WANT TO
SUPPORT IS CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THEIR PORTIONS THAT ARE NOT --
AT RISK IN THERE FOR MAYBE A
MORE DYNAMIC THOUGHT IS IT IS
WORTH WHILE THEY'RE DRIVING I
STRUGGLE WITH IN TERMS OF THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS I'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD MENTION.
OF THE THERAPEUTIC BENEFITS --
OF ACROSS OF THIS SPECIES FOR
HUMAN -- RESEARCH -- AND THERE
ARE CERTAINLY FOLKS I LOOK TO ON
THIS ISSUE CAME IN SUCCESSOR
SUPPORT FOR THIS THAT'S NOT
REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS -- MY STAFF'S OF COURSE
REVIEW REVIEW OF WAS TRYING TO
FIND ADDITIONAL INFORMATION --
SOME OF THE COMMENTS CRITICALLY
FROM THE LOUISIANA DELEGATION --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PARTICULAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION REFERENCES --
EATING WERE AT LOUISIANA
LOUISIANA ALLIGATORS AND TALK
ABOUT BAGS AND WALLETS BUT NOT
TALKING ABOUT RESEARCH -- WHICH
IS AN IMPEDIMENT FOR ME GETTING
WHERE I'D LIKE TO BE OUR I THINK
WE'RE SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO BE ON
THIS BILL -- IT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT WE THE ALLIGATOR EGGS
ARE PERHAPS MORE HELPFUL -- IN
THERE PRETTY KEEP THERAPEUTIC
USES -- AND I'M CONFUSED ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE A THE
IMPORTATION OF THE EGGS IS
ALLOWED UNDER THE CURRENT BAND --
IF IF THIS LEGISLATION WAS NOT
PASSED. TO SOMEONE WHO MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER THAT.
PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT ARE THE
ANIMAL A OR THE CROCODILE EGGS.
BUT GETS IN A MORE EGGS ARE THE
ONLY A THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT
THAT'S HERE.
I'VE SEEN THE SHAKING OF HEADS
AND NOW NOW THAT ONE OF THE
DOLLARS WILL BE CORRECT THAT THE
THERAPEUTIC BENEFITS COME -- IN
A LARGE PORTION FROM THE BLOOD
OF THE ANIMALS THEMSELVES A LOOK
AT A DIFFERENT ON THE BODIES AND
DIFFERENT PROTEINS ARE IN THE
BLOOD PRODUCT OF THE ANIMAL SO
WOULDN'T BE JUST THE AG.
IS THE BLOOD PROHIBITED UNDER
THE BAN ON IS A PART OF THE ITEM
ALSO IF I'M CORRECT US AS THE
STATE NOW ANY PART.
OF THE BODY OF THE ANIMAL WE
PROHIBITED SO ON THEIR SITE IS
FOR EXAMPLE BLOOD IS A PART OF
THE ANIMAL SO YOU CAN EXPORT
BLOT WITH A PERMITS -- IT CAN
EITHER SPEAK.
TO ANYTHING THERAPEUTIC
[inaudible]
WITH.
IT IS I UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT
BAND DOES NOT PROHIBIT -- LIVE
BIG FROM BEING IMPORTED.
OKAY SO EGGS ARE PERMITTED BUT
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY QUESTION THE
ANIMAL THAT COULD BE BENEFICIAL
FOR HUMAN RESEARCH CORRECT AND A
COPY OF WITH AXES IT DEPENDS ON
THE AGE OF THE AG TO BECAUSE AT
A CERTAIN AGE IS GOING TO BE A
LIVE AMBER INSIDE THAT ACT.
SO YOU HAVE A LIVE ANIMAL.
JONATHAN LOUISIANA.
ABOUT THIS DEGREE YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER.
REGARDING THE THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS THEY'RE SIX TYPES OF
THE EIGHT CAN DO DOES THAT IT
TREATS -- WE CIRCULATED AROUND A
PICTURE OF A PATIENT WHO HAD
FLESH EATING BACTERIA CONSUMING
HER NECK AND THE UPPER TORSO
AREA AND WITHIN TWO MONTHS IT
WAS TREATED WITH THE ALLIGATOR
SELVES.
AND IT WAS -- CURED AT THAT TIME --
THERE'S HEPATITIS -- HIV WIND
WAS TREATED AT AN IN VITRO LEVEL
WERE KILLED 50% OF THE HIV VIRUS
WITHIN ONE HOUR OF TREATMENT
THAT'S STILL A LONG WAYS FROM AN
ACTUAL -- SERUM HOWEVER -- IT IS
PROMISING HERPES SIMPLEX ONE
STAFF INFECTION MERCER HER ALSO
TREATED WITH THIS RIGHT NOW
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IS LOOKING
AT THIS AS A WOUND TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE FOR OUR VETERANS
WERE IN AFGHANISTAN AND OTHER
AREAS -- BECAUSE THE BACTERIA IS
IN THOSE AREAS ARE ACTUALLY VERY
DIFFICULT TO TREAT WITH
TRADITIONAL ANTIBIOTICS -- THERE
ARE ALSO TWO TYPES OF PNEUMONIAS
WHICH ARE BEING TREATED --
THERE'S ALSO OSTEOPOROSIS OUR
OUR STORE OF THEIR IDEAS WHERE.
THE CORTISONE TREATMENTS WHICH
ARE TYPICALLY DETERIORATING
TISSUE -- ARE NOT AFFECTED
NEGATIVELY BY THE HYALURONIC
ACID WITHIN THE ALLIGATOR
MUSEUMS.
SO THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF HUMAN
AILMENTS.
THAT ARE PRESENTLY BEING LOOKED
AT IN ADDITION TO REMOVING
ANTIBIOTICS FROM AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS LIKE SWINE IN COW THAT
WOULD TRADITIONALLY REQUIRE
ANTIBIOTICS.
THEY NO LONGER DO BECAUSE THE
ALLIGATOR PRODUCTS ARE IN THEIR
MEAT -- THAT THAT CONSUME THANK
YOU OKAY THANKS SO I AM
INTERESTED TIME INSTRUMENTS AND
I RECOGNIZE.
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY BILL THAT
WE HAVE LEFT I KNOW THEY ARE
PASSIONATE FEELINGS ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL GOOD DISCUSSION I
AGREE WHAT SO I I GUESS RIGHT
WHAT I WOULD NEED TO SEE IS FOR
HER -- PROTECTIONS I MEAN IS
SAID MINIMALLY THAT THE LEGEND
THAT LANGUAGE IS PLACE BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE.
AS MISS VERY POINTED OUT I HAVE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED MS FRIEDMAN'S
BILL FROM A FEW WEEKS AGO AND
FOR CONSISTENCY SAKE.
I STRUGGLE WITH SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING
THAT BILL -- THERE MAY BE
CUTENESS FACTOR THAT'S INVOLVED
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT RIGHT -- AND MY
INTEREST THOUGH ISN'T LIFESAVING
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY I THINK WE'RE
HERE TO SERVE THE CITIZENS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS OF STATE CALIFORNIA --
AND IF THEY CAN BENEFIT FROM
THIS MEDICAL RESEARCH THAT WOULD
BE OF INTEREST TO ME I REPRESENT
A LOT OF COMPANIES -- IN SAN
DIEGO -- WHO I PRESUMABLY WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS ACCESS BUT
THAT'S A FAR DIFFERENT --
CONVERSATION THEN MEET -- THEN --
SKIN -- THAN SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS SO -- I DON'T KNOW I MEAN
I WILL TO SUSPEND DISBELIEF A
BIT LONGER TO TO SEE IF WE CAN
MAKE IT CONVERSATION ABOUT
LIFESAVING TREATMENTS I'M NOT AS
INTERESTED.
IN ME AND I AND IN SHOES AND
WALLETS AND PURSES AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE OF THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE I'M AT IF THAT MAKES
BETWEEN -- WHICH I HATE THAT
TERM -- NORMALLY A PRETTY
DECISIVE IN NATURE BUT I CAN SEE
BOTH SIDES OF THIS AND I'M NOT
SURE HOW WE CAN PROCEED IF AT
ALL TODAY -- BUT THAT'S MY TWO
CENTS CHAIR.
IN IT IT DOES SOUND LIKE YOU
KNOW THERE'S A MEMBER BEFORE
SIDE I BELIEVE MR LAYING WHO IS
UP HERE EARLIER.
HAD MADE THAT POINT AS WELL THAT
HE WANTS TO WORK ON LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD HELP BETTER PROTECT.
AGAINST THREATENED SPECIES
OBVIOUSLY BEING USED AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY HIS INTEREST.
IS IN THE MEDICAL AS WELL WELL
IN THAT AS A QUESTION ARE THE
ENDANGERED.
SPECIES THE ONES THAT PEOPLE
NEED. TO TO TEST UPON BECAUSE IF.
IT.
NO AND I GUESS IN A IN THE
ANALYSIS UNDERSIDE THESE ALL
WELL THIS IS ALL HIDE SOLD
COMMERCIALLY REQUIRED TO BE TAG
TO DISTINGUISH THEM FROM LISTED
SPECIES THAT ARE NOT PERMITTED
AND I GET.
AND THAT'S ALSO SAID I STRUGGLE
WITH IS THAT COMMITTEE NOW SAYS
WELL GOOD I'M DOESN'T AS WE
SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE IN INTO
MEDICAL -- AND YOU KNOW AGAIN
ABOUT GOING OFF FOR THE
TESTIMONY WHICH ARE PEOPLE ON
BOTH SIDES ARE MAKING THE SAME
CASE.
RED FOR MAKING OFF THE CASES ARE.
OKAY -- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
JUST THAT YES VISIBLE ON A
FOLLOW UP AND THIS IS TO BOTH
THE AUTHORS AND I AND I AND I DO
HOPE THIS BILL ACTUALLY GETS OUT
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK THERE IS.
ADDED VALUE HERE WHILE THERE IS
SOME CONCERNS THAT ARE CLEARLY.
SEEN HERE AND PRESENTED.
IS THERE IS A SERIOUS COMMITMENT
FROM BOTH THE AUTHORS.
AND LOOKING AT TAKING AMENDMENTS
AS IT GOES.
FROM HERE I THINK IT GOES TO THE
FLOOR THEY'LL BE IN THE SENATE.
WILL IT BE FOCUSED ON IN THE
SENATE WHERE YOU CAN TAKE SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN OUTLINED.
BUT YEAH ABSOLUTELY OUR GUEST.
THANK EVEN THOUGH THAT'S WHAT I
WANT TO HEAR ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MAYBE EVEN READ YES ABSOLUTELY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY IT WILL BRING IT BACK YOU
KNOW.
THE DID YOU HAVE DID YOU WANT TO
ADD TO THAT MISTER GLORIA WELL I
GUESS I'D BE INTERESTED IN
INTEREST ANYWAY WHAT YOU THINK
YOU COULD SUPPORTER YOUR
SPONSORS COULD SUPPORT.
IN TERMS OF NARROWING.
THE NATURE OF THE BILL.
MIKE THANK YOU WERE OPEN TO
EVERYTHING LET ME JUST SAY THAT
THAT -- WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT
THIS IS THAT.
THIS IS AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HAD BEEN CREATED.
THAT HAS BROUGHT THE SPECIES
BACK FROM THE BRINK OF
EXTINCTION IN MANY AREAS -- IT
IS.
A PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE STATE OF LOUISIANA
AND THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
AND IT IS -- IT IS RESULTED
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION AS
WELL AND SO.
AS LONG AS WE CAN RECOGNIZE THAT
AND THEN RECOGNIZE THE
THERAPEUTIC BENEFITS.
THAT HAVE BEEN CREATED BECAUSE
OF THIS PARTNERSHIP I THINK WE
CAN WE CAN GET TO YES -- I'M I
DISAGREE WITH.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE -- FROM THE
SANTA CLARA REGION BUT BUT IF
YOU DON'T RECOGNIZE IT THEN IT'S
HARD TO GET TSN WHATEVER
ADVISEMENT NEED TO ACCOMPANY THE
PRODUCT -- WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO HAVE.
THAT.
BE PART OF IT SO THAT -- SO THAT
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE COMPLYING
WITH WITH SITE IS AND THAT YEAR
THAT'D BE IS ECOLOGICALLY
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES THAT IT
THAT HAVE BEEN -- A PART OF OF
THE OF THE DEVELOPMENT.
AT THE OF THE PRODUCT AND SO.
I GUESS WHAT I A RESEARCHER SANE --
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A RECOGNITION
OF THE OF THE RESURGENCE OF THIS
SPECIES GIVEN SOME OF THIS TO
THE SENATE SHOULD SHOULD BE ABLE.
TO TO THIS BUT YOU KNOW COULD
COULD YOU LIMITED TO THE NON --
IN DANGER NON VULNERABLE SPECIES
IS THAT EVEN TECHNICALLY
POSSIBLE COULD WE PROHIBIT THE
IMPORTATION FOR COSMETIC AND AND
FASHION USES WHICH ARE.
KIND OF BACKWARDS IN MY OPINION --
LIMITED TO HIM AND INVESTMENT
FOR LIFESAVING THERAPIES I MEAN
THESE THE THAT THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS I THINK.
AT LEAST SPEAK TO ME I WANT TO
BE FOR THE WHOLE COMMITTEE BUT I
I THINK THAT THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN IMPORTED SUBMITS ITS
ENDANGERED SO SOMEONE CAN HAVE A
NEW BAG THAT'S NOT SOMETHING I
CAN SUPPORT.
RIGHT WELL THE ENDANGERED.
UP PART OF IT IT THERE'S NO
QUESTION AT ALL I DON'T THINK IT
I MEAN THAT THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT BUT IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NARROWING
IT ONLY TO MEDICAL RESEARCH WE
HAVE TO TAKE THAT BACK TO THE
SPONSORS AND HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH THEM.
AND I THINK THAT IS INTENT OF
THEIR AMENDMENT IS TO STATE IN
THERE AND HAD AND I KNOW.
FOR ME -- PROBABLY WANT TO HAVE
EVEN STRONGER LANGUAGE BUT THE
INTENT IS TO ENSURE THAT.
NOTHING COULD BE IMPORTED THAT
WOULD BE A THREATENED SPECIES
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
IMPERMISSIBLE UNDER SIDE EAST OF
THE TREATY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THIS
HEARING DID YOU HEAR WELL I JUST
MENTION NIGHT.
AMERICAN ALLIGATORS ARE LISTED
UNDER THE FEDERAL ESA AS A
LOOKALIKE SPECIES OUT OF THE
THINGS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT SO.
WHAT IS ANY LOOKALIKES THERE IF
YOU?
MEANING THEY LOOK ALIKE ENOUGH
LIKE THAT THE LISTED SPECIES
THAT THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM
THERE THEY ARE LISTED AS
THREATENED BECAUSE THEY ARE
TRADE WOULD IMPACT ADVERSELY
SPECIES THAT THEY LOOK ALIKE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE THE
DIFFERENCE CANNOT BE TOLD.
SO EVEN IF YOU HAD A DOWN THIS
ROAD IF THEY'RE RAISING A FARM
DIVERSION OF A SPECIES THAT'S
LISTED UNDER THE ESSAY THAT
WOULD NOT BEEN WE DID WHAT YOU
SUGGESTED.
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT THE SALE OF
THE SPECIES THEIR RATING
REGARDLESS OF ITS SOURCE.
SO EVEN IT'S NOT ENDANGERED IT
HAPPENS TO LOOK LIKE IT'S IN
DANGER SO THERE ARE QUITE A LOT
OF OUR FACILITY BECAUSE IT IS.
IT'S CONSIDERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO CREATE THAT ITS
TRADE CREATES ENOUGH OF A
PROBLEM FOR SPECIES THAT IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT IT.
TOO IS LISTED.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND.
SINCE AND I AM SO BASICALLY
UNDER THE LAW RIGHT NOW UNDER
THE TREATY AND THAT THIS IS
STATED IN THE ANALYSIS ELSEWHERE
IT IS ILLEGAL. TO IMPORT
THREATENED SPECIES.
INTO THE UNITED STATES WE ALSO
HAVE.
THE US FISH AND WILDLIFE
ACTUALLY DOES DNA TESTING. TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS NOT A
THREATENED SPECIES WHEN IT WHEN
IT COMES IN -- SO THERE.
SO THAT IS A LEGAL I THINK WHAT
MISS FEARING A SANE THERE STILL
ISN'T A LEGAL TRADE THAT GOES ON
AND YOU KNOW JUST LIKE WITH A
LOT OF A LOT WE PASS LAWS
BANNING THINGS ARE SCORES SAYING
THIS IS PROHIBITED.
BUT THEY'RE STILL PEOPLE OUT
THERE THERE ARE BAD ACTORS WHO
ARE BASICALLY BREAKING THE LAW
ANYWAY RIGHT.
AS BUT UNDER THE LAW AND UNDER
THE TREATY IT IS ILLEGAL TO USE.
TO IMPORT A THREATENED SPECIES.
IT FOR WHATEVER PURPOSE.
YEAH WE CAN GO TO THE EXPERT IF
YOU LIKED IT BUT I WILL WE NEED
TO GET MOVING ALONG HERE SO I
THINK WE'VE KIND OF DEFINITELY
COVER A LOT ISSUE GROUND HERE.
OKAY MAYBE TAKE THAT AS YOU GUYS
IS CLOSE.
OKAY OKAY -- ALL RIGHT SO BRING
I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR SO
I'M FILLING IN FOR THE CHAIR
TODAY -- THE CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS NONE ON THIS
BILL -- I PERSONALLY AM GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY --
IN MY BASIS FOR DOING SO IS
NUMBER ONE WE WE DO HAVE A
HISTORY HERE OF PREVIOUS
LEGISLATURE'S.
EXTENDING THE SUNSET YES OF FOR
AT LEAST THREE TIMES NOW WE'VE
DECIDED.
BASED ON THE RECOVERY OF THE
SPECIES IN THE THINGS THAT WERE
SEEN IN.
IN FLORIDA AND IN LOUISIANA AND
AUSTRALIA -- THAT THIS ACTUALLY
HAS BEEN HELPFUL -- TO THE
RECOVERY OF THE SPECIES.
AND REALLY ALL WE'RE DOING HERE
IS EXTEND IN THAT SENSE THAT
AGAIN -- SO ME I I THINK.
HE'LL WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN SOME
GOOD RESULTS THERE I THINK
THERE'S THINGS THAT WE COULD.
CONTINUE TO TRY AND BUILD UPON
TO ENSURE PROTECTIONS.
AS THE MEMBER GLORIA IS POINT
OUT AND OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE WE HAVE AUTHORS.
WHO ARE VERY MUCH WILLING TO
WORK ON AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS GOING FORWARD --
AND SO I WOULD ENTERTAIN YOU
KNOW A IS IT MOVED AS AMENDED OR
JUST SAYS IT.
OKAY MOVED AS AMENDED AS AS
PROPOSED BY THE AUTHORS AND
THEIR YEAH GO HEAD AND READ THE
AMENDMENT AGAIN.
THE MOMENT STATES STARTING ON
PAGE FOUR LINE. TWELVE WOULD BE.
THREE PRODUCTS SOLD IN THE STATE
PRIOR TO THE PROHIBITION
CONTAINED IN THIS SUBDIVISION
WHICH ARE WHOLLY OR IN PART.
FROM ALLIGATORS ARE COCKETT I'LL
SHALL BE ACCOMPANIED BY A
DISCLOSURE THAT READS AS FOLLOWS
THIS PRODUCT WAS MADE USING
MATERIALS IN FULL COMPLIANCE.
WITH THIS PROVISIONS OF THE
CONVENTION ON INTERNATIONAL
TRADE IN ENDANGERED AN
ENDANGERED SPECIES SOCIETIES
[inaudible]
SECOND.
BED BUT THAT'S THE I GUESS WE'LL
GO THERE PROPOSED AMENDMENT.
OKAY SO THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
MOTION AS AMENDED.
AS THEIR SECOND.
SECONDED BY A DOCTOR CHOI ALL
RIGHT -- MEDICALLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
YES WE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED GALLAGHER.
BY GALLAGHER I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU NOT VOTING VALLEY FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US NO [inaudible]
THREE OF US NO.
REVERSE BLOCK A RUBIO SALAS
WOULD. THREE TO ONE ON CALL.
OKAY THE BILL'S GOT THREE VOTES
LEAVE IT ON CALL AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR PRISON TO PRESENTED.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP LET'S KEEP
THIS FROM -- ON OUR SPECIAL
ORDERS HERE WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
THREE AND MISS CABLING AND UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS.
IS THAT ON IS IT ON SHOULD BE.
YES.
AND I'M NOT [inaudible]
HELLO.
THIS IS BETTER YEAH GO AHEAD
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR PUTS A TEMPORARY
PROHIBITION ON TROPHY HUNTING OF
BOBCATS WHILE ALLOWING THE FISH
AND GAME COMMISSION TIME TO
REVIEW CRITICAL FACTORS.
INCLUDING THE AFFECT OF TROPHY
HUNTING ON BOTH BOBCAT
POPULATIONS AND THEIR PREY THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF A HUNT TO
THE AGENCY.
AND AN ANALYSIS OF NON LETHAL
MEASURES BEFORE RE OPENING A
TROPHY HUNTING SEASON ON BOBCATS.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR ALSO
CONTAINS COMMONSENSE EXEMPTIONS
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE BOB THE
TAKE A BOBCATS IN THE EVENT THAT
ONE WAS THREATENING PUBLIC
SAFETY LIVESTOCK OR PETS.
CALIFORNIANS CONSISTENTLY HAVE
SUPPORTED PROTECTIONS AGAINST
TROPHY HUNTING FOR OUR STATE'S
NATIVE CARNIVORES.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO THEN
GOVERNOR REAGAN INITIATED A
MORATORIUM ON THE TROPHY HUNTING
OF MOUNTAIN LIONS FOLLOWED BY A
BALLOT MEASURE PROHIBITING PRO
HITTING HUNTING OF MOUNTAIN
LIONS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS WHITTLED AWAY AT THE METHODS
USED TO KILL CALIFORNIA SMALLER
NATIVE WILD CAT.
IN TWENTY TWELVE THE LEGISLATURE
BANNED THE USE OF POUNDS IN THE
HUNTING OF BOBCATS AND
RESTRICTED TRAPPING WHICH WAS
SOON FOLLOWED BY A STATEWIDE BAN
ON TRAPPING BY THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION.
IF PASSED THIS BILL WILL
REPRESENT THE NEXT CRITICAL STEP
TO FINALLY PUT AN END TO THE
NEEDLESS SLAUGHTER OF THESE
ELUSIVE CATS.
AND ALLOW FOR THE GATHERING OF
MUCH NEEDED SCIENTIFIC DATA.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR SUPPORTS
THE NOTION THAT WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT SHOULD BE BASED UPON
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE BY
SETTING IN PLACE A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE DEVELOP ACOMPREHENSIVE
BOBCAT MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS WILL
INCLUDE AN UPDATED STATEWIDE
POPULATION ESTIMATES.
THE LAST BOBCAT POPULATION
ASSESSMENT IN CALIFORNIA IS MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS OLD AND IS
DATED AND LIKELY INACCURATE.
BECAUSE THE ASSESSMENT SO DATED
IT FAILS TO REFLECT THE CURRENT
SCIENTIFIC METHODS FOR ASSESSING
AND MONITORING THE OVERALL
HEALTH IN TREND OF THE STATEWIDE
POPULATION.
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL REQUIRE THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER THE
EFFECTS OF TROPHY HUNTING
BOBCATS.
INCLUDING AFFECTS ON THEIR PREY
DISEASE ABATEMENT AND CONTROL OF
INVASIVE SPECIES SUCH AS THE
NUTRIA RATS PRIOR TO RE OPENING
A BOBCAT HUNTING SEASON.
LACKING NO RELIABLE A RECENT
ESTIMATE OF THE CURRENT
STATEWIDE POPULATION IT'S COMMON
SENSE TO PUT AN END TO THIS
KILLING UNTIL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE COMPLETES
EXTENSIVE ANALYSES.
SHOWING YHO BEHIND OF BOBCATS
NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
TROPHY HUNTING.
PRO TROPHY HUNTING ENTHUSIASTS
CANNOT ARGUE THAT DECISIONS NEED
SCIENCE BUT THEN ARGUE AGAINST
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD MANDATE
THE GATHERING OF THAT EXACT
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION.
ADDITIONALLY BOBCAT TAX COST A
MERE THREE DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FOUR CENTS BARELY MAKING A
CONTRIBUTION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
LESS THAN FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THAT IS LESS THAN THE
SALARY OF A SINGLE GAME WARDEN.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWELVE FIFTY FOUR AND HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
WENDY KEEP OVER FROM THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU SO A MEMBER AND ARE
YOU DID YOU SAY ARE YOU TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS YES OKAY.
THERE AND AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO
MINUTES EACH SO LET'S TRY AND
STAY ON TRACK.
I'M I'M WENDY KEEP OVER I'M THAT.
NATIVE CARNIVORE PROTECTION
MANAGER FOR THE HUMANE SOCIETY
OF THEN AND UNITED STATES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEES -- THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES AND OUR
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTERS I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC BOBCATS HAVE
BEEN AFFORDED SOME PROTECTIONS
IN RECENT YEARS.
YET HUNTER STILL CUT A KILL
HUNDREDS OF THEM ANNUALLY FOR
NOTHING MORE THAN A TROPHY OR
FOR THEIR FUR PELTS.
AND THOSE FOR PELZER OFTEN
SHIPPED OVERSEAS MARKETS IT'S
TIME IN CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE THE
LOOP AND PUT A MORATORIUM ON
TROPHY HUNTING CALIFORNIA'S
SMALLEST WILD CATS WHO ARE
HIGHLY SENTIENT AND HOLD
INTRINSIC VALUES.
BOBCATS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
BALANCING THE HEALTH OF THEIR
INCOME SYSTEMS THEY PREY UPON
RODENTS RABBITS INVASIVE NUTRIA
WHICH IN TURN BENEFIT FARMERS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO I JUST LOOK THIS UP NUTRIA
CAN PRODUCE THREE LITTERS A YEAR
IN UP TO TWELVE KIDS PER LITTER --
NUTRIA HARM CROPS WETLANDS
ECOSYSTEMS AND EVEN HUMAN HEALTH
ON THE OTHER HAND BOBCATS ARE
VERY SLOW TO REPRODUCE --
THEY'RE VERY AND THEY'RE
INCREDIBLY RARE IT'S EXCITING TO
SPOT WHEN IN THE WILD AND 74% OF
CALIFORNIANS WOULD VALUE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A WILD BOBCAT
WE JUST DID A POLL -- EARLIER
LIKE LAST WEEK.
AND THAT'S WHAT WHAT CAME OUT OF
THAT 74%. 74% CALIFORNIA'S WANNA
SEE OR A BOBCAT IN THE WILD.
SO BOB CAT NUMBERS ARE KEPT IN
CHECK BY A NUMBER OF OF FORCES.
THEY THEY ARE PREYED UPON.
BY OTHER CARNIVORES THEY FACE
COMPETITION FROM OTHER
CARNIVORES SUCH AS COYOTES AND
MOUNTAIN LIONS AND ALSO THE
NUMBER OF PREY REGULATES THE
NUMBERS OF PREDATORS -- JUST
LIKE WITH ANY CO SYSTEM SO YOU
MEMBER THE CLASSIC A SNOWSHOE
HARE AND THE LINKS -- MODEL SO
BOBCATS ALSO FACED ADDITIONAL
THREATS IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
LOSS OF HABITAT FROM URBAN
SPRAWL AND OF COURSE THE RECENT
DEADLY FIRES AND FOR THESE
REASONS BOB CATS DON'T NEED TO
BE TROPHY HUNTING.
HUNTED PART ME.
TROPHY HUNTING SIMPLY PUTS
UNNECESSARY ADDITIONAL PRESSURE
ON THEIR POPULATIONS WHICH HAS
NOT BEEN STUDIED IN OVER THREE
DECADES.
AND AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN MENTIONED
THIS LEGISLATION SUPPORTS THE
USE OF SOUND SCIENCE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT OF
WILDLIFE DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
MUCH A BOBCAT MANAGEMENT PLAN.
THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS ASSESSES
THEIR POPULATION USING THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
AND REPLACES THE OUTDATED THIRTY
FIVE YEAR OLD ASSESSMENT.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF A LOOK AT THE
HOLISTIC AFFECTS OF TROPHY
HUNTING BOBCATS NOT JUST ON
THEIR OWN POPULATIONS BUT ALSO
ON PREY AND INVASIVE SPECIES CAN.
CONTROL.
UP PRIOR TO OPENING A SEASON HE
COULDN'T WRAP UP A LITTLE OKAY
SIR SO -- JUST THREE MINUTES.
I'M AT THREE MINUTES YEAH.
OKAY -- CALIFORNIANS WITH WEED
AS I SAID WE DID A POLL --
CALIFORNIANS BY ABOUT 4%.
WHAT A 70% DE UM DON'T SUPPORT
TROPHY HUNTING SO?
I CAN WRAP IT UP THERE AND I CAN
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF YOU LINE DID
YOU HAVE. NINE STAFF OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
GOING INTO ANOTHER WITNESS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NAME AND JUST SUPER WHETHER OR
NOT SUPPORT THE BILL KRISTOL
MARLIN ON BEHALF THE DORIS DAY
ANIMAL LEAGUE AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
NICHOLAS SACKETT ENDS UP SUCH
QUESTION LEGISLATION IN SUPPORT.
CAROL MISSILE DINE UMANE
SOCIETY LEGISLATIVE FUND IT'S
PART.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
AND DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
ANONYMOUS FOR THE VOICELESS WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL?
ASHLEY LUIS FAIRFAX CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
PATRICIA EASILY MEADOW VISTA I
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KAREN LACKEY LARKSPUR CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN KIRKPATRICK IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THE MIDDLE FOR SACRAMENTO
POP PACK PIZZA AND IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS I SUPPORT?
MARGARET KIRKPATRICK TRUCKEE
CALIFORNIA I'M IN SUPPORT.
ERIN HOW GAY ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT COYOTE AND HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES IN
SUPPORT.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ELSE READ -- ON
BEHALF OF COMPASSIONATE BAY I
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG EL SERENO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND IT'S
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA MEMBERS.
WE SUPPORT.
FREE THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THE HERE GARCIA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
DEBBIE MEREDITH SUFFERED A
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
BONTA TOMLINSON PROJECT COYOTE
AND CALIFORNIA COUNCIL.
WILDLIFE REHABILITATED IN
SUPPORT AND I ALSO READ THE
GAVIN NEWSOM PUT ON HIS WEBSITE
THAT STE THANK YOU HE SUPPORTS
THE END OF BOBCAT HUNTING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GENE TRAP DAVIS I TALKED TO A
MAN WILDLIFE ECOLOGY FOR THIRTY
YEARS AT SAC STATE AND HAD.
THIRTY ONE OKAY STUDENTS --
DOING A MASTERS I SUPPORT THIS
BILL VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THIS NAME AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU
SUPPORT.
A CYBER URINE TO CALIFORNIA I
PLUS I HAVE SINCE NOW DAVIS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TOTALLY KIRBY DAVIS I SUPPORT.
TERRI BARNATO COLFAX CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
CARILLO DONALD GRASS VALLEY AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
STACEY SANDERS GRASS VALLEY I
SUPPORT.
DEBORAH CLAWSON NEVADA THE
HOPO HANNEKE ELK GROVE I SUPPORT.
SUSAN SIDNEY DENT SAN QUENTIN
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PIPER KRYSTLE FOLSOM CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HEATHER SCHRADER DAVIS
CALIFORNIA WITH AGENTS VIA MAY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO JENNIFER KENNEDY AND FROM
EL DORADO COUNTY AND HSUS WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SURE IN MONTE FROM DAVIS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M PAM RUN QUEST I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE HUMANE SOCIETY
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND OUR TWELVE HUNDRED THAT NERI
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO BRENDA KERRY FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BRIAN AGREE FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M GOING TO HOURS ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP GENTLEMAN AGAIN TWO
MINUTES. TWO MINUTES EACH.
GO AHEAD MR HERE MEMBERS -- AND
STAFF MANY PARENTS ARE FROM
SINGLE HAVE THE REMARKABLE UP TO
THE THANK YOU.
YEAH GOOD MORNING TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIC
SKLAR FROM SANTA ANA CALIFORNIA
ALSO PRESENT AT THE CALIFORNIA
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
DEEPLY HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY
I WANT TO SHOUT OUT YOUR STAFF
WHO WE WORK WITH CLOSELY AT THE
COMMISSION AND ARE TERRIFIC ON
THE WORK WE ALL DO TO PROTECT.
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL WILDLIFE
COUPLE QUICK COPY OUT TO BE VERY
BRIEF MY SUBSTANCE COMMENTS ONE
IS I'M NOT HERE REPRESENTING THE
COMMISSION OCCASIONALLY MEET
EVERY OTHER MONTH.
AND SO WITH THIS BILL DROPPED
AFTER OUR LAST MEETING WILL BE
DISCUSSING IT ARE BEATING UP A
WEEK FROM.
TOMORROW IN THE END UP SANTA
MONICA -- ADDITIONALLY -- I'M
NOT STRICTLY HERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE TO DISPEL I DEEPLY SHARE
THAT THE AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO
THIS SPECIES INTO WILDLIFE
PROTECTION AS YOU'D EXPECT.
ON THE COMMISSION IS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO THAT AS WELL I
APPLAUD MOST OF WHAT'S IN THIS
IN THIS BILL -- I'M HERE JUST AS
AN INSTITUTIONALIZED AND TO TALK%
ABOUT PROCESS I'M AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED.
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED US INTO
IN TWENTY TWELVE TO STUDY THE
COMMERCIAL TRAPPING ABOUT CATS
AND WE DID THAT THOROUGHLY AND
I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
COMMISSION VOTED TO BAN
COMMERCIAL BOBCAT TRAPPING IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOW FORBIDDEN.
IN THE WHOLE STATE -- WITH AT
THE CO AUTHORS ALSO RIGHT THAT A
GOOD STUDY HAS NOT BEEN DONE FOR
A WHILE IN THESE KIND OF THINGS
NEED TO BE BASED ON SCIENCE.
I APPLAUD THE IDEA OF ASKINGTHE
COMMISSION TO EVALUATE THE
RECREATIONAL HUNTING A BOBCATS
COM THERE'S NO INDICATION IF
THERE'S ANY THREAT TO THE
SPECIES THEIR CHARISMATIC
IMPORTANT SPECIES.
REPORTING PART OF THE ECOSYSTEM
AND WE NEED TO STUDY THEM FULLY
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO IN YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR SUCH A STUDY IT'S AN
EXPENSIVE STUDY THEIR ELUSIVE.
THEY'RE SPREAD OUT ALMOST ALL
OVER THE STATE I'M IN SO WE NEED
THE RESOURCES TO STUDY THEM
THAT'S ALL I WOULD ASK IS WE
DON'T SET A PRECEDENT
ESTABLISHED MORATORIUM.
BASED ON THE IN A PREVIOUS TO
STUDIES ONE OF THREE SPECIES
ISN'T THREATENED OR ENDANGERED
WE DO THAT AUTOMATICALLY WHEN
THERE'S A PETITION FOR SPECIES
IT'S ACCEPTED.
IN THIS CASE IT'S NOT NECESSARY
I THINK MORE TORIA -- SHOULD BE
USED VERY SPARINGLY WE YOU HAVE
MY OBLIGATION AND DEDICATION TO
STUDY THIS.
ISSUE CLOSELY AND TO BRING IT
BEFORE THE COMMISSION.
YOU'RE LUCKY YOU'RE YOU'RE
SPEAKER JUST GIVE THEIR NAME AND
AT THE END AND WHERE THEY'RE
FROM WE GOT HEARD ABOUT A
HUNDRED FIFTY SPEAKERS AT THREE
MINUTES EACH ON THIS TOPIC LAST
TIME EXPECT WILL.
HEAR THE SAME AGAINST I'M NOT
ASKING FOR THIS BECAUSE WE WANT
EXTRA WORK WE HAVE A TINY STAFF.
AND IT'S A LOT OF WORK BUT WE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IT AND ARE.
I WANT TO TAKE ON AND SO WE JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THIS WITHOUT
THE MORATORIUM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMISSIONER NEXT.
LEVEL CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKET ONLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
WHEN THE FIRST SAY RESPECTFULLY
I'D HARDLY CALL A FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY POUNDS BOB CAT AS A
TROPHY ANIMAL.
BUT THAT'S JUST MY OPINION.
REGARDING AB TWELVE TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR IT WE SEE THIS IS A VERY
ANTI HUNTING MEASURE THAT IS NOT
BASED ON SCIENCE OR SOUND
SCIENCE -- WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
BOB CATS ARE ABUNDANT AND FOUND
THROUGHOUT MOST OF CALIFORNIA.
AS YOU ALSO MAY KNOW THEIR FOUND
THROUGHOUT MOST THE LOWER FORTY
EIGHT ALL THE WAY UP INTO CANADA
DOWN IN MEXICO.
HONEY IN -- IS HIGHLY REGULATED
AND HAS VERY LITTLE IF ANY
IMPACT ON THE SPECIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN THE BOBCAT HUNTING TAGS
THERE ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND OF
THOSE SOLD AND ONLY ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE ANIMALS
WERE TAKEN SO.
CLEARLY HUNTING IS SUSTAINABLE
FOR THE SPECIES.
BOB CATS AS YOU ALL KNOW AS WELL
PREY ON A VARIETY OF WILDLIFE
INCLUDING GAME BIRDS SMALL
MAMMALS EVEN DEAR.
AND WILDLIFE MANAGERS IN OUR
VIEW IN NEED THE FLEXIBILITY TO
TAKE THEM WHEN NECESSARY TO
MAINTAIN -- GOOD PREDATOR PREY
POPULATIONS.
IT'S PARTICULARLY AND THE
FRAGMENTED HABITATS THAT WE HAVE
LEFT WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
ECOSYSTEM THAT WE HAD A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY YEARS AGO WHEN THE
WHEN CALIFORNIA BECAME A STATE.
LEGAL HUNTING -- IS ONE OF THOSE
MANAGEMENT TOOLS AND ALSO
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
CONSERVATION THROUGH HUNTING
LICENSE STAMPS TAGS PITTMAN
ROBERTSON ACT REVENUES.
AND A LOT OF THAT MONEY Q. IS
USED FOR ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES SO
THAT SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND.
LAW ABIDING HUNTERS THERE IN THE
FIELD THOSE THAT BY THE LICENSES
THEY ARE THE EYES AND THE EARS
OF THE WARDENS OUT IN THE WOODS.
IF YOU TAKE THE LEGAL HUNTERS
OUT OF THE FIELD.
YOU'RE GOING TO JUST REDUCE --
THE ABILITY TO SEE POACHING TO
REPORT ON IT TO USE CAL TIP
WE'VE GOT MARIJUANA CULTIVATION
GOING ON POACHING OF OTHER
SPECIES WE WANT THESE LEGAL
HUNTERS IN THE FIELD TO CONTINUE
TO A THE WARDENS -- AS WAS
TOUCHED ON EARLIER I MEAN IN OUR
VIEW THIS BILL REALLY
CIRCUMVENTS THE SEA QUEST
SCIENCE BASED PROCESS OF THE
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
ON WHICH WAS SPECIFICALLY
ESTABLISHED REGULATE ON IN SO --
THAT SOMETHING -- THAT IS OF
HUGE CONCERN TO US FINALLY I
WOULD SAY.
THE FIVE YEAR PROHIBITION THAT'S
BEEN -- MENTIONED IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO US THAT
REALLY MAKES NO SENSE BECAUSE
AGAIN FROM A SCIENTIFIC
VIEWPOINT.
HONEY IN IS NOT A PROBLEM
THERE'S NO REASON TO HAVE A BAN
ON IT.
AND REALLY ALL YOU'RE DOING THEN
IS REMOVING -- DATA THAT COULD
BE HELPFUL THE POPULATION WHEN
WE GO OUT TIME HARBORS OF THESE
ANIMALS WE KNOW HOW MANY ARE
TAKEN AND THAT HELPS TO SUSTAIN
ONLY SUSTAINABLY MANAGED SPC
OVER THE LONG TERM SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER HENLEY.
OKAY -- OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MY NAME IS JIM WATER
SENATE REPRESENT TO THE CUP
COUNTRY AT THE CONGRESSIONAL
SUPPORT AND CAUCUS.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION AND
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR NORTH
AMERICA WHILE SHE I'D LIKE TO
CONCUR WITH MY PREDECESSORS ON
BOTH A COMMENT OPPOSITION ADD.
THAT.
SEEKS WHAT YOUR OPPOSITION IS
VERY QUICK DOCUMENT IS PART OF
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
MANDATE THAT IS NOT MENTIONED
BEFORE THANKS OR HE MADE THAT
POINT ALL RIGHT YET.
OTHER AT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE I HAVE FOR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
BUT YET MR BIGELOW.
DOES MOVED IT AND THAT IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED I BELIEVE THE
SENATE MEMBER TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS AND SECONDED BY MISS
REAVIS.
YES MISTER BIGELOW.
MISSTEP MAYBE YOU COULD TAKE AN
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS ARE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE HERE BOTH BY.
HE'S OF THE OPPOSITION.
SEEM REASONABLE MAYBE YOU COULD
ANSWER.
WHY ARE YOU?
TAKING AN ACTION TO OUT RIGHT DO
A MORATORIUM WHEN THERE IS --
STUDIES THAT NEED TO BE DONE TO
MAY BE JUSTIFIED DOING A
MORATORIUM.
SO I WILL LET.
ALL THIS ADDED THAT REALLY
QUICKLY BECAUSE I I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT POINT I HAVE BEEN
HERE THE SO IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLY THREE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
ONE BOBCATS WERE TAKEN.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
YEAR. TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE IN
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
YEAR -- THE REPRODUCTIVE RATES
FAR EXCEED THE RATE OF HARVEST.
THE PREVIOUS THERE HAS BEEN NO
STUDY THAT SHOWS THAT THEY ARE
THREATENED AT THIS TIME AND I
THINK THAT WAS THE BIG POINT THE
COMMISSIONER BROUGHT UP IS.
ABSENT SOME CLEAR SCIENCE IT'S
HARD TO DO A A BAND AND YOU
BROUGHT REALLY SHOULDN'T PROCEED
WITH THE MORATORIUM.
UNTIL WE HAVE THAT SO WHY NOT DO
THE STUDY.
FIRST SO THAT WE KNOW REALLY
WHAT'S GOING ON AND THEN WE
COULD PROCEED TO A BAD WHAT
RATHER THAN DOING THE BAND AND
THE STUDY.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE SCIENCE AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL HERE IN AGREEMENT THAT THE
SCIENCES AND ON EITHER SIDE.
AND UNTIL IT IS WE SHOULD STOP
THE HUNTING BE ABLE TO GET THE
DATA I THINK IT'S VERY HARD FOR
THE PRO HUNTING IS YES. TO MAKE
THEIR ARGUMENTS AGAINST A
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD MANDATE
THE GATHERING TO EXTRACT THE
SCIENTIFIC DATA.
OKAY YES MISTER.
SO CAN I CAN HELP YOU CAN I DO
NEED EVERITT YET ALL RESPOND TO
THAT AS WELL -- I JUST ONE AGAIN
IT'S IT'S ALSO BASED ON HUMAN
VALUES AND WE'VE DONE IT WE'VE
DONE A SURVEY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ABOUT 70% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
OPPOSED TO TROPHY HUNTING.
AND WE DEFINE TROPHY HUNTING AS
WHERE A PERSON'S PRIMARY
MOTIVATION IS TO KILL AN ANIMAL
IN ORDER TO DISPLAY BODY PARTS
OR TO STUFF THE ANIMAL THEY TAKE
A SELFIE WITH THE ANIMAL IT'S
NOT NO ONE EATS BOBCAT.
OR THEIR OR THEY'RE SELLING THE
FIRS ABROAD.
SO.
ESSENTIALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN
END OF TROPHY HUNTING A BOBCATS.
AND THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS IN THE
BILL THAT STILL ALLOW FOR THE
KILLING OF BOBCATS I THINK THERE
ARE NUMBER OF EXEMPTIONS THAT
ARE LISTED SO IT'S NOT.
AND I WANT TO SAY IT'S NOT AN
OUTRIGHT MORATORIUM BUT THERE
ARE INSTANCES WHERE THE KILLING
OF BOBCATS.
WOULD BE ALLOWABLE -- IF THERE'S
BODILY HARM IF THEY'RE ATTACKING --
LIVESTOCK OR PETS IF YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
IF YOU HAVE A PERMIT SO IT'S
IT'S NOT AN OUTRIGHT MORATORIUM
AND IN FACT -- AS WAS MENTIONED
WE HAVE TAKEN COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND OUR HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE
COMMISSION -- THEY YOU KNOW
AFTER MOMENTS COME INTO PRINT SO
THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS YOU KNOW
FURTHER ALONG.
BUT IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO KIND
OF STUDY THE ACTIONS TO TAKE A
PAUSE AND STUDY BOTH THE AFFECTS
OF THE BIO DIVERSITY -- IN OUR
ECOSYSTEM YOU KNOW WITH THE
BOBCATS WITH THEM REDUCING AND
NUMBER -- AND ALLOW THE DATA TO
SHARE WITH THIS.
TO HELP THE STATE UNDERSTAND --
AND DECIDE HOW IT WANTS TO
CONTINUE TO ACT AS IT RELATES TO
THE BOBCAT.
SOUL.
YES GO AHEAD AS WE MAKE A QUICK
CORRECTION -- HUNTERS CANNOT
SELL THE BOBCATS OUT OF STATE
THERE'S A BAN ON COMMERCIAL TRAP
YOU CAN'T SELL THESE BELTS THAT
ALSO PEOPLE USE THEM.
AND THEIR HOME AND AND WE WILL
IN THE DISCUSSIONS WE HAD ABOUT
IT DURING A VERY LONG MULTI YEAR
PROCESS ON THE BAY COMMERCIAL
BOBCAT TRAPPING.
IT WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT WHILE
IT'S TRUE THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
EAT BOBCAT THAT -- THE MOSTTHAT
ARE USED FOR PELTS BY THE PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO MINUTES AND IT'S A
YOU KNOW IT'S WORLD FOLKS IN IN
YOU KNOW IN VERY SMALL NUMBERS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBERS
NOW WE GOTTA GET IT THAT THAT'S
CRITICAL ON THE LAST THAT EACH
OTHER SOMETHING AROUND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND I BELIEVE CLOSE
THAT SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND A
LONG TIME AGO.
BUT THERE'S NO INDICATION IT'S
GOING DOWN AND WE WOULD
CERTAINLY WELCOME A PETITION IF
THEY'RE SCIENCE THAT SAYS.
THAT WE NEED TO LIST THE SPECIES
RIGHT AWAY WE WE TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND THAT'S WERE MORE
TORY COMMITTED PLACE BRENT SO
ODD.
TRYING TO GET TO THE CONCERN
HERE WHICH IS.
WHY NOT GO THROUGH A BUDGET
PROCESS AND WORK WITH THE
COMMISSION?
WHY WASN'T THERE THOUGHT MAYBE
TO THE SPONSORS? TO ACTUALLY ASK
FOR A REQUEST FOR FUNDING.
SO THAT THE COMMISSION COULD
THEN DO THE LONG TERM STUDY OR
SHORT TERM STUDY HOWEVER IT
COMES ABOUT.
SO THAT WE COULD IDENTIFY.
IS THERE A NEED IS ARE WE ARE A
PURPOSE OR PLACE FOR A
MORATORIUM FOR THIS SPECIES
COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT WELL
AGAIN -- MOST PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA DO NOT WANT TO HAVE A
TROPHY HUNT ON BOBCATS AND WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO WOULD GET
FUNDING TO THE AGENCY SO THEY
CAN STUDY THEM.
AND YOU KNOW SOME OF THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE RIGHT NOW IS
IS YOU'VE GOT TO USE REMOTE
CAMERA TECHNOLOGY -- ESPECIALLY
WITH BOBCATS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
UNIQUE PATTERN IT'S IT'S EASY
IT'S EASY TO USE THOSE KIND OF
REMOTE CAMERAS SO.
YOU KNOW.
COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS THEY
COULD PROBABLY YOU DO A PRETTY
GOOD SIZE STUDY IN CALIFORNIA.
ON BOBCT SO LET'S LET'S GET THE
FUNDING LET'S DO IT LET'S LET'S
PUT A MORATORIUM LET'S STUDY.
BOBCATS LET'S SEE WHAT'S GOING
ON AND WHEN YOU PUT THOSE
CAMERAS OUT THERE NOT ONLY ARE
YOU SEEING WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
BOBCATS BUT YOU CAN STUDY OTHER
ANIMALS TOO SO IT'S A IT'S A WIN
WIN SITUATION.
I I AGREE THAT THERE CAN BE A
WIN WIN SITUATION.
BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT.
AS WE LOOK AT BOB CATS THEY ARE
PREDATORS AND INTO THEMSELVES
AND AS A GROWING SPECIES THEY'RE
HAVING AN IMPACT.
ON THE WILD BIRDS.
WE'RE SEEING A DECIMATION OF A
QUAIL AND DUCK POPULATIONS ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE'RE
SEEING OTHER SPECIES WHILE THE
GRADS.
GOING AWAY BECAUSE OF THE
PREDATORS THAT ARE TAKING DOWN
BECAUSE THERE'S AN
OVERPOPULATION THERE'S A HUGE
GROWTH IN THESE ARENAS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU'RE USING INFORMATION.
OF THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHICH
YOU SAID SEVENTY SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IS WHAT THE BASS NUMBER
WAS ON THAT.
AT THAT TIME IN THE SEVENTIES IN
FACT IF WE TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
NUMBER JUST USING SEVENTY
THOUSAND AND WE JUST ASSUME THAT
HALF OF THEM WERE FEMALES AND OF
BEARING.
AGE -- THAT WOULD MEAN. THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND FEMALES COULD HAVE
A POTENTIAL OF SIX LITTERS.
IT'S A POTENTIAL THAT'S WHAT'S
IN RESOURCE RESEARCHED DATA YOU
CAN SAVE MORE OR I'M SAY LESS.
BUT SIX IS THE NUMBER AND THEY
HAVE AN AVERAGE OF EIGHT KITTENS
SO IF WE LOOK AT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND LETTERS OUT OF THAT.
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND AND WE
MULTIPLY THE EIGHT TIMES.
ON THOSE LETTERS THAT'S ONE
POINT SIX MILLION.
KEEP OUR BABY KITTENS THAT ARE
GONNA GROW.
MAN FROM NINETEEN YES MA'AM
NINETEENTH THAT.
YOU MAY WHEN I'M DONE OKAY A SO
WHEN.
OUR KITTENS GROW TO MATURITY
THEY WILL BE ABLE WHICH IT TAKES
A FULL YEAR BEFORE THEY CAN
BREED.
AND THAT NUMBER GOES ON AND
EXTRAPOLATE BUT IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT ONE POINT SIX
MILLION.
I'M GONNA BE FOR TRY TO BE VERY
I'D SAY 90% OF THEM DON'T MAKE
IT.
SO WHEN A MINUTE SORRY.
THAT'S ONE MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND IF WE LOOK AT THE A
NUMBER OF ONE MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND AND
REDUCE THAT FROM THE ONE SIX
THAT'S A HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
NEW KITTENS.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE BEARING
THEIR CONTINUED TO GROW.
WERE IN THAT IN THAT ALMOST TEN
MILLION RANGE.
AS THIS STARTS TO GROW AND EACH
AND EVERY OTHER YEAR THOSE ARE
SPRINGS ARE ABLE TO START.
HAVING LITTLE BABY KITTENS THAT
ARE GOING TO GROW INTO FEMALES
THEY'RE GONNA BEAR MORE KITTENS.
SO THERE'S A A HUGE NUMBER OF
BOBCATS THAT EXIST.
OUT IN THE WORLD SO REALLY THIS
COMES DOWN TO A DEBATE OF
PHILOSOPHICAL -- POSITIONS.
PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT THINGS
TAKEN AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
WANTING TO HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
DO THAT.
AND A THIRD COMPONENT.
HUMAN INTERVENTION TO HELP KEEP
THINGS IN CHECK.
SO NOW HAVING SAID THAT.
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR -- SO BOBCATS DO
NOT REPRODUCE INFINITESIMALLY AS
YOU'VE INDICATED A MOST BOBCAT
KITTENS TO EVEN MAKE IT PAST THE
FIRST YEAR AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
KITTENS THEY HAVE ABOUT THREE ON
AVERAGE.
A FEMALE DOESN'T BECOME MATURE
UNTIL SHE'S ABOUT TWO YEARS OLD
AND THEN SHE'LL HAVE YOU KNOW
ONE LETTER ABOUT EVERY YEAR MOST
OF THOSE KITTENS WILL NOT
SURVIVE.
THE THE BOBCATS ALSO ARE PREYED
UPON BY A DOMESTIC DOGS BY
COYOTES BY MOUNTAIN LIONS -- AND
THEY'RE IN COMPETITION WITH
THOSE SAME CARNIVORES FOR
RESOURCES SO.
I MEAN BOBCATS ARE EXTREMELY
RARE -- COMPARED TO THEIR PREY
SPECIES SO -- YOU'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE AN INFINITESIMAL NUMBER
BOBCATS LOOK AT MOUNTAIN LION --
OUTLINE HUNTING STOPPED IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
AND YOU GUYS WE HAVE SOME OF THE
BEST MOUNTAIN LION POPULATION
AROUND A MOUNTAIN LINES REGULATE
THEIR OWN -- BECAUSE THE THE
OLDER ADULT ANIMALS -- WILL KILL --
INCOMING IMMIGRATING YOUNGER
ANIMALS AND SO THEY THEY
REGULATE THEIR OWN SO WE DON'T
NEED HUMAN INTERVENTION TO
REGULATE BOBCAT POPULATIONS AND
AND CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE.
WITH OUTLINES IS SHOWN THAT'S
THAT TO BE.
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT I I
WOULD SAY THAT WE BOTH HAVE DONE
A RESEARCH ON ON THIS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
PRESENTS THAT INFORMATION AS TO
THE REPRODUCTION AND THOSE
NUMBERS.
IN IN THEIR OWN -- ON OUR
WEBSITE AND THERE ARE OTHER
WEBSITES THAT PRODUCE THAT SAME
INFORMATION THAT I CITED THAT'S
WHY UTILIZED IT BECAUSE IT WOULD
YOU CAN GO ON GO BILLION GO ON
ANY SEARCH ENGINE.
AND YOU CAN FIND THAT SAME
INFORMATION AND I I GRANTED THE
FACT OF MORTALITY WHEN I GAVE A
90% MORTALITY RATE -- WITHIN THE
RANGE.
AND AS I GIVE THAT RANGE.
THE NUMBERS ARE STILL.
IN THE MILLIONS.
AND IF YOU GET IF YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO GO OUT AND LOOK IN THE
WILD.
YOU GET TO SEE THE BOBCATS ON A
REGULAR BASIS AT LEAST I'M ABLE
TO GO OUT ON A REGULAR BASIS.
AND SEE HIM AND ENJOY HIM.
I THINK THEY'RE CUTE THEY'RE
FINE YOU GET TO WATCH A ROMP AND
PLAY AND THAT'S ALL ALL GOOD
THINGS BUT THE SAME TIME I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE AN OVERPOPULATION --
WHICH I'M SEEING.
THAT'S A PART OF THE ISSUE
THAT'S GOING INTO OTHER AREAS
WHICH THEY ARE TAKING DOWN OUR
POPULATION OF WILD BIRDS.
AND THAT'S A REAL ISSUE AND
THAT'S WHY I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
OF A STUDY BEFORE WE GO INTO A
FULL MORATORIUM TO SEE WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE.
AND I AND WE WANT TO STUDY TO A
DEGREE ANECDOTAL BUT IT IS OR
NOT SO WHAT I WANT TO DO IS IS
IS THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COULD I WAS MORE OF A COMMENT
THAN IT WAS EXHAUSTION -- SO ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY I WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AROUND MEMBER FAMILY HOW JUST
SAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OUT
I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING.
YOU KNOW MISTER BIGELOW IS
CORRECT THIS IS A VALUE BASED
CONVERSATION ABOUT PRESERVING
OUR NATURAL ECOSYSTEM AND
STUDYING BIO DIVERSITY WHILE
PROTECTING A SPECIES I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR AGAIN THIS
IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
I WILL BE OPPOSE IN THE BILL
TODAY -- MYSELF -- AND FOR A LOT
OF THE REASONS STATED BY MR
BIGELOW I DO THINK THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE A STUDY FIRST BEFORE WE
DO.
A MORATORIUM -- AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S THE REASON FOR MY
OPPOSITION DEFINITELY IMPORTANT
ISSUE SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING INTO BUT I THINK WE
NEED.
TO DO IT IN IN THE RIGHT WAY SO
WITH THAT -- MEASURE WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER NOEL GALLAGHER NO.
BIGELOW.
HELLO NO CHOI.
CHOI NO CHIU.
CHIU I DALLY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA GLORIA
[inaudible]
CHOLERA [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I THREE THREE ON CALL YES
THREE TO THREE EMILY THAT ARE
CALLED WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY A LOT
OF ABSENT MEMBERS RIGHT NOW
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
I ALSO WANTED TO RECOGNIZE THREE
OF US ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS IS
WITH US JOIN US SUBSTITUTING IN
TODAY -- SO WELCOME TO THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
WE GET A LOT OF INTERESTING
THINGS ON THE DOCKET TODAY.
OKAY SO NEXT UP WE HAVE MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR MR MAJOR IS VERY EFFICIENT
SO I KNOW HE WILL GET THAT
QUICKLY.
AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
YOU.
AND I WILL I GET MY BEST
EFFICIENT PRESENTATION YEAH
MISTER CHAIR I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS US.
I WANT I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
AS PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS
THOUSANDS OF BIG EXOTIC ANIMALS
ARE KILLED FOR THEIR SKINS EACH
YEAR THESE ANIMALS -- SUPPER FOR
THE SAKE OF FASHION -- IN VANITY
EVEN WHEN ALTERNATIVES EXIST
THERE ARE A BROAD ARRAY OF
LUXURIOUS CRUELTY.
FREE MATERIALS AVAILABLE FOR USE
INCLUDING EMBOSSED IMITATION
LEATHER THAT LOOKS AND FEELS
LIKE EXOTIC SKIN WITHOUT THE
CRUELTY.
SEVERAL LARGE REALLY.
TAYLOR'S HAVE ALREADY LED THE
CHARGE IN BANNING THE SCANS
INCLUDING CHANEL AND TAYLOR HMM
ADIDAS AND VICTORIA'S SECRET TO
NAME A FEW.
AB TWELVES.
AB TWELVE SIXTY WOULD BAN THE
SALE OF IN THE IMPORTATION WITH
INTENT TO SELL -- OF IGUANAS
HIPPOS CAYMANS AND SEVERAL
SPECIES OF LIZARDS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR HANNAH
SHINE AND NEXT SACKETT.
HI I'M HANNAH SHINE I'M SPEAKING
TO YOU AGAIN ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
FOR THE ETHICAL TREATMENT OF
ANIMALS AND ARE MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA. TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWELVE
SIXTY WHICH WILL EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF SPECIES PROTECTED FROM
THE CRUEL AN UNSUSTAINABLE
EXOTIC SKINS INDUSTRY.
REPTILE SUFFER IMMENSELY IN THE
EXOTIC SKINS TRADE.
HUNTERS SNARE WILD LIZARDS CUT
THEM APART WITH MACHETES SEVER
THEIR HEADS AND SKIN THEM. ONE
OF OUR VIDEO EXPOSES WHICH YOU
CAN SEE ON OUR WEBSITE PETER DOT
ORG SHOWS A LIZARD WRITHING IN
AGONY AS SHE SKINNED ALIVE. FOR
WORK A SPECIALIST AND REPTILE
BIOLOGY IN WELFARE STATES THAT
BECAUSE REPTILES HAVE A SLOW
METABOLISM THEY CAN REMAIN ALIVE
FOR UP TO AN HOUR AFTER THEY'VE
BEEN DECAPITATED AND SKINNED.
CAYMANS ARE HUNTED AND KILLED IN
THEIR NATURAL HOMES OFTEN BY
BEING CRUDELY SHOT IN THE HEAD
SO THAT THEIR SKINS CAN BE
TURNED INTO BAGS BOOTS AND OTHER
ACCESSORIES.
THIS CRUEL TRADE HAS LED SOME
SPECIES TO BECOME NEARLY EXTINCT.
THEY'RE ALSO CAPTAIN FETID WATER
ON CROWDED FARMS WHICH ARE OFTEN
STOPPED BY STEALING ADULTS FROM
THE WILD AND FORCING THEM TO
BREED IN CAPTIVITY.
ALTHOUGH THEY CAN LIVE TO BE
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD FARMS
CAYMANS ARE KILLED BEFORE THEY
EVEN REACH MATURITY.
PASSING A. B. TWELVE SIXTY WOULD
SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
KILLING EXOTIC ANIMALS FOR THEIR
SKINS HAS NO PLACE IN A
COMPASSIONATE SOCIETY.
PUBLIC SENTIMENT AGAINST THE USE
OF EXOTIC SKINS IS GROWING
AROUND THE WORLD.
CHANEL STELLA MCCARTNEY DIANE
VON FURSTENBERG VICTORIA BECKHAM
AND NUMEROUS OTHER MAJOR
DESIGNERS AND RETAILERS HAVE
ALREADY BANNED EXOTIC SKINS FROM
THEIR DESIGNS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
FORWARD THINKING STATE AND YOU
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO SET
A COMPASSIONATE EXAMPLE BY
SUPPORTING A. B. TWELVE SIXTY
THANK YOU.
HELLO CHAIR COMMITTEE THANK YOU
PROUD OF ME MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SOCKET SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION -- I WON'T REPEAT
WHAT THE AUTHOR AND HANNAH SAID
BUT I WOULD JUST REITERATE THAT --
A POLL WITH THEM LAST YEAR AND
75% OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT A
BAN ON EXOTIC SKINS AND RETAIL --
AT THE OTHER MENTION THERE ARE
PLENTY OF ALTERNATIVES FOR THESE
KINDS OF PRODUCTS A WE DON'T
NEED TO BE SELLING THEM IN OUR
STORES IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD JUST SIMPLY SAY THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR -- FOR OFFERING THE
BILL AND PLEASE SUPPORT BUILT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S MOVED -- AS
AMENDED WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THEIR SECOND.
SECOND ABOUT THIS REAVIS.
OKAY ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
AGAIN THIS IF WE GET STATE NAME
AND WELL NOT YOU SUPPORT CHRIS
SOMEONE ON BEHALF THE MEANS THE
SIDE OF THE UNITED STATES AND
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY LEWIS ON BEHALF OF PITA
WHEN THE BRAMBLE SACRAMENTO ON
BEHALF OF DIRECT ACTION A BURN
ON OF US FOR THE VOICELESS AND
IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS WITH OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
SUPPORT?
KAREN LAFFEY LARKSPUR CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
THE LITTLE FOURTH IN SUPPORT
FROM OF REPRESENTING POP PACK.
PIZZA AND IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS.
SUSAN KIRKPATRICK PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MARKET KIRKPATRICK TURKEY
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
LINDSEY LIARS ANIMAL LEGAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT THE BILL.
CAROL MISSILE DINE HUMANE
SOCIETY THAT IS STATES IN
SUPPORT.
LESLEY GOLDBERG ELSE RIDEAU
REPRESENTING COMPASSIONATE BAY
IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG EL SERENO
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE AND
IT'S THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS.
IN SUPPORT.
CARE GARCIA SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JACOBY MARINO SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JANET PROVIDE SAID DAVIS
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WE SAW -- IN VIANI RAPTORS ARE
THE SOLUTIONS STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIN HOW THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF
THE UNITED STATES STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
PIPER KRYSTLE FOLSOM CALIFORNIA
EACH HAS U. S. -- STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
SURE MONTU FAVORS CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
JEAN TRAP DAVIS CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE BIOLOGIST FOR THIRTY
YEARS I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS.
MA'AM REAL QUICKLYJUST A I
DON'T MIND IF YOU FILM AT ALL
BUT MAYBE BACK AWAY FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS AS ACT YEAH.
YES GO AHEAD FREE THE RETREAT
FROM SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
FUNDED TOMLINSON PROJECT KOTV IN
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF WILDLIFE
REHABILITATED AS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S LAMONT BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH REPRESENTS
SOLUTIONS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BRIAN AGREE FROM DAVIS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
BRING TO CARRY FROM DAVIS
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MELISSA HOUSES SMELL FROM DAVIS
LILY KIRBY DAVIS STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
TERRI BARNATO COLFAX CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL WITH JAY IN
A NEWS NETWORK WE ISSUED.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIA O'DONNELL GRASS VALLEY AND
I'M STRONGLY SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
STACEY SANDERS GRASS VALLEY
STRONGLY SUPPORTING.
HOPO HAND THEY CAN HELP GROWTH
SUPPORT.
SUSAN SIDNEY DENT FRANKLIN
VILLAGE STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
K. CYBER ARANDA SUPPORTING THE
JUDY MANN COUSTEAU SPONSOR
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
I'M HERE FOR DR GARY MICHAELSON
AND PEACE FOR ANIMALS THANK YOU.
OKAY THE OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OKAY WILL BRING IT
BACK HERE TO THE COMMITTEE --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MR
MAIENSCHEIN YES MISTER BIGELOW.
MEET MAYBE IT'S NOT FOR MR
MAIENSCHEIN MAYBE IS FOR ONE OF
THE PRESENTERS.
YOU GAVE US A A FACTOR HERE OF
75% OF THE PEOPLE SUPPORTED AND
YOU YOU SPOKE ABOUT OF ALL COULD
YOU PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH A
COPY OF OF THE POLAND THE
PULLING SAMPLE.
AND HOW THE QUESTIONS WERE
FRAMED.
ABSOLUTELY WE COULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION I HAVE IT WITH ME.
GREAT.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
OKAY BRING IT BACK -- SO THIS
DOES HAVE A DO PASS WAS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR --
SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED.
MATTER QUICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION.
BUT YOU KNOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
CHOI.
CHOI NO.
CHIU.
CHIU I VALLEY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
AREA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I FIVE TWO TWO ONE OKAY
THAT HAS TO VOTE SINCE ON CALL
WE GOT SOME APPS MEMBERS SPECS
PICTURE YEAH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MISTER BLOOM I THINK
WE AS UP NEXT.
BUT HE IS PRESENT IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE GONNA GO OUT
OF WATER AND WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO MISTER FLORA
[inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
NINE COMMITTEES.
AND I HOPE YOU WILL FOLLOW THE
EXAMPLE OF MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
AND MOVE EFFICIENTLY.
THIS YEAR PRISON FOR SUPPORT
RIGHT. OH SORRY NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER TEN I MISSPOKE EARLIER
YOU MISTER FLORA PLEASE PROCEED.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER WOOD
SECONDED BY MISTER CHIU.
I'LL JUST SAY THE HEADER AND
THEN IF THERE'S ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WE WOULD LOVE FOR YOU --
TO MASTER WITNESSES BUT THANK
YOU MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
THE CHAIR -- TODAY WE PRESENT AB.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN IT IS BECAUSE
OF THAT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED HAD MORE NASH'S OPEN UP
FOR QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORTER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER REED THANK YOU TRYING TO
GET IN HI BOB READ WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE VALLEY ATWATER COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE I WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ON THE SIDE OF BUT WE MOVED AND
SECONDED.
DO YOU ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES WE DO OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHTS WE HAVE A DO PASSED
WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MADAM
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER BY GALLAGHER I'D
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU I KELLY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I OKAY. NINE TWO ZERO ON
CALL IN THE NIGHT NINE ZERO I'D
THAT STILL ON CALL AND THANK YOU
MISTER FLORA AND I'M SURE THAT
YOU'LL HAVE THE VOTES BY THE
TIME THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IS
OVER THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER.
WHAT LOWER WAITING FOR MR BLOOM
LET'S TAKE A COUPLE VOTES ON
ITEMS ARE STILL ON CALL?
MAY DO THAT [inaudible]
MADAM CLERK. TO BE DOES TAKE A
COUPLE BIRDS ARE STILL ON CALL
NOW THAT WE HAVE SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BACK.
YEAH.
MAYBE STARTING WITH.
ONE LICCARDO START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE GLORIA.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT GLORIA.
MISSING MEMBERS CHIU.
VALLEY'S TEAR UP HERE NO HE WAS
JUST.
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOOD.
WOULD I SEVEN TWO ONE I DON'T
NUMBER.
TWO WE'LL GO I'M GONNA GET RIGHT
THERE.
ALL YOU WANT TO TAKE IT UP.
HERE REALLY QUICKLY.
VIEW ALL THE GO AHEAD TAKE A
MONTH.
THE BILL.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER SIX MISREAD
WELL I HAVE MISTER BLOOM HERE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET HIM
ALWAYS.
THE HIM US.
SORRY ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
MR BLUE.
YOU ARE A OKAY SIR LAST OF
SPECIAL ORDER -- ITEM -- SO.
MR BLOOM AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU --
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE --
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION ENACTED
REGULATIONS TO RESTRICT THE USE
OF SECOND GENERATION ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
AFTER ALARMING DATA FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF WILDLIFE FOUND
THAT NON TARGETED WILDLIFE WITH
SUCCUMBING.
TO SECONDARY INFECTIONS LIKE
MANGE DUE TO THE WAY THE
RODENTICIDE AFFECTED THEIR
SYSTEMS. FOR THOSE OF FIVE YOU
MAY NOT KNOW MANGES AND NORMALLY
LETHAL -- BUT DUE TO THE EFFECTS
THAT ANTI COAGULANT TAP ON THE
ANIMALS A BLOCKS THEIR ABILITIES
TO FIGHT OFF OR HE'LL NORMALLY --
NON LETHAL AILMENTS POISONINGS
AND DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN DOCUMENTED IN NUMEROUS
SPECIES SUCH AS EAGLES HAWKS
FALCONS AL'S BOBCATS.
MOUNTAIN LINES AND EVEN THE
IMPERILED SAN JOAQUIN KIT FOX IN
NORTHERN SPOTTED OWL.
THE PROBLEM IS SO SEVERE THAT
OVER 70% OF WILDLIFE TESTED IN
CALIFORNIA HAD BEEN EXPOSED TO
RODENTICIDE STE -- THESE ARE
DENNIS SITES POSE AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO CHILDREN%
PETS AND DOMESTIC ANIMALS AS
WELL.
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED PAT'S
NEEDLESSLY DIE EACH YEAR DUE TO
RODENTICIDE EXPOSURE.
ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS AT UCLA
VIRTUALLY EVERY MOUNTAIN LION
THAT THE AT THAT UCLA AND THE
NPS OF TESTED AND 90% OF THE
BOBCATS TESTED FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
TEST POSITIVE FOR ANTI COAGULANT
THROW DOWN THE SIDES BOTH FIRST
AND SECOND GENERATION.
SO AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIX
TO TAKE STRONGER MEASURES TO
PROTECT CHILDREN PETS AND
WILDLIFE FROM THE UNINTENTIONAL
RODENTICIDE POISONINGS BY
BANNING THE USE AND SALE OF
SECOND GENERATION.
ANTI COAGULANT RODENTICIDE
STATEWIDE AND THE USE OF FIRST
GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE ON STATE OWNED
PROPERTY.
THE OPPOSITION MAY SPEAK OF
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES IF WE
WERE TO BAN SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
BUT THE FACT IS WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHICH HAS RESULTED
IN THE UNEXPECTED ONGOING DOUBTS
OF NON TARGETED WILDLIFE.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE MEANS OF
CONTROLLING RODENT POPULATIONS
ARE INCREASINGLY BEING DEVELOPED
AND SUCCESSFULLY IS BY PEST
MANAGEMENT AND THIS BY THE PAST
MANAGEMENTINDUSTRY.
IN THIS OFFERS SAID A GOOD DEAL
OF HOPE TO US.
AT THESE -- INCLUDING TO THE
OPPOSITION -- INCLUDE EIGHT NOT
A NEW ANTI COAGULANT RODENTICIDE
THAT DOESN'T PERSIST AFTER THE
TARGETED ANIMAL HAS INGESTED
THEM.
HI.
I'LL CONTINUE TO WORK -- WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD AND MY WITNESSES
HERE TODAY ARE LENDS THE LIARS
WITH THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND.
AND LISA -- ENDS WITH THE GROUP
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION OR RATS
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
FRIEDMAN AND SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA -- SO GOT
A MOTION AND A SECOND GO HEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS LISA --
INS VIANI AND I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF RAPTORS ARE THE
SOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEMS PROTECTION
ACT WE ARE A STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO EDUCATING PEOPLE
ABOUT THE ECOLOGICAL ROLE OF
BIRDS OF PREY.
AND THE IMMINENT DANGER THEY AND
OTHER WILDLIFE FACE FROM RAT
POISON IN THE ECOSYSTEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND AGAIN
IN TWENTY ELEVEN COOPER'S HAWKS
WERE FOUND BLEEDING TO DEATH ON
THE STREET IN MY BAY AREA
NEIGHBORHOOD.
TESTS REVEALED THAT THE HAWKS
HAD BEEN SECONDARILY POISONED
AFTER CONSUMING POISON RESIDENTS.
THE POISONS FOUND IN THEIR
LIVERS WERE SECOND GENERATION
ANTI COAGULANT SO STRONGLY ARE
MARKETED AS ONE FEEDING KILLS.
I QUICKLY DISCOVERED THAT
SECONDARY POISONING WAS A
STATEWIDE PROBLEM AFFECTING ALL
OF THE BENEFICIAL WILDLIFE THAT
HELP US CONTROL RODENTS
NATURALLY OWLS HAWKS EAGLES
BOXES MOUNTAIN LIONS BOBCATS AND
MANY OTHERS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN DUE TO THE
DANGER THESE PRODUCTS POSE TO
NON TARGET WILDLIFE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION REMOVED THEM FROM
CONSUMER SELVES.
HOWEVER SCIENTIFIC DATA
COLLECTED SINCE THAT TIME SHOW
THE PROBLEM HAS NOT IMPROVED
BECAUSE THE PEST CONTROL
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO USE THESE
PRODUCTS WHICH KILL FAR MORE
THAN RATS.
STUDIES SHOW THAT POISON RODENTS
ARE PREFERENTIALLY PREYED UPON
BECAUSE THEY ARE SIX SLUGGISH
AND EASIER TO CATCH.
STUDIES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY UC
DAVIS UCLA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES FOUND THAT
70% OF NORTHERN SPOTTED OWLS A
THREATENED SPECIES TESTED
POSITIVE FOR ROUTE POISON.
MORE THAN 85% OF CALIFORNIA
MOUNTAIN LIONS BOBCATS AT
PACIFIC FISHERS HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THESE DANGEROUS
POISONS.
THE POISONS DID NOT IMMEDIATELY
KILL THESE ANIMALS THEY CAN HAVE
SUB LEGAL IMPACTS INCLUDING
AFFECTING THE GENES THAT
REGULATE THE IMMUNE SYSTEM.
THIS MEANS ANIMALS LIKE BOBCATS
MOUNTAIN ON LANDS A COYOTES ARE
LESS ABLE TO FEND OFF DISEASES
LIKE MANGE.
STUDIES ON YOUNG BARN OWLS THAT
HAVE CONSUMED POISON RODENTS
FOUND LOWER BIRTH WEIGHTS AND
SHORTER WINGS AND LEG BONES.
OTHER NEW STUDIES JUST COMING
OUT HAVE FOUND SECOND GENERATION
ANTI COAGULANT IN FISH AND RIVER
OTTERS.
RAT POISON HAS SO SUCCESSFULLY
INFILTRATED CALIFORNIA'S
ECOSYSTEMS THAT MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED OUR NEW DDT.
THESE POISONS ARE HAVING A
CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON OUR
NATIVE WILDLIFE THE LONGER THEY
CONTINUED TO BE USED THE MORE
HARM WE WILL SEE PLEASE TAKE
ACTION TODAY TO STOP IT THANK
YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
MORNING COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS
LINDSAY LARSON I'M SPEAKING ON
HOW THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND AND OUR THIRTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I I WILL BELIEVERS IN THE POINT
THIRTY REYES BEFORE I'LL TRY TO
KEEP THIS BRIEF BUT I JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS A FEW ISSUES THAT
HAVE COME UP ON THIS BILL.
WE HAVE HAD -- TWO BILLS BEFORE
THIS HER TWO ACTS AS AS LOU
MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
MENTIONS -- TO TRY TO MITIGATE
THE PROBLEM -- THE DVR
REGULATING CONSUMER USE AND ALSO
BANS ON STATE PROPERTY.
THAT HAS NOT WORKED THIS IS THE
NEXT LOGICAL STEP SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ONLY BANS CERTAIN
TYPES OF PRODUCTS THAT WILL
STILL BE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE CHEMICALS AVAILABLE. TO THE
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS TO USE IN
ADDITION TO NON LETHAL METHODS
AS WELL.
THE OTHER ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EXEMPTION AS
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
SEEN WE REMOVE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
THAT TALKS ABOUT A PROCESS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH.
A PUBLIC HEALTH EXEMPTION STILL
EXISTS IN THIS BILL.
AS REFERRED TO IN SECTION II OF
THE BILL.
THIS IS THE SECTION DOES NOT
PREEMPT OR SIT OR SUPERSEDE ANY
FEDERAL STATUTE.
THE FEDERAL INSECTICIDE
FUNGICIDE AND RODENTICIDE ACT
PROVIDES A PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH.
SECTION EIGHTEEN OF THE ACT
ALLOWS THE AUTHORITY TO ALLOW
FEDERAL OR STATE AGENCY THE
ABILITY TO GRANT THE USE OF A
PESTICIDE PRODUCT WITHOUT
REGISTRATION.
IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY
CONDITION MOREOVER THE ACT EVEN
HAS AN EXPLICIT SPECIAL CRISIS
EXEMPTION PRISON PROVISION.
THAT ALLOWS THE HEAD OF A
FEDERAL OR STATE AGENCY. TWO I
AM.
ALLOWED TO USE THIS PRODUCT
WITHOUT.
APPROVAL TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
AND IN SHORT JUST TO BE CLEAR
THAT SEVENTY EIGHT DOES PROVIDE
A PUBLIC HEALTH EXEMPTION WE ARE
AWARE OF THIS RISK AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT -- ADDITIONALLY
WHILE WE KNOW THE DEPARTMENT HAS
SIDE REGULATION AGREE TO A
SECOND GENERATION.
EVALUATION PROCESS WE BELIEVE
THE LEGISLATION IS THE NECESSARY
STEP IN ORDER TO PROTECT
WILDLIFE DPR TO FOURTEEN YEARS
THE LAST TIME THAT ENGAGE IN A
REEVALUATION.
THAT'S THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS THAT
ARE GOING TO DIE DURING THE TIME
PENDING IF THE RE EVALUATION
PROVIDES DIFFERENT RESULTS THAN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE ROBUST
DATA SO FAR.
THERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEGISLATION IN THE FUTURE.
LASTLY NOW IS A SCIENCE
DEMONSTRATE A CLEAR NEED FOR
LEGISLATIVE ACTION RIGHT NOW
SUCH ACTION IS SUPPORTED BY
GROUND SWELL OF PUBLIC SUPPORT
FOR RESIDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S TWENTY NINE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
ENACTED RESOLUTIONS DISCOURAGING
THE CELEBRATE DOWN TO SIZE BY
LOCAL BUSINESSES.
THIS INCLUDES RICHMOND WIN HERE.
A SANTA CRUZ AS WELL AS HUMBOLDT
COUNTY.
LA CITY HAS A BAN -- OUT
POLICIES NOT USE WRITTEN SIZE ON
CITY PARK LANDS LA CITY WHO'S
GOING THERE CRISIS RIGHT NOW
STILL HAS A LETTER OF SUPPORT
FROM COUNCILMEMBER POCKET WE
COULD DISRUPT THAT ARE REALLY
QUICK -- JUST IT'S IN CONCLUSION
JUST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE AYE IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
CRYSTAL MARLON ON BEHALF OF THE-HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES WE RESPECT AND I VOTE.
JEAN TRAPPED DAVIS CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL BIOLOGISTS WHILE IT
BALANCES FOR THIRTY YEARS I
SUPPORT THIS.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ASPEN US
ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CAROL MISSILE DINE ON WE HAVE A
FUND FOR ANIMALS SUPPORT.
JOHN MCTERNAN CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS CERTIFIED WILDLIFE
BIOLOGIST IN SUPPORT. ONE PUBLIC
ALONE NINETIES MANAGER FOR SAY
MONTH DOUBLE ON THE HAVE A FOR
TEN THOUSAND MEASURE MEMBERS WE
SUPPORT.
JANET COVERS ON BEHALF OF
RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION AND
PROJECT COYOTE I SUPPORT.
JOE CORBIN RECENTLY RETIRED UC
DAVIS THAT SCHOOL I'VE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
ERIN HELGI PROJECT COYOTE AND
HUMANE SOCIETY FOR THE UNITED
STATES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
AFTER MONTHS REPRESENTS SOLUTION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IN THE MIDDLE FOURTH POP PACK
PIZZA AND THE DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
SUPPORT.
CHEN MON TO DAVIS CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HYPER KRYSTLE HSUS STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS
STRONGLY SUPPORT?
NICHOLAS SECOND SOCIAL QUESTION
LEGISLATION IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA HOUSES SMELL DAVIS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT.
ANA TOMLINSON PROJECT KOTC
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL WAS LIFE
REHABILITATIVE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CASE IVORY ORINDA CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HOPO HANNEKE ELK GROVE SUPPORT.
SUSAN CITY DENVER SAN QUENTIN
VILLAGE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
CLEARLY KIRBY HUMANE SOCIETY
SUPPORT.
JENNY KEATING CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY SUPPORT.
THERE WERE COSTA NEVADA
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO SPEAK FOR
MY DOG SOPHIE FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
SECONDARY POISON LONG AGONIZING
DEATH PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LISA CARLIN FROM THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL JAY IN A
NEWS NETWORK WE'VE ISSUED
EDITORIAL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
SOME ANDREAS SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI JENNIFER KENNEDY FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND HSUS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PRIDE ACRE FROM LAW OFFICES OF
CARRYING A GREEN DAVIS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORT.
BRING TO CARRY FROM DAVIS
SUPPORT.
STACEY SANDERS GRASS VALLEY
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MARIE O'DONNELL GRASS VALLEY AND
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GUARDADO COLFAX CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
BRENT MEDINAN BE HAVE A MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND FRIENDS OF THE LOS
ANGELES FOR PARENTS AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISS CHEN MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GIVE IT MAKE SOME ROOM HERE FOR
THEIR LIVES [inaudible]
THE HEAD.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY.
MY NAME IS SYLVIA CAN MAYOR I'M
A BOARD CERTIFIED ENTOMOLOGIST
WITH THE PEST CONTROL OPERATORS
OF CALIFORNIA.
BOARD MEMBERS DO YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW MANY ROADS IT WOULD TAKE TO
CAUSE THE DISEASE OUTBREAK
[inaudible] ONE A QUICK CHECK
ON THE CENTER OF DISEASE CONTROL
WEBSITE REVEALS THAT RATS AND
MICE THAT LIVE IN OUR CITIES OUR
HOMES OUR SCHOOLS.
RESTAURANTS AIRPORTS CAN SPREAD
OVER FIFTY DISEASES.
SOME OF THESE DISEASES MAKING
NEWS RIGHT HERE IN OUR STATE.
IF YOU TAKE YOUR FAMILY ON
VACATION TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY YOU
COULD BE DEALING WITH HANTAVRUS.
IF YOU WORK IN DOWNTOWN LA
TYPHUS.
OUR TOOLS FOR ROAD IT MANAGEMENT
ARE NEEDED TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH.
SECOND GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
TO PROVIDE A SWIFT AND COST
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO REDUCE
POPULATIONS OF RATS.
SPREAD.
SPEED IS IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH ROAD IN OUTBREAKS
THE LONGER WE TAKE THE MORE
RODENTS REPRODUCE.
HUMAN HEALTH IS NOT THE ONLY
RISK HERE.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR OUR
AIRPORTS TO HAVE RATS AND MICE
RUNNING EVERYWHERE CHEWING WIRES.
NOW MAKING THIS A PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUE.
WHEN THE WORLD IS WATCHING LOS
ANGELES IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
EIGHT IMAGINE WHAT THEY WILL BE
THINKING WHEN RODENTS ARE
RUNNING EVERYWHERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE BAND ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL WROTE IT MANAGEMENT
TOOLS OF OUR TIME?
AND EXPOSED OUR VISITORS TO
THIRD WORLD DISEASES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS JIM
STATE AND I OWN A LOCAL PEST
CONTROL COMPANY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA WITH ABOUT
THIRTY EMPLOYEES.
WE SERVICE FIVE THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS.
AND ALSO THREE HUNDRED SCHOOLS I
ALSO COME TO YOU TODAY
REPRESENTING THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A AN ORGANIZATION OF
COMPANIES WITH OVER TEN THOUSAND
TECHNICIANS.
THAT WORK ON THIS ISSUE ALMOST
EVERY DAY FACT WHEN YOU HAVE A
RODENT PROBLEM WHERE THE FOLKS
THAT YOU CALL.
I WANT TO PUT A QUICK FACE ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE THAT
THAT MY COLLEAGUE GRAZED.
THE LOS ANGELES DEPUTY ATTORNEY
LIZ GREEN WOULD LAST YEAR
CONTRACTED TYPHUS IN THE COURSE
OF HER JOB WORKING THERE IN CITY
HALL SHE SUFFERED FROM THIS
DISEASE. FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND
IS STILL SUFFERING FROM SOME OF
THE LINGERING EFFECTS.
WHEN WE BRING UP ISSUES OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE PRETTY SERIOUS
THEIR PRESENT AND THEIR
INCREASING IN FACT THE NUMBER OF
TYPE IS CASES IN LA COUNTY LAST
YEAR DOUBLED?
SO IT'S A IT'S A REAL CONCERN
FOR US.
FORTUNATE STAND TO THAT WE HAVE
A VARIETY OF RODENTICIDE SO THAT
WE CAN CHOOSE FROM.
AND OUR INDUSTRY HAS RELEASED.
FAVORED THIS PARTICULAR SET OF
RODENTICIDE BECAUSE THEY ARE
THEIR PROFILE IS VERY FAVORABLE
FOR US THEY HAVE A AT AN
ANTIDOTE THEY WORK QUICKLY AND
THEY DON'T CREATE BAIT SHYNESS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THEY'RE FAIRLY POPULAR SIMPLY
REMOVING THIS TOOL FROM US.
COULD HAVE A LOT OF UNINTENDED
EFFECTS BECAUSE THERE WILL BE
PLENTY OF OTHER RODENTICIDE
REMAINING.
AND THOSE WILL LIKELY BE
EMPLOYED IN PLACE OF THESE WHICH
HAVE A MORE FAVORABLE -- PROFILE
FOR US.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT
WE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
WILDLIFE DAMAGE IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
RECENTLY WERE ABLE TO DELIVER TO
THE AUTHOR SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WE THINK WILL HELP ANSWER THE
QUOTE THE THE CONCERNS WE HAVE
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHILE A COOPERATING WITH THE
INTENT OF HIS BILL.
AND ARE REQUESTED A REALLY IS
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT A VERSION OF
THIS BILL.
THAT ALLOWS FOR THE STRONGEST
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
[inaudible]
AND WITH.
BY A CONSIDERING THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE
DELIVERED TO THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU.
OKAY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WIENER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT A QUEEN.
PRIME A QUEEN TARGET SPECIALLY
PRODUCTS FATHER THREE AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NICK -- SOPPY CALIFORNIA
LIFESTYLE FARMER YOU CUT THE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF WILSON OWNER OF ALL
PROFESS CONTROLLING CORPORATE IN
LOS ANGELES AREA I STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
ROBERT GALLO ON AROUND THE CLOCK
PEST CONTROL I ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS
REBEKAH BASQUE INS ON BEHALF OF
RESPONSIBLE INDUSTRIES FOR A
SOUND ENVIRONMENT AND WESTERN
PLAN HEALTH ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRISTOPHER MORALIS LOCKERS AND
A CALIFORNIA BIOLOGIST STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
CHARLES PASSING TINO FOR
MOUNTAIN VIEW CALIFORNIA
LIFELONG ANIMAL HEALTH ADVOCATES
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TRAVIS FOSTER FROM TERM ANNEX
INTERNATIONAL A REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR COMMERCIAL
I'M LICENSED IN FOUR STATES TO
PASS CONTROL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
OLIVER MENDOZA ROUND THE CLOCK
PEST CONTROL AND I OPPOSE.
ED BROWN TERM ANNEX LOS ANGELES
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JENNIFER FOX WITH TERM ANNEX
FROM HERE TO CALIFORNIA I ALSO
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NO COOKING AS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSE WITH A COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
TIM JUST TAKE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS JOE ACT OR BE
AT THE SYNGENTA PROPOSED.
FOR LESLIE MILIK DOT PASS
CONTROL MADERA STRONGLY
APPROVALS.
STEVE SCOVILLE FAIR OAKS
CALIFORNIA'S CONCERNED CITIZENS
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHUCK TYNDALL WESTERN
EXTERMINATOR STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ROBERT WILLIS TERM ANNEX PRESS
CONTROL LOS ANGELES I OPPOSE.
I'M BOB YOUR VICTOR BIOLOGIST
BOARD CERTIFIED ENTOMOLOGIST NAM
OPPOSED.
FEDERAL SO WEST EXTERMINATOR
FORTIFY ENTOMOLOGIST STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
TERRY THE CADDY DUSTIN PEST
CONTROL FRESNO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TARGETING TERM ANNEX ARMY BOARD
CERTIFIED ENTOMOLOGIST STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
ROBERT DAVIS TERM ANNEX
INTERNATIONAL LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JOHN -- KEY SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA
TERMINATES INTERNATIONAL
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
DAVE HENDRICKS FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA.
AVOID PEST CONTROL STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
TIM USED TO BRIDGE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN EXTERMINATOR STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
HECK COPS WITH OR CAN IN.
EXTERMINATING STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MAC MCALLISTER ABOUT THE TERM
ANNEX AND MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE EMPLOY
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JACKIE CLARK WITH WHAT'S PASS
CONTROL US SERVICES INCLUDING
HUMBOLDT COUNTY IS -- BUTTE
COUNTY -- TO HIM A COUNTY AND
SHASTA COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MARY HERNANDEZ A CONCERNED
CITIZEN FROM SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THEY STILL OWNER PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE SERVING SHASTA COUNTY
TO HIM A COUNTY AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSE.
REBEKAH PURDUE BUT WHAT
CALIFORNIA MCCAULEY I CAN PASSED
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
VENTURE MALE NATIVE CALIFORNIAN
REPRESENTING WE PROTECT STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DAVID ROAD LEADING EDGE PEST
MANAGEMENT I WORK IN THE AS
HERITAGE GOING BERKELEY AREAS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GRAY GRANTEE TARGET SPECIALLY
PRODUCTS LIVE IN CENTER OF THE
CONCERNED CITIZEN AND STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WE GOT THE IS RESIDENT SENATE'S
NO.
ORKIN PEST CONTROL STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
JASON PAIN PAIN PEST MANAGEMENT
OUT OF SAN DIEGO ORANGE COUNTY
LOS ANGELES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
JIM SHAVER OF CARLSBAD
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING --
ATLANTIC PASTE INCLUDING NON
RODENTICIDE MANUFACTURE.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JOE APOLLO O'CONNOR PEST CONTROL
SANTA BARBARA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
RODNEY ALAN HOT RODS HAS CONTROL
ATWATER STRONGLY OPPOSE.
WHO STOLE GUERILLAS ROSE BILL ON
BEHALF OF BAY ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCES STRONGLY OPPOSE?
BARRON MCDONALD CLARK PEST
CONTROL LODI STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JARED BITTEN CLARK PEST CONTROL
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA FATHER OF
SIX AND ABBOTT OUT ANIMAL LOVER
1100% OPPOSED.
DAVE WATKINS O'CONNOR PEST
CONTROL POLITIC CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
MY CAL TO MAYOR AGRICULTURE
INCORPORATED MERCED CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY. THREE ELEVEN FOURTH
GENERATION OWNER. NINETY THREE
YEAR OLD PEST CONTROL COMPANY
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE.
RYAN PENA SAM READING OF
CALIFORNIA US ARMY VETERAN
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SUSAN FREEZE OWNER OF A COLA
TERMITE AND PEST CONTROL FOR
THIRTY NINE YEARS STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
DENNIS JENKINS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL PEST MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JAKE PUBLIX NATIONAL PASS
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
ACTUALLY IN A NATIONAL PEST
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED.
JERRY HOWARD MANAGER HYDRO EXTRA
MIND PEST CONTROL FOR LOS
ANGELES SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA COUNTY.
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
VINCE COLEVILLE PASS CONTROL
CENTER ELDORADO STRONGLY OPPOSE.
DANIEL SLAGLE BELL LABORATORIES
CALL CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ED HERNANDEZ AND SUSPECTS
CORPORATION FROM SANTA MARIA
CALIFORNIA VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED.
SIGN A RENT A KELLER OF
UNIVERSAL OCEANS AND FOLSOM
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE.
ACTUALLY FRIEDMAN VECTOR
BIOLOGIST AT UNIVERSALIST
INSTEAD FOR MARTINEZ AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
PAGE GAIL I'M A LICENSED PEST
CONTROL ADVISER WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JOHN PAINTER DUSTIN PEST CONTROL
I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BLAIR BROOKS COURTS HAVE AGAR
SCIENCE FROM CAL CIVIL
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHUCK SINAL DECORATIVE
DISTRIBUTING OPPOSED.
RUDY ALOT SPEARHEAD PASS CONTROL
INVENTOR CALIFORNIA'S STRONGLY
OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS CARLY A OUR FROM
SPEARHEAD PEST CONTROL IN
VENTURA CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
CHRISTOPHER ATCHISON CLARK PEST
CONTROL OPPOSED.
KRISTEN BELL IN OUR COMMON CORE
BRAIDED MERCED STRONGLY OPPOSED.
GET REAL GOMA'S WITH UNIVAR
SOLUTIONS FROM LAKE ELSINORE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED.
ONLY IF THE DRUGS -- WITH FMC
CORPORATION STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CURT SMITH STARTED SPECIALLY
PRODUCTS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
DEAN WILEY NEWPORT EXTRA READING
MISSION VIEJO STRONGLY OPPOSE.
JOHN WOODWARD LINK IN CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHRIS FROM HOLY PLASTER PASSING
TERMITE MAKING CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
ERIC SMITH LICENSE PEST CONTROL
VISOR FOR TARGET SPECIALLY
PRODUCTS STRONGLY OPPOSED.
DANNY HUTTON SABBATICAL
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
TOM GRASS AND FATHER OF FOUR
GRANDFATHER TO STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CHANCE HAL ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA
OPPOSED.
ALLEN KENNEDY MAKE IT TO MY PASS
CONTROL THE POST.
BARBARA YOUNG SANTA ROSA
CALIFORNIA I SO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
LORD SHORT CINEMA COUNTY SANTA
ROSA CALIFORNIA FORTY TWO YEARS
IN THE BUSINESS.
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
KEVIN O'CONNOR O'CONNOR PEST
CONTROL SEVENTY YEARS SERVING
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS THANK YOU.
PRIME LEASE SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
RICH RECORDS AGAR TURF
DISTRIBUTING SANTANA.
pOPPOSE.
LAUREN THRESHER THRESHER TERMITE
AND PEST CONTROL SAN DIEGO
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
LITTER KATY CLARK PEST CONTROL
BACK OF WILL STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CASEY SCOTT CLARK PEST CONTROL
VACAVILLE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
RE CARRIER TAKER TERMITE AND
PEST CONTROL VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL.
KATHY BERNARD COMPASS PEST
MANAGEMENT IN RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED.
GORDON NASSER ORKIN PEST CONTROL
OPERATIONS MANAGER SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING JOHN BERNARD
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
LOVER BIRD LOVER ABSOLUTELY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GREG BAUSCH AMERICAN CITY PAST
AND TERMITES LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
SONNY THOMPSON TERM NEXT WINTER
TEMPLAR TERM ANNEX VICTORVILLE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE.
NICK BRANCA VENTURA CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
SCOTT HARRIS FULSOME CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
BOBBI MASTIN TARGET SPECIALTY
PRODUCTS SAN CLEMENTE CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
CARE THRASHER THRASHER PEST
CONTROL FROM CORONADO CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GILBERT OF ADDRESS DOWNTOWN PEST
CONTROL IN POMONA CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
KAREN FAIR MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE
CITY OF MALIBU I APOLOGIZE FOR
BEING LATE I WAS IN A MEETING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
MIKE PIERSON CITY OF MELBOURNE
CITY COUNCIL AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT.
TRAVIS MICHAEL SO **** CERTIFIED
ENTOMOLOGISTS FOR STILL
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THAT PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE.
YES.
SO REMEMBER FRIEDMAN THANK YOU I
THINK THIS IS YOUR THIRD TIME
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT BY -- COMMAND
YOUR STATE TO IT YES STAY TUNED.
TO WITH IT YES YEAH.
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE BILL -- I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND
ENCOUNTER ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
POISONED WITH THEIR GENOCIDE --
VERY FREQUENTLY -- ONE WAY TOO
FREQUENTLY ALMOST EVERY COYOTE I
SEE CERTAIN TIMES OF YEAR IS
HAIRLESS AND SUFFERING -- WE SEE
DEBT OWLS AND DEAD RAPTOR AROUND
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD ALL THE TIME --
SO IS MUCH IS THERE IS A USE
THEIR POTENTIALLY IS A USE FOR
DENNIS SIDE THIS IS CARPET
BOMBING.
THAT'S KILLING ANIMALS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INDISCRIMINATELY.
I SAW A VERY INTERESTING
PRESENTATION BY CITY OF VENTURE
I BELIEVE UP IN OXNARD WERE THEY
THE CITY IT'S I THINK IT WAS THE
CITY OR MAYBE IT WAS THE COUNTY
HAD DONE.
A STUDY WHERE THEY TOOK A
SECTION OF DAM.
OF NEAR AGRICULTURE AND THEY ONE
HALF OF IT THEY USE TRADITIONAL
RODENTICIDE WHICH WOULD NORMALLY
BE USED ON THE OTHER SIDE THEY
HAD A A SERIES WITH A ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO IS PUT UP THE RAFTER
HOUSES YOU DON'T HAVE DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF RATS AND OTHER PESTS.
IN THE ROAD GENOCIDE SECTION
BECAUSE ALL OF THE PREDATORS
ENDED UP GETTING KILLED OFF AND
THE RIVER.
RAFTER AND THE RATS WERE ABLE TO
AVOID EATING THE POISON -- BUT
NOT A LOT OF OTHER ANIMALS AND
WE'RE IS THAT THE RAPTORS SIDE
THEY SAW A HUGE DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF RATS SO WE KNOW THAT
THE USING -- OWLS IN RAPTOR
WORKS REALLY WELL IN A LOT OF
AREAS AND YOUR BILL DOES HAVE A
VERY REASONABLE EXCLUSION.
IF THERE'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
ALSO I THINK IT STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAT AS AN ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE.
ON IN LOS ANGELES AND HAVING
BEEN ON THE GLENDALE CITY
COUNCIL BEFORE WE HEAR
COMPLAINTS -- ABOUT THESE POISON
WILDLIFE ALL THE TIME THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY CONCERNING
TO CONSTITUENTS AND IT'S
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
IN THE EYES OF MY VOTERS THAT WE
HAVE THAT THERE IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
THIS TRADE OFF WHEN THERE ARE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE.
SO -- HI YOU KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK ABOUT ALL
THE TIME I AM SICK OF SEEING THE
SICK ANIMALS.
I'M SICK OF HEARING ABOUT
MOUNTAIN LIONS IN GRIFFITH PARK --
DYING BECAUSE OF HER GENOCIDE
POISONING -- AND YOU KNOW.
IF THIS IS SO SAY FOR THE
PATENTED THE THE PEST CONTROL
COMPANIES HAVE HAD YEARS TO
PERFECTED AND KEEP IT OUT OF THE
A SECONDARY ANIMAL POISONING
STREAM THEY HAVEN'T DONE SO SO I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO TAKE
ACTION.
AND GET RID OF THE ANTICOAGULANT
ROAD INSIDE I'M HOPEFULLY ONCE
AND FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
OKAY -- AND ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM BOARD MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE -- ALL
RIGHT MISTER BLOOM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- A WEEK
I HEARD THE THE OPPOSITION --
FIX A STATE THAT.
SECOND GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDE ARE -- ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL ROAD MANAGEMENT
TOOLS THAT THEY HAVE AND I DON'T
TAKE ISSUE WITH THAT.
OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT THEY'RE
SO SUCCESSFUL AND SO GOOD THAT
THEY HAVE THE SECONDARY.
AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE --
WITH THE PREDATORS AND AND OTHER
ANIMALS -- IT'S A WIDESPREAD
PROBLEM IT'S AN ODD NOT SUBJECT
TO SPECULATION ANY LONGER WE
KNOW THAT IT'S HAPPENING AND WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THERE IS
AN AGRICULTURAL EXEMPTION THAT
IS SET UP -- BUILT IN TO THE
BILL -- AND WITH RESPECT TO
AMENDMENTS WE RECEIVE THEM
YESTERDAY MORNING WITH RESPECT
TO OTHERS THUS SIMPLY BEEN NO
TIME FOR US TO ADEQUATELY REVIEW
THEM TO HAVE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
REVIEW THEM -- OR TO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT WEIGH IN ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS WE WILL CERTAINLY DO
THAT GOING FORWARD -- AND TELL
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT ALL
TAKE THEM INTO FULL
CONSIDERATION AND IF WE CAN
INCORPORATE THEM INTO THE BILL --
AND IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
DIMINISH THE IMPACT OF THE BILL
WE WILL CERTAINLY DO SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM IN
THIS DOES HAVE FROM THE FROM THE
CHAIRMAN DO PASS --
RECOMMENDATION.
I PERSONALLY AM GOING TO OPPOSE
THE BILL.
YOU OFFER A LOT OF THE REASONS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP I MEAN I
THINK THAT THIS IS -- YOU KNOW
GOING OVERBOARD IN THIS AND THE
SENSE THAT WE HAVE A YOU KNOW AS
HE SAID AND EFFECTIVE TOOL --
AND THE SPREAD OF DISEASE FROM
RODENTS IS A IS A HUGE ISSUE AND
MANY OF OUR BANK COMMUNITIES
WILL EVEN A RURAL COMMUNITIES --
AND SO YOU KNOW I I CAN'T TINO
WITH THAT WITH THIS -- WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL CAN'T
SUPPORTED -- AND SO WITH THAT
OUT I WILL HAVE MADAM CLERK
CALLED THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
CHOI NO CHOI KNOWN [inaudible]
TO DALLY.
FRIEDMAN YES FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS.
SALAS NO WOOD.
WOOD I FORTY FOUR ON CALL. FOUR
VOTES ON THE MISTER BLOOM AND
WE'LL KEEP THE KEEP IT ON CALL
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I BELIEVE
YOUR NEXT WITH -- ITEM
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
ELEVEN AB [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE CHECK A WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
AND GARCIA.
ALL RIGHT -- I'LL BE BRIEF THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB EIGHT
THREE FIVE DIRECTS THE STATE
WATER BOARD. TO DEVELOP MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR THE SAFETY OF
FRESH WATER RECREATIONAL BODIES
IS RELATED.
TO HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS -- HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
OF IT BECOMING AN WELL.
I DO HAVE AN EXPERT WITNESS --
WHO IS PROBABLY OUT OF THE
CORNER NOW AND I HOPE SHE WILL
BE IN HERE SHORTLY -- THAT SUSAN
FREAKY THE WATER QUALITY
MANAGEMENT FOR THE CAR OF TRIED --
COME ON UP [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
YOU CAN PRESENT IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING I'M SUSAN FOR KIßM DOT
MOVE A LITTLE CLOSER CLOSER TO
HIM.
I'M SUSAN FOR KIM THE WATER
QUALITY PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE
CREEK TRIBE THE CREE TRIBE IS
THE SECOND LARGEST TRIBE IN
CALIFORNIA.
LOCATED ALONG THE MID KLAMATH
RIVER IN NORTHERN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR WATER QUALITY PROGRAM FOR
THE CREEK TRIBES BEEN MONITORING
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE WE HAVE A
HIGHER LEVES VERY HIGH LEVELS
WHICH CAN EXCEED GUIDANCE BY
OVER TEN THOUSAND TIMES WITHIN
THE CLAN US.
AND SINCE WE'VE BEEN MONITORING
THAT KIND OF HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOM
WE'VE BEEN SAYING AS
MICROSYSTEMS ORIGINAL STUFF
WHICH PRODUCES A TOXIN CALLED
MICRO.
MICROSYSTEMS AS A LIVER TOXIN
AND THE LIVER TOXIN IT CAN CAUSE
SKIN IRRITATIONS RASHES
GASTROINTESTINAL DISTRESS --
NAUSEA DIARRHEA LIVER FAILURE
AND IT'S ALSO A KNOWN CARCINOGEN.
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO THE CREEK TRIBE BECAUSE
OF THE TIME OF THE YEAR THAT THE
TOXINS OF THEIR THAT THEIR
HIGHEST WITHIN THE KLAMATH RIVER
IN AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER.
IT'S TIMES WHEN IT'S CRITICAL
FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS TO BE IN THE
WATER.
NOT JUST FOR RECREATIONAL USE
NOT JUST FOR COOLING OFF BUT FOR
ISSUES SUCH AS WE HAVE TROUBLE
MEMBERS THAT ARE OUT THERE
SUBSISTENCE FISHING.
AND THEY'RE IN THE RIVER WHEN
THAT THERE'S TOXINS PRESENT FROM
EIGHT TO FOURTEEN HOURS A DAY
THERE FISHING FOR FALL CHINOOK
NOT ONLY FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT ALSO FOR THEIR COMMUNITY FOR
THE ELDERS AND FOR CEREMONIAL
USE ALSO OCCURRING AT THE SAME
TIME OF THE YEAR.
IS THE WORLD RENEWAL CEREMONIES
FOR THE CREEK TRIBE THESE OCCUR
ALONG THE KLAMATH RIVER AT
TRADITIONAL VILLAGE SITES.
AND IT'S A TEN DAY CEREMONY AND
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
CEREMONY THE MEDICINE MAN
TRADITIONALLY BAYS AND DRINKS
KLAMATH RIVER WATER WHEN YOU
HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF A HARMFUL
OUT BOOK ALTHOUGH BLOOM AND
TALKS AND IN THE WATER YOU DON'T
THE MEDICINE MAN TO DRINK.
DRINK AND MUCH LESS SPACE IN THE
WATER.
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE -- I WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT YOU.
PAST AB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE WHEN
YOU HAVE THIS HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOM ISSUE RIGHT NOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALL WE HAVE
IS DRAFT VOLUNTARY GUIDANCE FOR
RECREATIONAL USE.
BUT DOESN'T REALLY DO MUCH TO
GET THE INFORMATION OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC SO THAT THEY CAN BE
CONSISTENTLY AND ADEQUATELY
INFORMED ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
RISKS FROM THESE HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS.
IF WE HAD WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NO MATTER WHAT PART
WATER BODY SOMEONE WAS AN THEY
WOULD HAVE THE SAME INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH RISK
FOR THESE ARE BOGGLE BLOOMS SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT FROM THE PUBLIC AND
AND AGAIN JUST NAME AND YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON TREATS A BURKE
**** ON THE LOCAL --
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH WE WANNA --
SUPPORTING CONCEPT WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US SO FAR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORKING
WITH THEM.
AT ANY OTHER OKAY.
MANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE OR PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION OKAY.
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT MISTER QUIRK WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
AND I ASK YOU ARRIVE VOTE.
OKAY -- WILL BRING THAT BACK SO
THAT DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR --
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER.
HI GALLAGHER I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
DALLY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
WOULD. FIVE TWO ZERO ONE CALL
OKAY YOU HAVE FIVE VOTES FOR
THAT WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND
THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR FRAZIER.
WE HAVE YOU ON FRONT OF NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR YOU MAY
PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I AM MEMBERS.
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN MEMBERS ONLY
ONE OF THOSE MEMBERS IS FROM THE
DELTA.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR WILL ADD
SIX RESIDENTS OF THE DELTA TO
THE COUNCIL.
BALANCING THE REGIONAL
AFFILIATION OF THE COUNCIL
MEMBERS.
TIME AND AGAIN THE VOICES OF MY
DELTA NEIGHBORS HAVE BEEN
SILENCED OR COMPLETELY DISMISSED.
THE INTERESTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES HAS
BEEN TOTALLY PRIORITIZED.
WELL THE GOAL OF THE PROTECTING
THE DELTA ECOSYSTEM HAS BEEN
IGNORED DIMINISHED.
EVEN VIOLATED AT TIMES.
IT IS PAST TIME FOR THE COUNCIL
TO ACT RESPONSIBLY IN TRULY MEET
ITS MANDATE [inaudible]
IN STATUTES.
THE DELTA MUST BE TREATED WITH
THE SAME LEVEL RESPECT.
AND THE CO EQUAL GOALS MUST BE
UPHELD RATHER THAN DE VALUED.
FOR TESTIMONY TODAY AND AND FOR
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE I
HAVE WITH ME SOLANO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND FORMER DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL MEMBERS SKIP
THOMPSON.
AS WELL AS KAREN MAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SAVE THE DAY A
CALIFORNIA DELTA AIRLINES AND
ONE OF MY NEIGHBORS AND
DISCOVERY BAY [inaudible]
KAREN.
THANK YOU JIM GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY
LIVES IN THE DELTA ON THE
WATERWAY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS THOUGHTS AND
CONCERNS.
MY NAME IS KAREN MAN I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF SAVE THE CALIFORNIA
DELTA ALLIANCE A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING THE HEALTH OF THE
DELTA DELTA.
HOWEVER I COME TO YOU AS A
LONGTIME RESIDENT AND SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN ENJOYING THE DELTA
WATER WAYS SINCE I WAS EIGHT
WITH MY FAMILY.
I COME TO YOU AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
PERSONALLY INTRODUCED PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE TO THE DELTA WATER
WAYS.
EACH AND EVERY PERSON HAS COME
OFF THE WATER WAYS JUSTICE
CAPTIVATED BY THIS HISTORICAL
AND WONDERFUL LOCATION FILLED
WITH WILDLIFE BEAUTIFUL WATER.
IN NATURE.
IT'S PAINFUL FOR ME TO OBSERVE
THE TERRIBLE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
OUR STATE AGENCIES THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVE WORK AND PLAY IN THE
DELTA.
THIS RESOURCE.
THIS RESOURCE IS AN AMAZING
PLACE ONE THAT HAS DELL TO USERS
DON'T SEEM TO GET TIRE OF TO
DATE THE COUNCIL HAS
DEMONSTRATED TREMENDOUS BIAS
TOWARDS THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.
AND NOT TREATED THE DELTA
RESIDENTS AND USERS EQUALLY.
IT DOES NOT APPEAR THAT THEY
KNOW THE DOCTOR THE HISTORY THE
WONDER THE WILDLIFE THE
RECREATION AND THE LIFE LIKE WE
DO.
IN THE DELTA WE USE THE
WATERWAYS WEEKLY YEAR ROUND.
DURING THE SUMMERTIME WE
ENCOURAGE BOATS TO MEET AND DINE
AT THE LOCAL RESTAURANTS ON THE
WATER THERE'S NOTHING BETTER
THAN SEEING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TO TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE.
ENJOYING OUR WATER WAYS ON A
WEDNESDAY NIGHT GOING OUT FOR
DINNER TOGETHER.
SEVERAL THOUSAND PEOPLE ENJOY
THE MOST INCREDIBLE INDEPENDENCE
DAY FIREWORKS CELEBRATION AT
MANDEVILLE ISLAND.
OR THOUSAND FISHERMEN.
SEVERAL THOUSAND FISHERMEN EVERY
MONTH COMPETING ON FISHING
TOURNAMENTS ALL OVER THE DELTA
WATER WAYS.
OR HOW ABOUT WATCHING A
YOUNGSTER GET UPON SKIS FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME.
THEN OF COURSE THERE'S WATCHING
SOMEONE.
CATCH THEIR FIRST STRIKE BUT
BASS OR SALMON OR STURGEON ARE
CATFISH LARGEMOUTH BASS IT'S A
THRILL AT ANY AGE.
SO AS A RESIDENTS I ALSO SHOP AT
ALL THE LOCAL FRUIT AND FOR THE
FRUIT AND VEGGIE STANDS.
SO I CAN GET THE BEST IN THE
RIGHT PLACE FOOD FROM MY
COMMUNITY.
MY FORMER NEIGHBORS ARE
TERRIFIED OF THE PENETRATION OF
POTENTIAL SALT WATER TO THEIR
WATER SOURCES.
THE COUNCIL HAS FORGED AHEAD
WITH THE SO CALLED WATER FIX
WHICH HAS THE FARMERS VERY
CONCERNED.
IT WOULD BREAK MY HEART TO SEE
THE WATERFRONT COMMUNITIES LOSE
THEIR RESIDENTS.
AND THEIR UNIQUE DELTA HOME
PROPERTY VALUES DUE TO MORE THAN.
TEN YEARS OF MESSI CONSTRUCTION
WITH COMPLICATED WATER AND OR
ROADWAY ACCESS.
AS A FORMER MEMBER PRESIDENT OF
THE DISCOVERY BAY CHAMBER.
I KNOW THE TUNNELS WILL AFFECT
MANY LOCAL BUSINESSES BETWEEN
BETHEL ISLAND.
OAKLEY NIGHTS IN ANTIOCH
DISCOVERY BAY AND MORE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DELTA
STORESHIP COUNCIL HAS PROVEN
THAT IT DOES NOT REPRESENT ME
ARE MY NEIGHBORS WHO LIVE WORK
AND ENJOY THE ENTIRE THE ENTIRE
ONE THOUSAND MILES OF DELTA
WATER WASTE FOR RECREATION AND
LIVELIHOOD.
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE MEMBERSHIP
OF THE COUNCIL AND FINALLY GIVE
THE DELTA RESIDENTS EQUAL
CONSIDERATION.
WE DESERVE AS RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO TREASURE
THE HISTORY OF OUR CALIFORNIA
DOT TO WATER WAYS.
MY FAMILY AND I HAVE BEEN
ENJOYING THE DOCTOR WATER WAYS
FOR FOUR GENERATIONS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WHO LIVE IN OR ON THE
DELTA WATER WAYS BAY AREA
CENTRAL VALLEY TOURISTS LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND DISCOVERY BAY
BRENT WOULD ANTIOCH OAKLEY
NIGHTS AND STOCKTON RIO VISTA.
PITTSBURG AND MILLIONS OF DELTA
RESIDENTS.
AND TAXPAYERS.
PAYERS LIKE ME ARE DEPENDING ON
YOU TO MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION
TODAY I ENCOURAGE YOU TO INCLUDE
MEMBERS ON YOUR BOARD AND OR
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WHO ARE USERS WHO LIVE?
WHO KNOWS THE DELTA -- TREASURE
THE DELTA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME BY THE
WAY.
SHOULD YOU EVER WANT A MORE
DETAILED TOUR.
I PERSONALLY WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TAKE YOU OUT.
ON THE DELTA SO THAT YOU COULD
UNDERSTAND THE TREASURE THAT WE
ALL LOVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON
VICE CHAIR GALLAGHER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS --
SOLANO COUNTY SUPERVISOR STEVE
THOMPSON AND I REALLY WANT TO
SAY IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL THAT COULD CHANGE THE WAY.
THE DOCTORS VIEWED AND HOW WE
TREAT THE DELTA.
I'M HERE AS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAVE HAD
THE HONOR OF SERVING AS THE AS
THE CHAIR OF THAT DON'T TO
PROTECTION COMMISSION.
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE DELTA --
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF ELEVEN AB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR A SPONSORED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER CO
SPONSORED BY THE DELTA CAUCUS --
SENATORS DODD TO GALGIANI AND
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS -- EGGMAN
GRAYSON.
I AS WELL AS ALL THE FOLKS THAT
LIVE AND WORK IN THE DELTA
UNDERSTAND THE PARTS OF THE
DELTA FOR MUCH NEEDED WATER
SUPPLY.
THE DELTA REGION IS CRUCIAL FOR
MANY THINGS IT'S CRITICAL BUT IN
IMPAIRED ECOSYSTEM.
AN IMPORTANT FISHERY.
IN A VIBRANT AGRICULTURE AMONG
ITS MANY OTHER OPEN SPACE AND
RECREATION ATTRIBUTE.
BECAUSE OF ITS IMPORTANCE TO THE
STATE HAS BECOME A BATTLEGROUND.
GREATLY IMPACTING THOSE TRYING
TO MAKE A LIVING AND RAISE YOUR
FAMILY HERE.
AND THE FOLKS MANY WHO LIVE AND
FARM HERE IN FOR GENERATIONS ARE
THE MOST IMPACTED BY THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL'S ACTIONS.
YES ARE THE LEAST REPRESENTED ON
THE COUNCIL ITSELF.
THE LOCAL VOICE IS LARGELY
MISSING ON THIS BODY.
WHILE SERVING ON THE COUNCIL I
SAW NOTHING BUT PROFESSIONALISM
FROM ALL THE COUNCIL MEMBERS.
HOWEVER AND I MEAN NO DISRESPECT
SIX OF THE SEVEN MEMBERS ARE
POLITICAL APPOINTEES OR COME
FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS.
SO WHILE PROFESSIONAL THE DELTA
SERCHHIP COUNTS OF MAKE UP IS
VERY SKEWED.
THE ONLY CONSTANT TRUE DELTA
VOICE HAS BEEN THE LONE DELTA
PROTECTION COMMISSION
REPRESENTATIVE.
WE ARE NOT ARGUING THAT SPECIAL
INTERESTS IN THE SOUTH.
DO NOT HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY HERE
WHAT WE ARE SAYING IS THAT THE
CONSTITUENCY OF THE DELTA.
DESERVES DESERVES A REAL
CONSTANT AND MUCH STRONGER ROLE
IN THE COUNCIL.
I HAD THE HONOR PLACE YOUR AND
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITY TO SERVE
ON THE COUNCIL.
AS AT LONE VOICE THERE WERE MANY
TIMES WHEN I WAS THE LONE VOICE
FOR THOSE THAT WORKED LIVED AND
PLAYED IN THE DELTA MANY TIMES
WHEN THE STAKES WERE VERY HIGH
FOR THOSE MOST AFFECTED.
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
THE I WAS THE QUIET VOICE ON
THIS COUNCIL.
MAKING THE COMPOSITION COUNT
EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC AS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED THE DELTA
PROTECTION COMMISSION MEMBER.
HAS A TWO YEAR TERM.
AND YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE HOW
SCIENTIFICALLY DIFFICULT IT IS
FOR THE LAY PERSON.
BY THE TIME WE EAT THE TO ME --
YOUR MEMBER ARE UP TO SPEED IT'S
TIME TO CHANGE.
SO WITH GREAT URGENCY I COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO URGE SUPPORT
IN MOVEMENT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU SUPERVISOR AND ANY
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT FROM
THE PUBLIC.
AND AGAIN JUST NAME AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON
BEHALF OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY A
MEMBER OF THE DELTA COUNTIES
COCKE AS AS YOU LIKE TO SAY
NOTHING ABOUT US WITHOUT US ASK
FOR DRIVE IT TODAY THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
THANK YOU DENNIS ALBION HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL OF SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY AND MESA
WATER -- WE REGRETFULLY MUST --
OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
WOULD INCREASE THE DELTA STIR TO
COUNSEL THE THIRTEEN MEMBERS.
THE MORE MAJORITY OF WHICH
ACTUALLY COME FROM IN DELTA
INTERESTS -- WE AGREE THAT THE
DELTA IS A VERY VALUABLE
STATEWIDE RESOURCE AND I THINK
WHEN THIS WAS DEVELOPED -- WHEN
THE BILL WAS PASSED IN SB TO A
MINUTE SORRY AS TWO ONE SEVEN
ACTS IN TWO THOUSAND AND?
NINE THAT ESTABLISHED ADULT
EASTER TO COUNSEL IT ACTUALLY --
WAS A COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE THAT
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF THE STATE
OF THE STATE WHAT SIGNIFICANCE
OF THE DELTA.
I WHEN THEY THEY BALLOTS THE THE
THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE DUMPSTER
SHOULD COUNCIL THEY FOCUSED ON
THE THE DELTA HAS IS THE ONLY
REGION THAT ACTUALLY HAS A
DESIGNATED.
MEMBER UP ON THE COUNCIL AND SO
ALL THE REST OF THE MEMBERS CAN
COME FROM A CROSS SECTION OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER INTERESTS.
DIFFERENT -- GEOGRAPHICAL
REGIONS AND FRANKLY THEY HAVE
FOR A AND DIFFERENT DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND THEY HAVE AN
THAT REPRESENTS THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE DELTAS.
ITSELF IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
BOTH THE ESTUARY AND AND THE
RECREATION IT WAS DISCUSSED BY
THE PROPONENTS BUT ALSO FOR
WATER FOR A TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDORS FOR UP ALL THE
VALUABLE RESOURCES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
SO.
THE THIS BILL BASICALLY FAILED
TO RECOGNIZE THE BALANCE IN THE
STATEWIDE -- IMPORTANCE OF THAT
ESTUARY.
UP WE WOULD ALSO ARGUE AND KIND
OF RESPECTED KIND OF THE PROMISE
OF BILL THAT THIS IS NOT WORKING
WE WOULD ARGUE THE PROCESS IS
WORKING IN THE MOST.
SIGNIFICANT DECISION THAT THE
DUMPSTER TO COUNSEL HAS DONE.
IS TO REVIEW THE THE THE
CALIFORNIA WATER FIX AS THOUGH
IT WAS CONSISTENT WITH THE DELTA
PLAN AND THEY DID THAT LAST YEAR.
AND THEY QUESTIONED WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
QUESTIONED IT IN DELTA MEMBERS
QUESTION AND TODAY WE NEED MORE
INFORMATION WE NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL SCIENTIFIC.
EVALUATION OF THIS TO MAKE SURE
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE CO
EQUAL GOALS SO THE FACT IS IT
ACTUALLY WORKED THEY SENT IT
BACK TO D. W. R. D. W. R..
REPROGRAMMED NOW THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL REVIEWS BUT THE WHOLE
PROGRAM.
ACTUALLY WORKED AND SAID THIS IS
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE DELTA
PLAN AT THIS POINT AND CENTER
BACK.
FROM THE CURRENT GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE PROVIDES FOR A
BALANCED PLAN.
AND AND CONTINUE TO RECOGNIZE
THOSE TWIN GOALS AND I THINK THE
TWO WE HEARD FROM THE PROPONENTS
THIS MORNING.
THEY WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
THE MULTIPLE THE BILL WILL GOALS
REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT THE DELTA
SPECIFIC INTEREST -- AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE -- TO COULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO HOLD BILL COMMITTEE TODAY
AND MAINTAIN THE BALANCE THAT
THE TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
LEGISLATION DID THAT WAS A
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION.
INCLUDING CLICK CREATING THE THE
THE DUMPSTER TO COUNSEL THANK
YOU.
IN.
BRIEF IF YOU COULD.
GO AHEAD.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS BURKE BROUGH
REPRESENTING THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
WE ARE ALSO KNOWN AS DALY WATERS.
WE'RE BY THREE MAJOR
METROPOLITAN AREA IN THE STATE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR WATER
SUPPLY -- COMES FROM THE DELTA
OR ITS TRIBUTARIES -- IN THE
CASE OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT
55% OF OUR WATER -- STATEWIDE
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
DEPEND ON THE DELTA ALONG WITH
THREE MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND --
SO IN TWO THOUSAND NINE WHEN THE
DELTA REFORM ACT WAS HEADED TO
THE SIMPLY FOR A COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT NAME AL BRANDT WROTE
IN HIS FOR ANALYSIS THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS BILLS CHANGE.
IN DELTA GOVERNANCE IS THE NEW
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL THE
FOUNDATION.
AND HE WENT ON TO UNDERSCORE THE
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE ACT
FOUNDED WATER CODE SECTION
EIGHTY FIVE TWO AND TO WHICH
SAYS COUNCIL MEMBERS SHALL
POSSESS DIVERSE EXPERTISE AND
REFLECT A STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR WOULD UP
INTO THAT STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE
INTENDED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
WOULD ESTABLISH A MAJORITY
REPRESENTING IN DELTA INTEREST
YOU KNOW THE DECISIONS OF THE
COUNCIL ARE -- QUITE IMPORTANT
FROM WHAT LEVEL OF DEVELOPMENT
IS APPROPRIATE AND THE FRAGILE
ECOSYSTEM TO WHOSE FINANCIAL --
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER
A THOUSAND MILES A DELTA --
LEVEES AND OF COURSE.
WHAT IS THE DELTA CONVEYANCE
SOLUTION -- THAT IS DEEMED
CONSISTENT WITH THE DELTA PLAN.
OF YOU KNOW.
ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
PARTS OF THE STATE THAT ARE NOT
REPRESENTED ON THE COUNCIL --
YOU KNOW ONLY ONE REGION IS
CURRENTLY GUARANTEED A SEAT ON
THE COUNCIL AND THAT'S THE DELTA
ITSELF SILICON VALLEY DOESN'T
HAVE A COUNCIL ISSUED ME A
MEMBER OF THE COUNCIL NEITHER
DID SANTA BARBARA THE COACHELLA
VALLEY LARGE SWATHS OF THE BAY
AREA AND LARGE LOSS OF THE SELF
WHEN. TO COME LAST FALL WHEN THE
COUNCIL CHOSE NOT TO AFFIRM THE
WATER FIX AS CONSISTENT WITH THE
DELTA PLAN WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
HAD A GUARANTEED SEAT.
ON THE COUNCIL AT THAT POINT --
AGAIN IN FAIRNESS TO THE COUNCIL
THEY'RE DOING THE JOB THEY WERE
CREATED TO DO WHICH IS TO
BALANCE THE TWO CO EQUAL GOALS
OF ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION AND
WATER SUPPLY RELIABILITY --
WHILE RECOGNIZING THE DELTAS
INVOLVING PLACE STACKING THE
COUNCIL WITH MAJORITY VOTES OF
FOCUSED ONLY ON ONE REGION WHAT
SERVICE STATEWIDE PURPOSE.
OF THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE VERY
FOUNDATION OF THE DOCTOR REFORM
ACT WE ASK FOR YOU TO ABSTAIN OR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AFTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB READ
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
ON BEHALF OF VALLEY ATWATER
COALITION.
ROLAND WATER DISTRICT WANTED
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN DESERT
WATER AGENCY IN OPPOSITION.
MR TURN MEMBERS BETH ALL ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
JONATHAN CLAMP AFTER THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
KATHY COLBY HAVE THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO AUTHORIZED
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
FROM HOBBY WATER AGENCY AND
WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
THANK YOU.
SPENCER SACKS ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND THE
SAN BERNADINO VALLEY MINUTES BUT
WATER DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
SARS DIVERSE FOR THE MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION.
KRIS CONNOR PRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY A MISTER FRAZIER LET'S
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
LOVE THE OPPOSITION TELLING AT
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
ACTUALLY PULLED IT WERE FOR
MEMBERS HAD RECUSED THEMSELVES.
ON THE DELTA STORE CHIPS KELSO
BECAUSE OF INTEREST THAT WERE
NOT.
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
DELTA.
THE THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES AS
I WILL SAY.
OF THE ONLY TWO PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY DID.
OPPOSE THE DEAL AND IN THIS
REGION IT COULD GO FOR IT WASN'T
REALLY PULLED.
I MEAN IT WASN'T REALLY REJECTED
WAS ACTUALLY PULLED BY THE
COMMISSION -- WAS MR THOMPSON
AND MR GADO FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOW WERE OPPOSED
TO THE VIDEO SO YOU HAD A
BALANCE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS SAID NO.
AND A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MEMBER
SAID NO -- THAT BEING SAID I
NOTICED TODAY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I CHAIRMAN GARCIA IS --
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE FOR THE
SALTON SEA AND I WOULD LIKE HIM
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO HAVE.
EVERY BIT OF A CONCERN DEALT
WITH HIS SALTON SEA JUST LIKE
ANYBODY ELSE.
WHO HAS A A A A A AS AN INTEREST
IN THEIR?
IN THEIR DISTRICT.
I'VE GROWN UP ON THE DELTA.
THIS THING IS GONE FROM THE BC
DC.
TO SOLD.
MANY DIFFERENT MACHINATIONS OF
WHAT.
THEY'VE TRIED TO GET THROUGH NOW
IT'S AT WATER FIX.
WHAT WE'RE JUST TRYING TO DO AND
AGAIN IT'S IT'S AN EQUAL BALANCE
OF?
A YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
GOVERNMENT.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
AND AND WHAT GOES ON GENERALLY
HAS BEEN TO THIS POINT A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INTEREST.
IN CONVEYANCE GOING FORWARD --
THE DELTA WE FEEL HAS NOT BEEN
FAIRLY REPRESENTED IN THAT AND
WE WERE ASKING FOR AN EQUAL
BALANCE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AGAIN ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS A
FAIR SHOT IF SCIENCE PROVES TO
BE THE WINNER I WOULD ASSUME
THAT EVERYBODY WOULD BE FOR THAT
PROCESS I WANT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TO BE SUCCESSFUL BUT
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF A THIRD OF
THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA.
NOW WITH THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF
THE STATE SAYING HE WAS NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWIN TUNNELS I
LOOK AT IT THIS WAY MISTER CHAIR
ONE TOTAL DOWN. ONE TO GO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
I WILL TAKE THAT AS THE FINAL
CLOSER -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- SO
BRING IT BACK HERE JUST SO I'D
IT DOES HAVE A DO NOT PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
I'M FILLING IN FOR THE CHAIR.
TODAY.
I I CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE WITH
YOU AS SOMEONE WHO ALSO.
FEELS LIKE HE FEELS A GREAT
IMPACT IN MY DISTRICT OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT FOR EXAMPLE --
AND DOESN'T ALWAYS HAVE A WHOLE
LOT TO SAY AND HOW THAT PROJECT
IS OPERATED FOR EXAMPLE AT ALL
THAT OR BUILD THEM.
YOU AYE I THINK THE CONCERN.
YOU KNOW THAT IS THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED IS WITH.
YOUR EXPAND IN THAT SO GREATLY
THIS TO SIX MEMBERS.
OF YOUR WHO WOULD BE FROM THE
DELTA.
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW AT I THINK.
MAYBE BETTER REPRESENTATION OF
THE DELTA WOULD BE NECESSARY
WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
BEING AS THOUGH A LOT OF THOSE
IMPACTS AND KNOW OUR FELT.
LOCALLY -- AND ANY OF THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE WITNESS OF
THE ALL OF THE THE BENEFITS AND
WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME TO THE
DELTA ENJOY THAT AND AND BE PART
OF THAT AND AND SPEND THEIR
MONEY THERE AS WELL READ AND
ENJOY THE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO I YOU KNOW I THINK THOSE
THAT'S THE BALANCE AND MAYBE
TRYING TO FIND.
YOU KNOW ONE THING I'VE BEEN
WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IS WHAT YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT
MAYBE WHAT WE NEED IS A BETTER
OVER OVERALL GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
OF THE ENTIRE STATE WATER
PROJECT YOU KNOW LARGELY THAT IS
GOVERNED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES RIGHT NOW WHO'S.
LARGELY UNACCOUNTABLE -- TO
THOSE OF US WHO ARE ELECTED.
AND AND MAKES DECISIONS IN WAYS
THAT ARE NOT ALWAYS VERY CLEAR --
TO THIS BODY AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE.
BEEN OPEN TO IS A MAYBE WE WE
CHANGE THE OVERALL GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
MAKE IT MORE ACCOUNTABLE TO US.
SO I THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
BOUNCING THINGS IN WITH THAT --
I WILL.
YOUR IF THERE'S A MOTION TO THAT
EFFECT IS THERE A MOTION ON ON
THIS BILL.
THE COURTESY TO OUR MEN.
MOVED BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW IS OUR
SECOND.
WITHOUT A SECOND I CAN'T.
ALLOW THE BILL TO TAKE A VOTE SO.
I WOULD REQUEST RICK RICK
CONSIDERATION AND UNDERSTANDING
THE WHISKIES FOR DRINKING WATER
IS FOR FIGHTING.
BUT RIGHT RECONSIDERATION IS
NOTICED.
ON ON THE BILL [inaudible]
WHAT'S A IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO GRANTING RECONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
SEE NOW TO BE.
IT WILL BE RECONSIDERED BASED ON
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
OKAY NEXT WE HAVE.
SO A MEMBER BAUER CON.
MORE UP I'M GONNA HAVE TO TAKE A
LITTLE BREAK YOUR ARM AND HAND
OVER TO MR BIGELOW [inaudible]
YEAH
.
SOME DISCOUNT WE HAVE A. B. TEN
EIGHTY SIX WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START YOUR PRESENTATION I WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
HOW EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU.
I'M JAN PRESENTING AB TEN EIGHTY
SIX WHICH AID SMALL FARMS TO
CONVERT TO HIRE EFFICIENT
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS BY CODIFYING
IMPROVING THE EXISTING STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS SWEEPS.
THIS PROGRAM IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT HELPS US CONSERVE
WATER AND ENSURE THAT OUR
FARMING PRACTICES ARE GREEN
MOVING FORWARD.
THOUGH SO THERE'S MORE WATER FOR
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE AND ALSO
SO THAT WE AREN'T SEEING THE
POLLUTANTS GOING INTO OUR GROUND
WATER THAT WE SEE WITH FLOOD
IRRIGATION SO THIS BILL HELPS
SMALL FARMS MOVE INTO A MORE
RESPONSIBLE FARMING PRACTICES
AND THAT IS.
OUR GOAL HERE TODAY I HAVE WITH
ME HI BRIAN SHOW FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACT --
CULTURAL NECK WORK AND DAVE RUNS
DEAN FROM THE QUEUE IMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET ME
REMIND ALL THOSE THE PRESENTERS
THAT WE HAVE TWO MINUTES AND
THEY'LL BE THE SAME FOR THE ANY
OTHERS THAT ARE GONNA BE
COMMENTING.
EXCEPT FOR THE METIS
[inaudible]
PLEASE BEGIN.
NOTED THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M RANCHO BUT THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
WERE COALITION OF FARMERS
RANCHERS SCIENTISTS AND AG
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT OUR AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY
IS RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE'VE BEEN THE LEADING ADVOCATES
FOR THE SWEET PROGRAM SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN AT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT DROUGHT IS A
PERSISTENT THREAT TO FARMERS.
I DESPITE OCCASIONAL WHAT YOU'RE
THE RISK OF SEVERE DROUGHTS IS
PROJECTED INCREASE 50% IN THE
NEXT EIGHTY YEARS.
WE'VE WRITTEN TO REPORTS ON THE
STREET PROGRAM IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS. TO BETTER UNDERSTAND ITS
IMPACTS AND ALSO TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM.
IN THE MOST RECENT OF THOSE WE
INTERVIEWED -- FARMERS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS WHO'D
WORKED WITH OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SWEEP APPLICANTS.
AND APPLICATION REVIEWERS WHO
REVIEWED HUNDREDS OF SWEEP
APPLICATIONS.
I HAVE A SEAT ON A TIME TO GO
THROUGH THE ALL OF THE FINDINGS
THAT REPORT SO I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT.
TO THAT THIS BILL DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES.
THE FIRST IS THAT PARTICIPATION
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY LOW IN PART DUE TO
LIMITATIONS OF THE PROGRAM'S
GREENHOUSE GAS QUANTIFICATION
METHODOLOGY.
T. A PROVIDERS AND SWEEP AT
REVIEWERS FROM THAT REGION HAVE
SUGGESTED A FEW WAYS TO ADDRESS
THAT.
AND THIS BILL AS PROPOSED WOULD
SET UP AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
YOUR GUEST EXPERTS TO HELP WORK
THROUGH THOSE PROPOSALS. TO
HOPEFULLY IMPROVE PARTICIPATION
IN THAT A CRITICAL REGION OF THE
STATE.
THE SECOND IS THAT YOUR QUESTION
OPERATORS NEED TARGETED
CULTURALLY COMPETENT TRAINING TO
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS OF THE
SWEET PROJECTS.
CAPTION COMPANIES CURRENTLY ARE
NOT PROVIDING THAT -- BUT YOU
SEE A COPPER CENSURE EXTENSION
IRRIGATION SPECIALISTS ARE
WILLING TO AND HAVETRAINING --
MODULES PREPARED. TO OFFER THAT
TRAINING IN THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
CDFA TO PROVIDE THAT.
SO JUST BECAUSE BY SAYING THAT
THIS BILL MAKES A NUMBER OF
IMPROVEMENTS THE PROGRAM THAT
COME DIRECTLY FROM STAKEHOLDER%
FEEDBACK WE'VE HEARD.
WE THINK THEY WILL IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND REACH OF THE
PROGRAM AND PREPARING THE
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE FARMERS
TO THE NEXT DROUGHT.
AND WE SEE THE IS THAT THESE AS
CREATING SWEEP TWO POINT NOW --
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
THROUGH ANY CONCERNS -- TO MOVE
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
I'M DAVE RUN THIN POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS.
WE'VE BEEN A BIG SUPPORTER OF
SWEEP SINCE ITS INCEPTION BACK
DURING THE DROUGHT.
IT'S THE ONLY STATE PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSES ON IMPROVING ON FARM
WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
IT TENDS TO BE FORGOTTEN DURING --
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT RAINS -- BUT AGRICULTURE
IN CALIFORNIA FROM OUR POINT OF
VIEW PHASES AN EXISTENTIAL
CRISIS.
AROUND WATER AS THE CLAIMANT
HEATS UP.
AS WE TRY TO STOP OVER DRAFTING
GROUND WATER AND AND THE GREATER
ENVIRONMENTAL DEMANDS ARE MADE
ON SURFACE WATER.
WE NEED TO BE AS EFFICIENT AS WE
CAN BE DURING THE SUMMER.
AND SOMEHOW FIND A WAY TO
RECHARGE AQUIFERS IN THE WINTER
TIME.
WE SUPPORT AB TEN EIGHTY SIX
BECAUSE IT'LL FOCUS SWEEP ON
SUPPORT FOR SMALLER FARMS THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
INVEST IN MODERN IRRIGATION
SYSTEMS AND WE THINK THAT THIS
IS AN APPROPRIATE USE OF STATE
FUNDS.
THE BILL ALSO PROPOSES TO
INVOLVE MORE A YOU'RE ENGAGED IN
EXPERTISE IN ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM. TO BRING IN
CONSIDERATIONS OF WATER QUALITY
AND GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY.
TO ACTUALLY FUND TRAININGS FOR
GRANT RECIPIENTS AND PERHAPS TO
ENCOURAGE IRRIGATION DISTRICTS
TO WORK WITH FARMERS TO IMPROVE
PRACTICES ON THEIR FARMS.
PEOPLE WANT MICRO YOUR GAUGE IN
BECAUSE IT INCREASES THE YIELDS
AND ECONOMIC RETURNS BUT IT ALSO
HAS ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF
REDUCING RUN OFF.
AND STOPPING LEACHING OF
FERTILIZERS INTO THE GROUNDWATER.
AND SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF TRADEOFFS THAT
ARE GOING TO OCCUR IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
SWEET COULD BE A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF SOLVING WATER PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THAT WOULD LIKE.
YES I AM WITH THE UC DAVIS IN
ASSOCIATION -- WORLDS AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL -- WERE
AGRICULTURE UNIVERSITY AND OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE SMALL FARMERS AND
FAMILY FARMERS AND THAT IS WHY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
WELL AS OUR UNIVERSITY AND ARE.
YOU SEE COOPER EXTENSIONS.
ARE VERY MUCH INVOLVED WITH MORE
EFFICIENT IRRIGATION SYSTEMS
THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH OTHERS.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION THANK.
THREE THREE MITCHELL MAP THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MAYBE WE CAN MAKE SOME -- WAS
JUST GONNA BE ONE SO WE HAVE
PLAYED AROUND.
I THINK WORK IN MY THANK YOU
MISTER TRADE MEMBERS TAYLOR
RUSSIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU EDERATION --
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION IT'S ALWAYS
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
OPPOSITION AGAINST OUR
AGRICULTURAL COLLEAGUES -- BUT
ON THIS BUT WE NEED FIRST AND
FOREMOST LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AS
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT NEGOTIATING
ON SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAD.
OUR UPS ON THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAD -- WITH WE THINK THAT SWEEP
IS A PIVOTAL PROGRAM MINUTES
HISTORICALLY ALLOWED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
SOME OF THE WATER AND ENERGY
SAVINGS IN A MEANINGFUL MANNER
ON FARM -- AND WHILE THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT IS ARE
THE COMMITTEE MINUTES ARE AN
IMPROVEMENT ON AT THE BASE LINE
I THINK THERE ARE FEW
OUTSTANDING PIECES THAT DO
REQUIRE SOME CONSIDERATION THAT
ARE.
A DEVIATION FROM HOW SWEET AS
MANAGE NOW -- SPECIFICALLY ONE
IS THE INCLUSION OF WATER
QUALITY AS A NEW OBJECTIVE --
THAT CERTAINLY YOU CAN MAKE AN
ARGUMENT THAT FOR EDUCATION HAS
WATER HAS A WATER QUALITY
BENEFITS BUT IT'S NOT MEASURED
UNDER THE EXISTING PROGRAM AND
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT HOW
SWEET WOULD HAVE TO TRANSITION
TO MEASURE THAT -- ADDITIONALLY
THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT -- A
GROWER FROM APPLYING TO FOR THE
DOLLARS OR IMPLEMENTING THE
SYSTEM IF THEY CHOOSE TO
TRANSITION TO A SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER WATER USE CROP -- WE NOW
WITH THE ADVENT OF SIGMA WE'RE
GONNA SEE WATER BUDGETS ALL OVER
THE PLACE ON AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS -- AND THERE ARE
FARMERS NEED NOW MORE SO THAN
EVER FLEXIBILITY TO ADAPT TO
THOSE CHANGES YOU MAY ACTUALLY
SEE THAT INCREASE WHICH WOULD
OBLIGATE YOU OR ALLOW YOU UNDER
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES A
TRANSITION TO A HIGHWAY HIGHER
WATER USE CROP AND IF WE DO THAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE USING THE MOST EFFICIENT
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE THAT WILL
HAVE THOSE GHG EMISSION
REDUCTIONS ENERGY SAVINGS -- SO
IF THE BILL MOVES TODAY WE WE
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE THE
SPONSORS IN A MEANINGFUL WAY --
BUT ULTIMATELY I THINK WE
BELIEVE SWEEP ONE POINT OUT --
AND THE EXCESS SORT OF SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF SO -- IF WE ARE GOING
TO CODIFY WE MEAN NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING IT
CORRECTLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEN.
ANGELINE MOVEMENT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT.
OF BRING IT BACK -- TO MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
MAYBE A QUESTION -- FROM MYSELF --
AT ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF OF
OPPOSITION HERE AND RECOGNIZING.
THAT SWEEP IS ONLY IT WAS A
REALLY NEVER CODIFIED IT WAS
JUST A CURSORY ADDITION IN. TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THESE ACTIONS
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT NOW
MOVING FORWARD WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT COST.
HOW DO YOU PLAN ON ADDRESSING
THE COSTS OF?
DOING THE STUDIES AND ACTIVITIES
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE
ACTIONS OF THIS BILL BOTH IN THE
PLANE AND IN THE AMENDED VERSION.
YEAH SO WE'RE LOOKING AT USING
FUNDING FOR THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND WE THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL THE
MEASURE THAT SHOULD COME OUT
ABOUT FUND.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE CLARITY
TO THAT -- THE CHAIR WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR DIRECTION.
THERE WAS A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOMAN I'M SORRY MR SEE HAD MADE
THAT MOTION IS FRIEDMAN MADE THE
SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
REMINDER.
WITH THAT SAID -- PLEASE -- CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
A WOMEN'S.
GERMAN COST.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO A CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR GOD.
OKAY I WANT TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS BROUGHT
FORTH BY THE OPPOSITION WE'VE
BEEN IN DIALOGUE WITH THEM AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO BE ON
DIALOGUE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS PROGRAM WORKS. FOR THE
FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA MOVING
FORWARD -- AND YOU KNOW I JUST
HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK FOR
EFFICIENT FARMING THAT HELPS
PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
WATER SOURCES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS DOES
ENJOY FROM THE CHAIRMAN I DO
PASSED WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW NOW BIGELOW NO CHOI
[inaudible] TWO VALLEY
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D GLORIA
[inaudible]
CHOLERA.
KALRA I THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
WOULD. FIVE TWO ONE CALL.
THAT THE BILL IS ON CALL STILL
AND WE HAVE MEMBERS ABSENCE SO
WILL BRING THAT UP NGUYEN CARE
FOR THE OKAY.
SO WE'LL GO TO AGENDA ITEM
EIGHTEEN A. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX MISSED WORK.
FOR FIVE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
JUST BEGAN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MY NAME IS
TASHA BOERNER HORVATH AND I WHEN
I THINK THE CHAIR MEMBERS FOR
HEARING MY BILL.
EIGHT AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THE
PERMANENT PROTECTION OF SAN NO
FREE STATE BEACH BY REQUIRING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PARKS RECREATION TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
ABOUT PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD ENCROACH OR
INTERFERE WITH PARK OPERATIONS.
FOR DECADES A PROPOSAL TO
CONSTRUCT A MULTI LANE TOLL ROAD
THROUGH THE HEART OF THE PARK.
THAT WOULD HAVE BISECTED SENT
OVER STATE BEACH AND RUIN THE
SAN MATTEO WATERSHED.
WAS AN ACTIVE THREAT.
AFTER ADVOCACY FROM PARK
SUPPORTERS ACROSS THE STATE THE
TOLL ROAD PROPOSAL WAS REJECTED.
AT VARIOUS STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
IN LATE TWENTY SIXTEEN ILLEGAL
SETTLEMENT WAS REACHED BETWEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
FOUGHT THE PROPOSAL.
ON THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY
THAT HAD PROPOSED IT.
THIS AGREEMENT WAS FOLLOWED BY
SIMILAR AGREEMENT WITH CALTRANS
ON THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
AGENCY BY WHICH CALTRANS
SIMILARLY AGREE TO AVOID.
CONSTRUCTION IN THE PARK.
CONCERNS REMAIN THAT A NEW
PROJECT MAYBE PROPOSED WAS
SIMILAR IMPACTS.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX WOULD
ENABLE THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW ANY
PROPOSED PROJECTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME TOO TWO
WITNESSES SO I'LL TURN ON THEM.
SO WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER SEE
IN A SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN --
PLEASE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONTINUE.
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE --
I'M RACHEL NORTON I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX AND THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURNER **** BATH FOR HER.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
DISTRICT ISSUE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IS AN INDEPENDENT
MEMBER SUPPORTED NONPROFIT THAT
INFORMS INSPIRES CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF PARK
CHAMPIONS TO BE THE PASSIONATE
ADVOCATES OUR STATE PARKS NEED.
AT THE FOUNDATION WE CARE ABOUT
ALL STATE PARK.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO PLAY
FAVORITES AMONG THE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY WONDERFUL NATURAL
CULTURAL AND HISTORIC STATE
PARKS AND WE DON'T.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
PARKS THAT HAVE UNFORTUNATELY
BEEN TARGETED FOR DESTRUCTIVE OR
INAPPROPRIATE INFRASTRUCTURE.
FOR ALMOST TWO DECADES ONE OF
THOSE PARKS WITHIN AN OVARY
STATE BEACH WHICH IS ONE OF THE
TOP FIVE MOST VISITED STATE
PARKS IN THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
THE PARK PROTECTS THE LAST
REMAINING UNDEVELOPED WATERSHED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S HOME
TO THE WORLD FAMOUS TRUFFLES
BEACH AND IT HOUSES TEN
FEDERALLY THREATENED OR
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
AS THE ANALYSIS SUMMARIZES A
PROPOSAL FOR A MULTI LANE TOLL
ROAD WOULD HAVE BISECTED THE
HEART OF THE THREE THOUSAND ACRE
PARK AND SEVERELY IMPACTED
COASTAL RESOURCES.
IN LIGHT OF THAT THREAT AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN OUR NEARLY
FIFTY YEAR HISTORY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION ENTERED INTO A
LAWSUIT WITH OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIGHT THE
PROJECT.
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX SIMPLY
INSURES THAT WE REMAIN VIGILANT
ABOUT ANY ADDITIONAL THREATS TO
THE PARK AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD A THREAT
MATERIALIZE.
GIVEN OUR NEARLY FIFTEEN YEAR
FIGHT TO PROTECT CENTENO FREE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IS COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT THIS PARK AND ALL
OUR STATE PARKS REMAIN OPEN
ACCESSIBLE AND PROTECTED.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON A.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON LEAST
STEPHANIE'S LET MICROPHONE RIGHT
OVER TO ENSURE REAL CLOSE SO
EVERYONE CAN HEAR.
I'M STEPHANIE'S TO GET QUINN
WITH THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
AND I'M GOING TO TRUNCATE MY AYE
TESTIMONY BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
HERE ALSO MORNING.
SO ON SPEED WARP I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS CAMPAIGN FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
RECOGNIZING THIS.
YES WE'VE HAD GREAT MILESTONES
SUCH AS THE LAWSUIT SETTLEMENT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STARTING TO
HEAR FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SEE AN ARTERIAL THROUGH THE
PARK.
OF COURSE WE STOP THE TOLL ROAD
ITSELF -- SO THEREFORE WE URGE
YOU TO HAVE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
ISSUE PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT JUST
GIVES THE DEPARTMENT AN EASY WAY
TO TRACK THIS AND IT'S JUST A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO DO IT I ALSO
WANT TO STRESS THAT THERE ARE
ALSO -- SECRET NATIVE AMERICAN
SITES THAT ARE WITHIN THIS PARK
SO AGAIN WE URGE AN AYE VOTE SO
THAT FUTURE CALIFORNIANS CAN
ENJOY THE CULTURAL RECREATIONAL.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES THAT ARE
IN THIS BELOVED PARK.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY VOTER
TAURUS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT IN HALF THE NOT
TO RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY COAST KEEPER
THANK YOU.
MORE INCOME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MIKE LYNCH PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK RANGERS
SUBSTATION OUR ASSOCIATION
OPPOSE THE TOLL ROAD AND
SUPPORTS THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS PER
POST BILL [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WAIT A MINUTE DOORS OPENING STE.
I SEE NONE.
BACK TO MEMBERS MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
MISTER DALI.
SELECT A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED --
TYPICALLY WE DON'T.
DO THAT JUST NATION THAT REQUIRE
SOME A REPORT THIS IS THE FIRST
I'VE SEEN OF THIS TYPE OF PIECE
OF LEGISLATION -- THAT WE RE
WOULD PORT TO THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES OR THE ASSEMBLY NATURI
SOURCES WE HAVE SEQUEL LAWS WE
HAVE.
LOCAL CONTROL LAWS WE HAVE A
WHOLE SIX HOST OF LAWS BEFORE IN
THE PROJECT IS GOING TO BE.
MOVING THROUGH ANY.
PARK OR ANYWHERE WE WE HAVE A
WHOLE HOST OF ENVIRONMENTAL THE
CHECK MARKS IS THAT.
TYPICALLY GO THROUGH SO.
I'M I'M TRYING TO GET MY MIND
AROUND WHY THIS IS NEEDED OTHER
THAN ME NAY IF ANYBODY'S GONNA
PROPOSING THE AS THEY DID WITH
YOUR TOLL ROAD
AND YOU'RE ABLE TO FIGHT THAT
THERE'S A PROCESS FOR THAT SO
HOUSES BILL.
WHEN THEY NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE
WHAT IS IT WHAT IS IT REALLY
GOING TO DO I'M CONFUSED OF?
THER THE NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE
THAT HEY SOMEBODY'S GONNA
PROPOSE A PROJECT THROUGH.
THIS AREA AT A MINUTE YOU WOULD.
FIRST GO TO YOUR COUNTY OR CITY
OR WHAT THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
AND A POLL PERMIT.
TO DO SOMETHING A LITTLE THEIR
SON I'M THIS IS I'M MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
THAT THIS SETS FOR FUTURE.
LEGISLATION AND CIRCUMVENTING --
THE PROCESS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE.
SEC SO I EQUATE THIS TO A MORE
OF A NOTIFICATION THIS WAS A
HARD FOUGHT BATTLE SAVE TRESTLES
WAS WHAT I I KNEW IT UNDER
BEFORE I WAS ELECTED THE
ASSEMBLY.
HAVE BEEN GOING ON AND A HARD
WROUGHT COMPROMISE WAS REACHED
BETWEEN MANY ACTORS THIS COST
TAXPAYERS TONS OF MONEY THIS
COST TONS OF ACTIVISTS TIME.
AND ULTIMATELY FOUND A
COMPROMISE AND THAT COMPROMISE
IS REALLY VITALLY IMPORTANT
SENATE OVER STATE BEACH SPANS
TWO COUNTIES.
IT INCLUDES PART OF CAMP
PENDLETON WHERE THEY DO
MANEUVERS IN THE PARK.
THERE'S IT'S A VERY VERY COMPLEX
GROUP OF INTEREST AND SO WILL
THIS WILL REQUIRE NOTIFICATION
SO WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
AND KNOW WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED
AND THE LEGISLATURE COULD THEN
ACT ON IT AND I WOULD EXPECT AND
I WOULD BE COMING BACK WITH THAT
NOTIFICATION.
AND RUNNING A BILL TOM TO
PROTECT WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN -- A
CODIFIED THROUGH LEGAL AND OTHER
AGREEMENTS.
SO GO AHEAD AND SELECT AND LIKE
TO ADD SOMETHING PLEASE YEAH I'M.
YES THERE WERE SUCCESS THROUGH A
LAWSUIT SETTLEMENT AND THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY JUST WITH THE TOLL
ROAD AGENCY THEREFORE THEY ARE
BOUND THEMSELVES FROM ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOWEVER THAT DOES NOT PRECLUDE
THE ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN OTHER INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY SOUGHT TO
TAKE AN ARTERIAL ROADS THROUGH
THAT SO THERE ARE -- THIS KIND
OF PUT A BOW ON THE LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT THAT'S BEEN PART OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND REALLY PUTS
US ALL I NOTICE ON IN A VERY
MORE PROACTIVE WAY AND ENSURIN
THAT THESE PROTECTIONS.
ARE IN PLACE AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING.
TO ASK QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
MAYBE IS A LITTLE FOLLOW UP TO
THAT MR DAILY US VERY.
POIGNANT.
AND SOLID QUESTION.
THAT RAISES THE ISSUE IF THIS
ACTION IS THEN BROUGHT TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION AND
BROUGHT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THE MOST LIKELY IT WOULD
TRUNCATE AND AND THEN TO HAVE
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY OF BEING
HER TRUNCATING THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND ALL OTHER LOCAL.
ISSUES SO I'M WONDERING IF THERE
SHOULD BE A BUYER BEWARE.
MOMENT IN SETTING A STATE
PRESIDENT.
YOU MAY WANT TO THINK THIS
THROUGH BUT GIVEN THAT SAID YOU
DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND YOU DO HAVE A SECOND AND I
WOULD.
SEE NO ONE ELSE RALLY TO ANY
CALLS OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
LET'S CALL ROLE.
MAY I PLEASE CLOSE I'M SORRY YES
MA'AM SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A GIVER COMMENTS WILL KEEP THEM
AND DEFINITELY A MIND AS WE
BEFORE WITH THE SPELL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW NO BIGELOW NO.
CHOI [inaudible]
CHIU.
GALLEY NOT LOADING.
KELLY NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN YEAH
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D.
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD I WOULD I WE HAVE
SOME MEMBERS THAT ARE ABSENT AND
WE WILL HAVE A AFFORD THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY COME BACK AND VOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHECK.
IT WITH THE NEXT [inaudible]
ONE HELLO [inaudible]
IS FRIEDMAN.
YOU HAVE AB.
SIXTY AND YOU HAVE A BE.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN WHICH WOULD YOU
LIKE FIRST.
LET'S TAKE NUMBER SIX LET'S TAKE
A BE -- SIXTY OKAY THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A SECOND BUT MR SOLACE.
HOW DOES BE VERY BRIEF YOU MAY
MANY OF YOU SAW THIS BILL LAST
YEAR WHEN IT WAS JUST AS GOOD A
BILL?
THIS YEAR IT'S EVEN BETTER AND
IT'S ABOUT HAVING A FISSION SEE
STANDARDS FOR WATER METERS.
WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I DO HAVE -- WITH
ME TODAY TREE SEQUENCE FROM AND
OUR DC TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO
TELL YOU WHY THIS IS SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF
YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TRACY
QUINN I'M WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I WILL
TRY TO KEEP IT FREE FALL
COVERING JUST A FEW TALKING
POINTS.
OF THE NEED FOR AB SIXTY ARISES
FROM THE TENDENCY OF WATER
METERS TO PERFORM POORLY WITH
THE FLOW THROUGH THE WATER WHEN
THAT FLOW THROUGH THE WATER
METER IS VERY LOW.
THE RESULT IS THAT EVEN WITH
BRAND AB RAINY METERS LOW FLOWS
THAT ARE INDICATIVE OF LEAKAGE
ARE EITHER UNDER RECORDED OR NOT
RECORDED AT ALL.
THE CENTRAL CHALLENGE THAT AB
SIXTY SIX TO ADDRESS IS THAT THE
CALL CURRENT VOLUNTARY STANDARDS
FOR THE ACCURACY OF WATER METERS
DO NOT EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE
NEED FOR ACCURACY AT LOW FLOWS.
THE LACKS.
INDUSTRY SPECIFICATIONS HAVE
REMAINED UNCHANGED FOR DECADES.
FOR THE MOST COMMON SIZE OF
RESIDENTIAL METERS THE VOLUNTARY
INDUSTRY STANDARDS CALL FOR A
LOW FLOW ACCURATE TEST ACCURACY
TEST OF ONE QUARTER GALLON PER
MINUTE. TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE A LEAK OF ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED GALLONS PER DAY
COULD BE NOT RECORDED AT ALL.
FOR THE LARGER METERS NOW
REQUIRED BY SOME UTILITIES THE
LOCAL ACTION ACCURACY TEST IS
PERFORMED AT THREE QUARTER
GALLONS PER MINUTE A HALF
GALLONS PER MINUTE AT ONE AND A
HALF.
INCH METERS.
MOST SHOWERS THERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE TAKE SHOWERS AT ONE HALF
GALLONS PER MINUTE SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT THIS COULD BE A REALLY
BIG PROBLEM -- THE METERS WOULD
FAIL TO CABBAGE TO CAPTURE
ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF LEAKAGE AS
WELL AS OTHER INTENDED USES LIKE
DRIP IRRIGATION.
WHEN A METER FAILS RECORD WATER
DELIVER TO SOME CUSTOMERS TO
ADVERSE EFFECTS TAKE PLACE?
THE UTILITY DOES NOT RECEIVE AS
MUCH REVENUE AS IT SHOULD SO
IT'S REYES MUST BE INCREASE FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE.
AND THE CUSTOMER GETS NO
INDICATION FROM THEIR WATER BILL
THAT THEY MAY HAVE A HIDDEN LAKE.
AND THEY HAVE NO INCENTIVE TO
LOOK.
SIMPLY PUT METERS THAT ARE MORE
ACCURATE CAN HELP CUSTOMERS SAVE
MONEY AND SAY WATER AND
UTILITIES CLICK THE REVENUE THEY
NEED.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE NEW
METERS AVAILABLE TODAY THAT ARE
MORE ACCURATE THAN WAS REQUIRED
BY THE VOLUNTARY TERRY STANDARDS
BECAUSE WE TESTED THEM.
A TOTAL OF EIGHTY FOUR METERS
WERE TESTED DRAWN FROM SIX
PROMINENT US MANUFACTURERS.
WE TESTED MULTIPLE SAMPLES OF
THE SAME TYPE OF METER AND EACH
METER WAS TESTED TWICE.
THE RESULTS CONFIRMED AND WERE
SIMILAR TO A PREVIOUS TEST BY
OUR CITY BY UTAH STATE.
WHICH FOUND THAT.
THERE IS SOME VARIABILITY IN THE
ACCURACY OF METERS AT LOW FLOWS
EVEN WITHIN THE SAME METER TYPES.
METERS WITH ACCEPTABLE ACCURACY
FLOWS LOWER THAN THE INDUSTRY
VOLUNTARY STANDARDS ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
GREATER LOW FLOW AGASSI NEED NOT
APPLY GREATER COST.
AS NEARLY ALL OF THE METERS A WE
TESTED WERE MECHANICAL METERS
DRAWN FROM OUR PARTNER UTILITIES
INVENTORIES OF NEW READERS AND
THEY WERE NOT PREMIUM PRICED NEW
TECHNOLOGY.
A STATE STANDARD COULD CUT THE
LOW FLOW TEST RATE IN THE THE
ONES IN THE VOLUNTARY INDUSTRY
STANDARD AND HALF AND PERHAPS
EVEN LOWER WITHOUT A MAJOR
REDUCTION AND UTILITY CHOICE OF
METER SUPPLY.
AB SIXTY ALLOWS THE CC UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO SET WATER
METER STANDARDS IT ALSO ALLOWS
UTILITIES TO CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
AN INSTALL NONCONFORMING METERS
AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF REQUIRED
UNDER MULTI YEAR PURCHASE
AGREEMENT.
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THIS
EASY TO SET ONE STANDARD FOR ALL
METER TYPES AS THE LETTER FROM
DOESN'T WATER AGENCY IMPLIES IN
FACT EIGHTY W. W. A. HAS
SEPARATE ACTORS THE STANDARDS
FOR EACH TYPE OF METER.
INCLUDING MECHANICAL METERS --
SUCH A SINGLE JET MULTI JET
OSCILLATING PISTON OF AS WELL AS
STATIC METERS LIKE THE
ULTRASONIC -- METERS MENTIONED.
OKAY SORRY -- WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU -- VOTE
YESTERDAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
POSITION.
J. SELECTED WITH THAT'LL STING
GILBERT ROBESON SMITH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION OF SUPPORT
A PERMANENT POSITION ON THE BILL
A HANDFUL OF TECHNICAL ISSUES WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OTHER.
MOVING TO A FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SPOT READ WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF DESERT
WATER AGENCY.
WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE AUTHOR STAFF FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS THE
BILL OVER LAST YEAR.
A LOT OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
DOES THAT WATER RATES IN OTHER
OF MY CLIENTS HAD HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED BY THE AUTHOR.
I THINK WE'RE REALLY LEFT WITH
THE QUESTION AS TO WHAT THE NEED
IS HERE -- THE AGENCY BELIEVES
THAT THE AMERICAN WATER WORKS
ASSOCIATION AND THE STANDARDS
THAT THAT INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED SCIENTIFIC IN
INDUSTRY -- GROUP PUT TOGETHER
ARE SUFFICIENT THE NEW LAWS NOT
NECESSARY.
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL COSTS THE BILL DOES
REQUIRE.
THE COMMISSION TO LOOK AT THE
LIFE CYCLE COSTS.
UNDERSTAND THAT THESE LOW FLOW
HI IF IT HI READ METERS WHILE
THEY MAY CUT.
THE ACCURACY AND HOW FOR TALKING
ABOUT MOVING FROM A 95297%
ACCURACY 298% ACCURACY SO WE'RE
WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE A 1%.
THE SIGNAL THAT THE CONSUMER
WILL RECEIVE FROM THAT MORE
ACCURATE METER WILL NOT BE WILL
BE NEGLIGIBLE.
BECAUSE WE BILL THEN ONE HUNDRED
CUBIC FEET.
INCREMENTS AND FOR USERS FOR
TYPICAL SINGLE FAMILY HOME THAT
DON'T USE A LOT OF WATER IT'S
GOING TO TAKE THE NEARLY ONE
YEAR AND A CITY DIFFERENT SO.
BE CAREFUL WITH THE POTENTIAL
COSTS THAT WERE INVOLVED IN THIS
BILL WE THINK THE A. W. DAY.
W. W. A. DOES A GOOD JOB IT
SHOULD CONTINUE BE RELIED ON
WITH US FOR A NO VOTE.
THE OTHER OPPOSITION.
HAD SEEN THAT WILL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE I GUESS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY IS MISTER WOULD --
SORRY BY THE MS GARCIA AND
SECONDED BY MISTER SOUTH.
YES MISTER DOLLAR SO -- JUST A
QUESTION I KNOW THIS IS THE
POLICY COMMITTEE NOT THE
FINANCIAL COMMITTEE WHICH IS
SOMETHING I HAVE CONCERT WITH
THAT CAN YOU TELL ME.
SO GIVE ME AN IDEA SO I HAVE
REPRESENT.
VERY SMALL COMMUNITIES WITH
WATER SYSTEMS AND SO WHAT WOULD
YOU WHAT DO YOU PERCEIVE IT TO
BE.
WHERE WHERE'S THE POINT GOING TO
BE MEASURED OUT I GUESS IS SO
YOU'RE MAJORING AT THE?
DISCHARGE WERE YOU DISCHARGED
INTO THE SYSTEM OR AT THE WHAT'S
THE PROCESS FOR ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THERE'S SO MANY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ANOTHER'S
SYSTEMS OUT THERE SO YEAH THIS
IS FOR THE INDIVIDUAL HOME
BEATER AND JUST TO CLARIFY --
THE GENTLEMAN WHO JUST SPOKE WAS
REALLY COMPARING APPLES AND
ORANGES HE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
ACCURACY PERCENTAGE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE FLOW THAT THEY CAN
MEASURE.
SO THE METERS THAT THAT ARE
OFTEN USE NOW DON'T RECORD THOSE
LOWER FLOWS SO IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF A 1% DIFFERENCE IT'S
RECORDING.
A MUCH HIGHER -- IT'S IT'S
RECORDING THE WATER -- THAT
RIGHT NOW IS NOT BEING REALLY
CAPTURED -- AND I JUST WANNA
ALSO POINT OUT THAT LAST YEAR
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO -- FOUND
OUT THAT THEY HAD HAD A TWO
MILLION DOLLAR OVER CHARGE FOR
CUSTOMERS FROM AN ACCURATE
METERS.
AND WE'VE SEEN ACROSS THE STATE
OTHER MUNICIPALITIES RUN INTO
PROBLEMS WITH METERS SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S OF CONCERN TO
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
BEST OF TECHNOLOGY THAT'S OUT
THERE. TO DO YOU ENVISION WHAT
THIS BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT IS A PHASE IN
PROCESS SO SO THIS IS THE COST
AND SO WE'RE BEEN WE'VE IN THE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS THAT I
REPRESENT.
ARE BEING NICK THEY'RE BEING
CHARGED WITH A LOT OF TASK AND
THERE'S NO ABILITY TO RECOUP THE
COST.
YEP PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN
WHICH ALLOWS A TWO THIRDS VOTE
BY THE PEOPLE ARE BEING TAXED OR
FEET OR WHATEVER WHAT DO YOU.
WHERE FRAUDULENT PUT IT SO I'M
GOING TO YEAH I'M TRYING?
TO GET MY MIND AROUND WHAT THE
HOW THIS IS GONNA BE IMPLEMENTED
AND THE TECHNOLOGY.
THE TECHNOLOGY DIFFERENCES IN
WHAT WE HAVE NOW VERSUS WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO REGULATE YEAH SO
WE'RE NOT -- ASKING FOLKS TO TO
INVEST IN A NEW TECHNOLOGY --
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A VARIETY OF METERS THAT
ARE OUT ON THE MARKET RIGHT NOW
AND SOME PERFORM BETTER THAN
OTHERS EVEN WITHIN EACH CLASS
TYPE SO?
MECHANICAL METERS ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE MORE AFFORDABLE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE MOST COMMON
AND EVEN WITHIN THOSE TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MECHANICAL
METERS SOME PERFORM BETTER.
AND SO WE'RE JUST ASKING IS THAT
CC SET STANDARDS SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT OUR WATER UTILITIES
ARE.
PURCHASING METERS THAT CAN
MEASURE AT THOSE BUT THOSE X..
EXTENDED LOS LOBOS THERE SHOULD
BE A COST DIFFERENCE TO THE
WATER DISTRICT BECAUSE THERE'S
PLENTY METERS OTHER THAT ME WHAT
WE'RE ASKING.
FOR THEY WON'T HAVE TO REPLACE
WHAT THEY HAVE WE'RE NOT ASKING
THEM TO GO IN WE EVEN SAYING
THAT THOUGH IF I WILL.
WATER UTILITY HAS A CONTRACT A
MULTI YEAR CONTRACT TO BUY A
CERTAIN METER THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO PURCHASE THAT --
THROUGH A DATE CERTAIN AND SO
THERE THERE SHOULD BE A HUGE
COST IMPACT TO A WATER SUPPLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THE RIGHT BRING IT BACK WE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I'VE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OKAY -- SO THIS IS A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHOI.
CHU.
DALY NOT VOTING DALY NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR I'D LOSE REVIEWS THREE OF
US [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I TWO FIVE TO TO CONTROL
OKAY OF FIVE VOTES THERE WILL
EVEN ON CALL.
THANKS AND WE HAVE YOUR SECOND
BILL UP NOW A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THANK YOU AB FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AUTHORIZES CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
IMPOSE AND COLLECT CIVIL
PENALTIES FROM LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITIES.
THAT FAILED TO SUBMIT WATER
RELATED REPORTS IN PLANTS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO BE SUBMITTED TO
DELIVER YOU ARE UNDER EXISTING
LAWS.
WHILE EACH OF THE SEVEN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS INCLUDED
UNDER THE BILL ARE REQUIRED BY
CURRENT LAW THE LAW IS GENERALLY
SILENT ON THE CONSEQUENCES OF
NON REPORTING.
NONE OF THESE REQUIREMENTS OR
COMPANY BY GENERALLY APPLICABLE
PENALTY FOR THE FAILURE TO MAKE
A TIMELY SUBMISSION TO W. R..
AS A RESULT COMPLIANCE WERE
WRITTEN WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IS VERY SPOTTY
ACROSS THE STATE REPORTING
COMPLIANCE FOR URBAN WATER LOSS
AUDIT REPORTS IS AROUND 90%.
WHILE REPORTING BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THEIR PERMIT
PROGRAMS FOR THE WATER
EFFICIENCY OF NEWLY IRRIGATED
LANDSCAPES IS ONLY ABOUT 35%.
WITHOUT EFFECTIVE SANCTIONS FOR
NON REPORTING LOCAL ENTITIES ARE
NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR LATER
MISSING REPORTS IN PLANS FOR THE
MORE D. W. R. HAS NOT CREATED OR
PUBLISHED A MASTER LIST OF ALL
THE LOCAL ENTITIES REQUIRED TO
COMPLY WITH WATER REPORTING LAWS.
THISMAKES IT DIFFICULT TO KNOW
THE RATE OF NON COMPLIANCE AND
WHICH DISTRICTS ARE CONSISTENTLY
IN NON COMPLIANCE.
THE LACK OF COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE WATER REPORT A WATER
PLANNING AND REPORTING LAWS
MAKES IT DIFFICULT PRETTY W. R.
TO ADEQUATELY DO ITS JOB.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC TO ASSESS THE
WORK BEING DONE BY THEIR LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE CHARGED WITH
MANAGING WATER RESOURCES.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN CREATES A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE FRAMEWORK FOR
D. W. ARE TWO ASSESSABLE
PENALTIES UPON LOCAL PUBLIC
ENTITIES THAT FAILED TO SUBMIT
PLANTS AND REPORTS THAT ARE
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW.
PENALTY LEVELS ARE VERY MODEST
DO YOU HAVE YOUR IS AUTHORIZED
TO REDUCE OUR WAIVE THE
PENALTIES ENTIRELY UNDER.
SPECIFIED CONDITIONS A PORTION
OF THE FUNDS RECEIVED AS
PENALTIES AS DIRECTED TO
SUPPLEMENT AN EXISTING FUND TO
PROVIDE LOANS TO WATER AGENCIES
FOR WATER CONSERVATION.
THE BILL ALSO FIXES THE
KNOWLEDGE AND DISCLOSURE GAP BY
REQUIRING DEEP YOU ARE TO
PUBLICLY DISCLOSE THE LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE NON COMPLIANT.
TO AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN NO.
WITH ME TODAY IT AND BY THE WAY
OUR GOAL IS TO GET COMPLIANCE
IT'S NOT TO YOU KNOW PENALIZE
AGENCIES BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE EVERYBODY IS
COMPLYING AND SOME PEOPLE AREN'T
JUST SHIRKING THE REQUIREMENT.
WITH ME TODAY IS A ROW HE SHARMA
WITH AN RTC TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY WHEN THIS IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ARE HE SHARMA I'M HERE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB --
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IF THERE'S ONE
MESSAGE THAT I HOPE YOU ALL TAKE
AWAY FROM MY TESTIMONY TODAY
IT'S THIS.
DATA HAVE VALUE.
WHEN THE ENTITIES RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING CRITICAL WATER
DATA DO NOT COMPLY WITH
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THE PUBLIC PUBLIC
IS LEFT WITH AN INCOMPLETE AND
INACCURATE PICTURE OF HOW WATER
IS USE DISTRIBUTED AND MANAGED
IN THE STATE HERE'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE?
COMMUNITIES RESIDENTS AND
FARMERS CAN USE THAT DATA THE
WATER DATA FROM THESE REPORTS TO
HOLD THEIR WATER SUPPLIERS AND
MANAGERS ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT WHEN 56% OF FARM GATE TO
LIVE REPORTS AND 16% OF RECENT
ACT WATER MANAGEMENT PLANTS ARE
MISSING THAT ACCOUNTABILITY IS
STIFLED.
WHEN WATER DATE IS ALLOWED TO
LEAK THROUGH THE DATA CRACKS
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO USE THAT
DATA IS RESTRICTED?
AND LIKE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED THERE NO CURRENTLY NO
PENALTIES FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WHICH MEANS THAT THE ENTITY IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMPLYING WITH
THE LAW.
ARE NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT NON COMPLIANCE.
THESE WATER DAY LEAKS MEAN THAT
D. W. ARE THE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR USING THIS INFORMATION TO
INFORM THEIR WATER MANAGEMENT
DECISIONS CANNOT ADEQUATELY DO
ITS JOB.
THANKFULLY AB AT WE CAN FIX THIS
LEAKY A WATER DATA PIPELINE --
WITH A. B. FOURTEEN AT FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN WHICH PROVIDES A TOOL
FOR D. W. R. TO TIGHTEN ITS
ENFORCEMENT OF WATER DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
I HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
WATER IS ONE OF THE MOST
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES IN
OUR GOLDEN STATE.
AND D. W. R. CANNOT MANAGE WHAT
IT DOES NOT EFFECTIVELY MEASURE
SO WE STRONGLY URGE YOU GAVE OUT
ON A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE THE TERRACOTTA FOR NEW
AND SUPPORT.
TRACY QUINN FOR SEAL CV IN
SUPPORT.
N. WITNESSES TUBS ISSUE HISTORY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BABRI BUT WITH THREE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF DESERT
WATER AGENCY ELDORADO IRRIGATION
DISTRICT IN VALLEY ATWATER
COALITION.
MY CLIENTS UNDERSTAND THEIR
POLITICAL SUBDIVISIONS OF THE
STATE AND THEY ARE SUBJECT TO
THE WHIMS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WITH RESPECT TO HOW THEY PERFORM
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES.
HOWEVER.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE OR NECESSARY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPOSE TO
AUTHORIZE AN AGENCIES IMPOSE
CIVIL PENALTIES. FOR THESE --
RATHER BURDENSOME AN ONEROUS
STATE MANDATES.
A LOT OF THE INTERESTS THAT ARE
NOT ABLE TO COMPEL TO COMPLETE
THESE REPORTS ARE THE SMALLER
SYSTEMS THAT SERVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE SERVING.
THREE THOUSAND TO LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS.
AND HAVING TO DO THERE'S REPORTS
IS A SIGNIFICANT COST BURDEN ON
THOSE.
I'M NOT SUGGESTED THEY NOT DO
THE REPORT COMPILED AND COMPLY
WITH THE LAW I'M JUST SUGGESTING
THAT.
IT'S BETTER FOR THE STATE TO
OFFER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GUIDELINES WERE AND A REGULATORY
APPROACH TO ASSIST THESE SMALLER
SYSTEMS AND COMPLYING WITH
REPORT.
THE SECOND POINT THAT WE WOULD
RAISE IS THAT.
WE NEGOTIATED WITH THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH RESPECT TO MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS REFORMS FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL WATER MANAGEMENT
PLANTS.
AND AS YOU WILL READ COMMITTEE
WILL RECALL IN THE MAKING WATER
CONSERVATION WAY OF LIFE
FRAMEWORK THAT THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION PUT FORTH IN IN
[inaudible] TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THERE WAS A HEAVY RELIANCE ON
CIVIL PENALTIES TO COMPEL
COMPLIANCE.
STAKEHOLDERS ENGAGED WITH THE
WITH THIS AUTHORED WITH THE
BROWN ADMINISTRATION OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY MOVE AWAY
FROM CIVIL PENALTIES TO OTHER
MEANS OF ACHIEVING COMPLIANCE.
WITH RESPECT TO ADD WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS WE NEGOTIATED A
COMPROMISE WHERE IF AN AD WATER
SUPPLIER DID NOT DO THE PLAN.
THEN THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES COULD WRITE THE PLAN
AND CHARGE THAT.
WATER SUPPLIER FOR DOING THAT
PLAN IF THE WATER SUPPLIER
FAILED TO COOPERATE WITH THAT
EFFORT.
THEN THEY COULD BE SUBJECT TO
CIVIL PENALTIES WE THINK IT WAS
AN ELEGANCE AN APPROPRIATE
COMPROMISE ONE THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN THIS AUTHORS BILL THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW A. B..
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT NOW COMES
THIS BILL TO IMPOSE A CIVIL
PENALTY OUTSIDE OF THAT PROCESS.
THE FINAL POINT WITH RESPECT TO
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANS GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
THE PENALTY THAT WE NEGOTIATE IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH RESPECT TO
SIGMA AND TRUST ME EVERY WORD IN
THAT BILL THAT LAW WAS.
VERY.
HOTLY DEBATED AND DISCUSSED.
THE PENALTY FOR NOT DOING A PLAN
IS THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TAKES OVER YOUR
YOUR BASIN.
SO WE DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY
TO HAVE A CIVIL PENALTY OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR A THOUSAND
DOLLARS WE THINK.
FOLKS ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
STATE WERE COMING IN AND
CONTROLLING GROUNDWATER
EXTRACTIONS IN THESE AREAS.
THOSE PLANS AREN'T EVEN DO AND
TELL TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND AND YET HERE WE
ARE AT THE BILL TO US ESTABLISH
A CIVIL PENALTY. ONE WE GIVE
FOLKS.
WATER DISTRICT A CHANCE TO
COMPLY WITH THESE MULTIPLE STATE
MANDATES THAT HAVE LARGELY BEEN
ADOPTED SINCE THE TWENTY TEN AND
THEN SEE HOW WE'RE DOING AT THAT
POINT SO WITH RESPECT QUESTION
OF A THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
FOR THE AUTHOR.
YES MISTER BIGELOW.
IF FOR THE AUTHOR MAYBE IT'S
JUST ONE OF THE NERDY THINGS
INSIDE THE BILL -- WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE NON COMPLIANT
LIST BEING SUBMITTED ONLY TO THE
MAJORITY PARTY LEADERS SUCH AS
THE SPEAKER PRO.
THE SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE.
WHY IS WHY IS THAT ELEMENT IN
THERE I SUPPOSE THAT WE COULD
DISTRIBUTE THE NON COMPLIANCE
LISTS HIM MORE TO EVERYBODY I
MEAN?
THAT IS WELL REAL REASONS THAT'S
REALLY THE PART OF THE QUESTION
I WAS WANTING I WAS A REASON FOR
THAT.
AND IF THERE WASN'T A REASON MY
NEXT.
ASK COULD BE CAN WE JUST DO THAT
FOR ALL EVERYONE TO BE.
PUT ON NOTICE.
HOPE THE WHITE YES SURE I DON'T
SEE WHY DON'T YOU YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO INCLUDE THAT AS YOU
MOVE.
FOR A PRESS WE COULD I'M BIGGEST
TRADITIONALLY IN THROUGH THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEES.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET THINGS
OUT TO BOTH SIDES IS THAT.
YEAH WE WERE IT'S WHAT THIS
WASN'T AT ALL ABOUT SIDES IT WAS
USED WE WERE JUST PICKING
STANDING SO I JUST THOUGHT IT
WAS ONE OF THOSE NASTY THINGS
YEAH NO THAT'S FINE.
NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I STILL DRUG STRUGGLE WITH MUCH
OF THE BILL BUT I I THERE WAS
JUST ONE OF THOSE NERDY THINGS
YOU KNOW.
LOOKING THROUGH THERE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR HELP.
IN EXPLAINING IT.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
MAYBE JUST IN IN YOUR CLOTHES.
YOU KNOW MAYBE ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT MR RE BROUGHT
UP -- WITH REGARD TO HEY WE HAD.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT I THINK
ESPECIALLY WITH AG DISTRICTS
WERE CUT ALREADY HAVE THIS
PROCESS IN PLACE AND NOW IT
SEEMS LIKE HERE COMES ANOTHER.
YEAH POTENTIAL PENALTY.
IS THIS MAY BE TOO TOO SOON.
MAYBE SEE HOW SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT IS IMPLEMENTED.
WELL THIS IS NOT ONLY FOR
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IT'S FOR
OTHER -- REPORTING AS WELL AND
WE DO KNOW THAT THEIR AGENCIES
THAT FOR YEARS HAVE BEEN OUT OF
COMPLIANCE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU HEARD IT RIGHT
THERE THAT A LOT OF THE AGENCIES
CONSIDER.
WHAT WE DO TO BE WITH AT OUR
WHIM YOU KNOW ONEROUS ALL OF
THAT THIS CLEARLY AN ATTITUDE I
THINK WITH SOME AGENCIES THAT
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE -- TO
COMPLY I MEAN THEY'RE NOT
COMPLYING SO IF AGENCIES ARE
WILLFULLY NOT COMPLYING THERE
HAS TO BE SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN
DO TO GET THEM INTO COMPLIANCE
THIS IS WE'RE TALKING SUCH A
SMALL YOU KNOW WHAT A NOMINAL
AMOUNT BUT IT WOULD IT'S REALLY
INTENDED TO GET THEIR ATTENTION.
AND TO SAY IT'S NOT JUST OUR
WHIMS WE DO THIS WITH INTENTION
AND WE EXPECT THESE REPORTS TO
BE GENERATED.
AND I WILL SAY ALSO WE HAVE
ANOTHER BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE
SEEN BY THIS COMMITTEE IT MAY
HAVE ALREADY GONE THROUGH ON
CONTENT I'M NOT SURE THAT.
THAT I DON'T REMEMBER THAT
STREAMLINES THE REPORTING TO TRY
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE
AGENCIES SO THAT IF THEY WANT TO
THEY CAN JUST DO THE REPORTING
ONCE A YEAR INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
LOOK EVERY MONTH TO SEE WHAT'S
DO.
SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
RED TAPE FOR A LOT OF AGENCIES
WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
AND REDUCE IT AND MAKE IT EASIER
AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT YOU HAVE TO IT WHEN YOU HAVE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN COMPLIED.
WHAT DO WE DO WHAT ELSE CAN WE
POSSIBLY DO AT THIS POINT -- AND
IT DOES SAY THAT YOU HAVE YOUR
CAN WAVE OF PEOPLE ARE MAKING
pTOWARDS THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
DO THIS -- SO I THINK THAT IT'S
VERY REASONABLE AND IF AND IF
THE AGENCIES.
DON'T WANT.
TO HAVE THIS ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTY THEY CAN JUST COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
OKAY -- WELL THAT IT DOES HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
THE AYE. FOR ME PERSONALLY I
THINK.
THOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT
OF WE WANT TO BRING PEOPLE INTO
COMPLIANCE I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF THESE DISTRICTS.
AS A SOLOMON DALLY BROUGHT UP --
THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH THEIR
REVENUES AS IS.
AND KEEPING UP WITH ALL THE
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
OUT THERE -- AND THEN THE OTHER
THING IS AS WE MOVE INTO
CONSERVATION IS A WAY OF LIFE.
AS YOU'RE.
HAVING THOSE RATE PAYERS --
CONSERVE.
IT ALSO BECOMES ACTUALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR THAT REPAIR --
BECAUSE THEY STILL HAVE YOU'VE
NO MATTER HOW MUCH THEY CAN
SERVE THEIR THE END UP ACTUALLY
PAYING THE SAME SOMETIMES ANSWER.
YOU KNOW APPLY TO THEM AS YOU
KNOW IN ORDER TO COMPLY WITH
THESE PROVISIONS SO.
YEAH -- AND THEN IF WE HAVE A
FINE LEVIED UPON THE ALTERNATELY
THAT'S A RATE PAYER THAT'S GONNA
PAYING.
FINES AS WELL IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THE THE DIRECTORS OF THAT
DISTRICTS US IS.
I THINK FOR SOME OF THESE
DISTRICTS IT'S IT'S IT'S
BECOMING HARDER.
TO COMPLY WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE OUT THERE AND
THEN ALSO HAVE IN REVENUE
STRESSES.
NO -- ALSO THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH WITH COMPLAINTS SO.
SO I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND MAYBE SOMETHING THAT COULD.
CAN HELP ALLEVIATE THAT FOR SOME
OF THESE DISTRICTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING.
AND WHAT THAT'LL DO NOT INCLUDE
CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MOST -- SORRY I DID NOT GET HIM.
MOTION BY MISTER KALRA AND
SECOND BY MISTER WOOD THANK YOU
FOR CATCHING THAT.
ALL RIGHT SEVENTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
BIGELOW.
NOT BIGELOW NO CHOI.
CHOICE NO.
TO DELHI.
DELHI NO FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS.
WOULD.
WOULD HIGH. THREE TO FOUR OKAY
HAS THREE BUILT SIMILARLY THAT A
COUGH -- MISTER GLAZER I BELIEVE
YOU ARE PRESENTING FOR MISTER
LEVINE TODAY -- AND SENATOR IT'S
A PLEASURE TO HAVE YOU HERE GOOD
TO BE HERE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME SO AB A SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE.
BOTH HAVE SIMILAR BILLS ON THE
SUBJECT THIS YEAR AND IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE THIS BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT SMOKING OUR STATE
BEACHES AND PARKS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO SOME OF THE
NATION'S BUT SCENIC BEACHES AT
PARK LANDS. FOR THE PARKS AND
BEACHES ARE MANAGED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
AND DAD.
IT HAS IT'S A WONDERFUL GREAT
EXPANSE OF HOLDING OF THE STATE
AGENCY.
AS YOU KNOW SECONDHAND SMOKING
LITTERING OF CIGARETTE **** IS
DETRIMENTAL THE HEALTH OF OF
VISITORS AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
CIGARETTE **** AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMMONLY LITTERED ITEMS ON EARTH.
FOR THE LITTER RATE OF
APPROXIMATELY 60%.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THEY
WERE THE MOST COLLECTED ITEM
WORLDWIDE.
DURING INTERNATIONAL CALLS TO
CLEAN UP DAY.
HOW TO TESTIFY?
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT.
IS ROBERT UNIONS WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY.
MOVED AND SECONDED -- MISTER
MISTER KALRA MISTER WOULD --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ROBERT NING AS I'M WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE --
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
CIGARETTE **** ARE THE MOST
COMMONLY FOUND ITEM DURING A
BEACH AND WATER WAY CLEANUPS
RANKING TOP TEN MOST COLLECTED
ITEMS.
ALONG WITH PLASTIC BAGS AND
STYROFOAM -- TAKEN CONTAINERS
DATA FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN
INTERNATIONAL COASTAL CLEANUP
REVEALED THAT CIGARETTE ****.
BOB WHERE THE NUMBER ONE MOST
COLLECTED IN BEACH CLEANUPS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CIGARETTE **** NOT ONLY POSE
CHOKING AND POISON HAS OR TO
WILDLIFE.
THAT MAY.
THAT MAY MYSTIC THE LETTER FOR
FOOD BUT THE TOXINS CAN LEAD
FROM THESE BUT ALSO DETRIMENTAL
TO WATER QUALITY AND CAN LEAD TO
HUMAN WILDLIFE HEALTH CONCERNS.
NUMEROUS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
THE STATE HAVE ALREADY.
ADOPTED ORDINANCES TO BAN
SMOKING ON PARKS AND PUBLIC
BEACHES.
THIS MEASURE WOULD BRING THE
ENTIRE STATE UNDER UNIFIED
POLICY THAT WOULD REDUCE.
OF CIGARETTE LETTER AND
POLLUTION TO OUR PARKS BEACHES
AND OF WATERS THANK YOU.
OKAY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
TRACY BYRD A TARA SOME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION.
THERESA BREAKAGE ON BEHALF OF
HEAL THE BAY IN THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MORE IN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CAN'T DO BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT AND I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO CONVEY THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL.
ZACHARY CORE BUT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
HI WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE GERMAN MEMBERS OF THE MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
INSURERS PRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARK RANGERS ASSOCIATION.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE PARK RANGERS
THAT ARE COMPLETELY SUPPORTS THE
BAN ON SMOKING IN THE PARK WE
HAVE TWO CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
IN OUR POINT OF VIEW COMES
DIRECTLY FROM.
THE RANGER IN THE FIELD WAS
GOING TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SUCCESSFULLY.
IMPLEMENTING THIS BAND -- OUR
CONCERNS THIS THE MORE MINOR
CONCERN IS THE BAIL AMOUNT
CURRENTLY BILL MONTHS TWENTY
FIVE WHICH IS.
VERY LOW AND INCONSISTENT WITH --
THE MAIL AMOUNT FOR THE
STATEWIDE SMOKING BAN ALL LOCAL
BANDS.
THE STATE WIDE ONE IS UP TO
HUNDRED AND UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
MULTIPLE ARE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARK REGULATIONS AS INFRACTIONS
HAVE A A VIOLATION AMOUNT FINE
OF UP TO A THOUSAND AND OF
COURSE THAT'S NOT THE AMOUNT
THAT THE DA'S IN THE COURTS
DECIDE THE ACTUAL BAIL AMOUNTS --
DEPENDING ON THEIR LOCAL
CONDITIONS -- OUR SECOND MORE
SERIOUS -- CONSIDERATION HAS TO
DO WITH THE AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
THE RELIGIOUS BELIEF LANGUAGE
THE COULD EASILY MAKE
ENFORCEMENT IN THE FIELD BY OUR
RANGERS IN THE FIELD.
LARGELY IMPOSSIBLE.
THE REASON FOR THIS IS THAT --
FIELD RANGERS HAVE NO WAY TO
VERIFY A PERSON'S PERSONAL
BELIEF AND IT'S VERY HARD FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO ASCERTAIN.
A PERSON CAN SIMPLY SAY.
I HADN'T I'M SMOKING IS MY
PERSONAL BELIEVE FOR RELIGIOUS
BELIEF AND THE WORD COULD EASILY
GO AROUND IS THAT WOULD AND
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THESE ARE THE
MAGIC WORDS.
WE FEEL THAT THE RANGERS NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE.
WE THINK THAT JUST A MINOR PER
MINOR AMENDMENT TO THIS PROPOSAL
TO TAKE OUT THE WORD BELIEVE AND
PUT IN SOME LANGUAGES SAYS THE
GOOD FAITH EXERCISE OF A
RELIGIOUS PRACTICE OR CEREMONY.
WOULD GIVE RANGERS THAT TOOL.
THE REASON IS EVEN PRACTICE AND
CEREMONIES INSTEAD OF BELIEVE
ALLOW THE FIELD RANGER.
IN SITUATIONS OF DUBIOUS CLAIMS
OF RELIGIOUS SMOKING WHICH
PROBABLY REPLY TO NINETY NINE
POINT 9% OF PEOPLE JUST WANT TO
SMOKE. TO INQUIRE ABOUT THAT
RELIGIOUS PRACTICE OUR BELIEF
WILL GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
HANDLES WE DO AND MANY OF OUR
VIOLATIONS TO THE INTENT OF THE
PERSON.
AND WE'RE LIMITED TO PERSON JUST
BEING ABLE TO SAY IT'S A BELIEF --
ALTHOUGH THIS IS A SMALL CHANGE
THE RANGERS SOLICITATION FEELS
WE GIVE THE FIELD RANGER ENOUGH
OF A TOOL DETERMINE TO BETWEEN
ORDINARY SMOKING.
AND GENUINE ARTICULATED
RELIGIOUS ACTIVITIES.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER LYNCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SCOTT
ST PLACE I'M A CITIZEN ACTIVIST
AS WELL AS AN AVID VISITOR OF
OUR CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER MUCH
RESEARCH I WROTE THE ORIGINAL
LANGUAGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS SMOKING BAN
LEGISLATION AND HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED EVER SENSE.
THAT SAID I HAVE THREE ISSUES
REGARDING THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
OF AB.
ONE SEVEN ONE EIGHT FIRST ONE
BEING FINE AMOUNT A SECOND BEING
THE RELIGIOUS FREEDOM EXEMPTION
AND THE THIRD BEING THE COST.
THE FIRST PROBLEM IS THE FIFTH
INEFFECTIVE PROPOSE FINE AMOUNT
OF UP TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR
VIOLATIONS.
MY ANALYSIS OF OTHER STATE PARKS
SMOKING BAN FINES REVEALS OREGON
STATE PARK FINES UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS NEW
JERSEY STATE PARKS START AT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS AND GO
AS HIGH AS ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
HAWAII STATE PARKS DO NOT EVEN
HAVE A SET FINE AMOUNT. TWENTY
FIVE BUCKS IS ABOUT THE SAME
COST TO THREE PACKS OF
CIGARETTES AND HONESTLY HOW MANY
SMOKERS DO YOU KNOW WHO WILL
TAKE A POTENTIAL UP TO TWENTY
FIVE DOLLAR FINE AMOUNT
SERIOUSLY.
AS I RECALL THE LANGUAGE FROM
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SMOKING BANS CONTAINED
IN UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR FINE AMOUNT.
THE REASON BEING TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS IS IN LINE WITH
THE STATE LITERAL OP FINE WHICH
IS ACCEPTED IS COMPLETELY
REASONABLE.
THE SECOND PROBLEM WITH AB ONE
SEVEN ONE EIGHT IS THE RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM EXEMPTION.
DEFINING A GOOD FAITH PRACTICE
OF A RELIGIOUS BELIEF LEGALLY IS
GOING TO BE A VERY DIFFICULT
THING TO DO.
A GOOD FAITH PRACTICE OF A
RELIGIOUS BELIEF IS FAR TOO
SUBJECTIVE AND ONLY CREATES A
MASSIVE LOOPHOLE THERE IS NO
SMOKING BAN IN THE ENTIRE NATION
WEAR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM COMES
INTO PLAY.
MY HOME COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
PASSED THE SMOKING BAN LAST
MONTH FOR COUNTY BEACHES IN
INLAND PARKS WITH NO RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTIONS MADE.
LASTLY BUT COST OF IMPLEMENTING
A SMOKING BAN WILL BE AROUND TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
PLEASE LET'S NOT WASTE OUR
CALIFORNIA'S TAX CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS MONEY ON A LOT THAT IS
INEFFECTIVE AN UNENFORCEABLE.
AFTER HAVING SERVED AS A
MILITARY POLICEMAN IN THE U. S.
ARMY.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM EXPERIENCE
THAT LAWS RULES REGULATIONS THAT
OFFER TOO MUCH WIGGLE ROOM FOR
VIOLATORS TO ESCAPE FROM.
THE AVERAGE PEACE OFFICER WILL
SIMPLY FOCUS THEIR ATTENTION ON
OTHER PRIORITIES.
AB ONE SEVEN ONE EIGHT CONTINUES
TO USE THE SAME FLIGHT FAILED
GAME PLAN WHOSE SOLE PURPOSE WAS
TO HOPEFULLY APPEASE JERRY BROWN
BACK IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE YEAR IS NOW
201-9 WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR AND
NEW PROSPECTS FOR GETTING GOOD
THINGS DONE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I KNOW
FULL WELL THAT YOU WANT TO PASS
A STRONG INTELLIGENT ENFORCEABLE
LAW THAT WILL GIVE OUR STATE
PARKS THE PROTECTION THEY NEED.
WHILE MAKING BEST USE OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TAX DOLLARS.
THEREFORE I AM ASKING YOU TO DO
THE SMART THING. TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND INSIST THAT PROPER
CORRECTIONS BE MADE TO THIS WELL
MEANING BILL BEFORE IT IS
ALLOWED TO MOVE FORWARD THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION -- BRING IT
BACK TO THE OMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR ON THIS.
AND WE'VE HAD THIS BILL BEFORE
US A FEW TIMES NOW -- YES.
DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR OF EVEN THOUGH I
DO READ -- IMPEDE ANALYSIS -- OF
FROM MY KANTAKOUZENOS POSE ABOUT
THE I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS
ONE ON THE BASIS OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCE SO.
IN THE CITY OF IRVINE WE OUT.
DID THE VERY EXTENSIVE -- THE
HEALTH IMPACT UPON THE SECONDARY
SMOKING IT WAS SO AWFUL WHEN
MEAN AND THAT WE ADOPTED THE NO
SMOKING IN THE PUBLIC AREAS AN
OPEN.
ALL.
A SPACE IN THIS WORKING VERY
VERY WELL.
EVEN THOUGH TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
A MAY NOT BE ENOUGH -- TO BEGIN
WITH I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
DETERRENCE.
ONCE -- THIS -- BANIAS
IMPLEMENTED.
RAISING THE FINE IF FOR TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS DOESN'T WORK IT
WILL BE A LOT EASIER -- AND OUT
ON THAT BASIS SO I THINK WE NEED --
TO THE VOTE ON THIS ONE TO BAN.
SMOKING ON THE PUBLIC BEACHES SO --
HAD THE PICNIC AREAS -- BECAUSE
SOMEONE WANTS TO OUR FEW PEOPLE
WOULD RUIN AND TYLER.
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE PRESENT.
IN THAT AREA AND A SECONDARY
HOME.
FOR IMPACT UPON HEALTH OF THIS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE SO THEREFORE
IS NOT JUST THE INDIVIDUAL OR SO.
I HAD BEEN A TO BE HONORED THE
BUT THEY THE PUBLIC PLACES SUCH
THIS IS SOMETHING I WOULD NOT.
BE ABLE -- TO SUPPORT TO WANT
SOMEBODY SMOKES IN THE PUBLIC
AREA.
THANK YOU.
HE DUCKED CHOI ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SIR TO GLAZE YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
AND THANK EACH YEAR GALLAGHER.
LET ME JUST SUFFERS SAY THAT.
DOCTOR CHOI THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THIS EFFORT
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS SECOND TO NONE
AND WOULD APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE HAVE --
WORKED ON THIS TOGETHER FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS NOW.
LET ME ADDRESS A COUPLE THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
I IN REGARD TO THE AMOUNT.
YOU KNOW AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA UNIFORM BEILIN
PENALTY SCHEDULE CREATES A A
SERIES OF FIVE ADDITIONAL COSTS
TO A TECH AND NOT JUST THE FACE
VALUE.
OUR DETERMINATION IS THAT THE
COST OF A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
SMOKING VIOLATION WOULD.
BE CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL COSTS
I WOULD NOTE THAT AT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ADJUST IN
FUTURE YEARS IF WE FIND THAT THE
FINE IS A SIGNIFICANT UP ISSUE
THAT WE WANT.
TO MAKE IT HIGHER -- IN REGARD
TO THE RELIGIOUS BELIEF.
WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR A PARK
RANGERS THEY HAVE DIFFICULT JOBS --
AND WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
MAKE THE MORE DIFFICULT.
BUT THEY ENJOY A LOT OF
DISCRETION IN THE CHOICES THEY
MAKE IN THE FIELD.
AND I THINK THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE GOOD JUDGMENTS
ABOUT WHETHER SOMEONE IS
PRACTICING -- IN A RELIGIOUS
BELIEF FOR CEREMONY -- AS THE
BILL SPECIFIES OR NOT.
AND IF THERE'S A DISPUTE ON THAT
THAT THE COURTS WILL ULTIMATELY
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT THAT WAS
BEING DONE APPROPRIATELY --
MEMBERS WE'VE WORKED ON THIS
BILL FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS I
THINK PEOPLE ARE PRETTY SET IN
THEIR VIEWS ABOUT IT.
BUT I THINK FROM OUR POINT OF
VIEW FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVIN'S POINT OF VIEW.
PUBLIC HEALTH -- THE SAFETY OF
OUR FORESTS AND PARKS -- IT MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF OUR STATE TO
HAVE AS A MY WITNESS INDICATED A
UNIFORM POLICY ACROSS THE BOARD.
I THINK IT'S A HEALTHY ONE FOR
FOR PEOPLE AND AND FOR WILDLIFE
AND FOR OUR OUR STATE WITH THAT
I ASKED HERE I PUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- THIS
DOESN'T DO IT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
I PERSONALLY AS AS A HAVE IN THE
PAST WILL BE IN OPPOSE -- BUT IT
DOES SEVENTY PASSENGERS SO MADAM
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER NO GALLAGHER NO
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CHOI HI CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU I THANK YOU ELIE
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS BLANCA
RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
WOULD I THINK YOU [inaudible]
SIXTY TWO SIX VOTES WILL BE THAT
A CALL.
THANK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHT I WILL PRESENT THE LAST
BILL.
OKAY THE LET'S.
I FORGOT MACHINE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU HAVE AB
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN YOU HAD A
MOTION BY MISTER WOULD I BELIEVE
IT WAS AND I SCOND BY MISS
GARCIA -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS
IS A GREAT BILL TO PROVIDE YOU
LIKE IT'S CLOSEHERE YOU'D FOR
DAM UNDER JUST CHECKING. TO PAY
THEIR DAM FEES.
I WOULD ASK DERIVE A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT -- I DO NOT YOU HAVE
WITNESSES ARE THERE ARE FOLKS
WHO WISH TO SUPPORT THIS BILL IN
THE AUDIENCE.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE MAKE A MOTION FOR
PAT WE HAVE A MOTION AGAIN BY
MISTER WOOD AND A SECOND BY MISS
GARCIA.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I SHOULD LIKE TO OFFER A CLOSE --
DISASTER AYE VOTE.
THIS IS WELL DONE IT'S A WELL
WRITTEN BILL WE THANK YOU IT HAS
A DO PASS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH.
LET'S SEE HOW THE VOTE GOES
THOUGH THE BUT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GALLAGHER.
BY GALLAGHER I'D BIGELOW.
CONSIDERING AN ON A YEAH I'LL GO.
HELLO I CHOI.
I THINK GUYS [inaudible]
I CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALLY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HI GLORIA [inaudible]
HI KALRA [inaudible]
THREE OF US [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
LOUGHERY VIA ICE SALAS.
WOOD [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN GALLAGHER.
IT HAD A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I TO MATE IT'S A. B..
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN AGAIN.
IT HAD TO DO FIVE THREE MEN I
SIX TEN THERE ARE SOME ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER THEIR ACTING VICE
CHAIR.
OF THE TO STAY UP THERE.
MISTER CHAIR AND YOU CAN
FINALIZE ALL THE VOTES FOR SIR.
SEVEN YOU HAVE TO LEAVE AND GO
SOMEWHERE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT WORLD.
ALL RIGHT -- WHAT HERE'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO WE'RE GONNA?
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THE THE
LIST OF BILLS AT THIS POINT. FOR
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE SO WE
CAN -- THOSE MEMBERS WISH TO GO
AND THEN WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN [inaudible] FOR FIVE WHAT
AFTER WE GET DONE WILL KEEP THE
ROLL UP UNTIL -- ONE THIRTY FOR
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE AT
THIS TIME SO WITH THE SECRETARY
PLEASE START WITH AGENDA ITEM.
ONE AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT AND
LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
NUMBER ONE AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
GLORIA [inaudible]
CHIU.
HI CHIU I'D.
BLANCA RUBIO RIGHT.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
WOULD.
YOU GOT.
YEAH.
SO IT SAT ON THE THREE NINE TWO
ONE NINE ONE ONE CALL OKAY.
THAT'S THAT'S NINETY ONE IS
STILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
TO ONE THIRTY HAS A GOOD NUMBER.
I'D CHEN ITEM A. B..
FIVE TO SEVEN CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DALLY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
AS HIS AGENDA ITEM.
TO AB.
FIVE TO SEVEN FRIEDMAN NOT
VOTING CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA
[inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE TWO ONE TWO ONE THE BILL
HAS FIVE TO ONE WE'LL KEEP IT ON
CALL TOLL LIKE I SAID WHEN.
THIRTY MOVING ON THE AGENDA ITEM
THREE AB.
ONE TWO FIVE FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB ONE TWO FIVE FOUR DALY.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
I KALRA [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
LONGER RUBIO NETWORKING.
LOCKER RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS.
SALAS I SIX SEVEN TO THREE THAT
ONE IS SEVENTY THREE WILL HAVE
THAT BILL ON CALL.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM AB.
TWELVE SIXTY AB [inaudible]
TWELVE SIXTY GALLEY.
THE ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS IS
AGENDA ITEM [inaudible]
FOR MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
DALY NO.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I GLORIA.
HI GLORIA I KALRA [inaudible]
I ROBERT RIVAS.
BLANCA RUBIO.
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS AYE SALAS
AYE. TEN TO THREE WITH WITH A
CAN OF THREE THAT IS TENDER
THREE AGAIN WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN AS WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
LIST.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO CHEN ITEM
FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT CHIU
[inaudible]
CHIU I DALLY NO DALY NO
GLORIA.
HI GLORIA I KALRA [inaudible]
LARA I ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
WALKER RUBIO.
LONGER RUBIO NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
THAT'S 671-234-5725.
IT IS SEVEN TO FIVE AGAIN SAME
THING WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
GOING THROUGH THE LIST GOING TO
AGENDA ITEM SIX AB.
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SIXTY CHOI.
NOW CHOI NO.
CHIU ART CHIU I'D [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
I ROBERT RIVAS I THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE TWO THREE
THAT WAS NINE TO THREE AGAIN
WILL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN
[inaudible]
GEN ITEM [inaudible] EIGHT THAT
IS A. B..
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN WHAT WHAT I'LL
CALL SENATE THE AND THE BEFORE
YOU SEVEN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
DALLY.
HI KELLY I KALRA.
I THREE OF US I'VE THREE OF US I
SALAS.
SALAS HI IT'S FOURTEEN TO ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO AS WE CAN SAFELY
SAY.
WELL WAIT TILL THE END.
GOING TO AGENDA ITEM TEN THAT'S
AB.
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN AB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN NUMBER TEN DALY.
DALY I KALRA.
COLOR I'D.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I'D BLANCA RUBIO.
LOCAL RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I FOURTEEN TWO ZERO AGAIN
IT'S A SAFE.
BET ON THAT ONE BUT WE'LL KEEP
IT OPEN [inaudible]
AB.
ELEVEN I'M SORRY AGENDA ITEM
ELEVEN AB.
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE SB THIRTY FIVE
ITEM ELEVEN CHIU.
CHIU I'D DELI.
DELI I'D GLORIA.
HI GLORIA I KALRA.
KALRA I THREE OF US I WAS
RIVERSIDE.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I BLANCA RUBIO.
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOULD I FOURTEEN TO ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ON NASHVILLE.
MOVING ON TO ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB TEN EIGHTY SIX MAYBE
TEN EIGHTY SIX ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN GALLAGHER.
WHICH ONE IS THIS.
BARNES AND NOBLE A SIX GALLAGHER
NO.
CHOI NO CHOI NO. TWO HI CHIU I'D
DALLY.
GO DAILY NO [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I SALAS.
SO.
SALAS NOT VOTING.
WOULD WOULD I NINE TO FOUR
NINETY FOUR ON NINE THAT IS.
NINE TO FOUR WE'LL KEEP THAT ONE
ROLE FOR THE ROLE TO BE OPEN
TILL THE END.
SO IT'S A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT
SO EVERYONE PLEASE FOCUS ON THIS
FOR A MOMENT.
AGENDA ITEM FOURTEEN AB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR WAS HEARD IN
COMMITTEE IT -- DID NOT HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION BY THE
CHAIR.
THERE WAS A MOTION OFFERED BUT
NO SECOND.
WAS PRESENTED BY THE MEMBERS
THAT WERE PRESENT AT THE TIME.
DOES ANYONE.
WISH TO SECOND THE MOTION.
ARE FOR A. B..
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR SCENE NINE
THE AUTHOR WAS.
OFFERED AND IT WAS EXTENDED FOR
RECONSIDERATION SO WE'LL LET
THAT ONE STAND.
ON A ON ITS OWN AT THAT POINT.
DID EVERYONE UNDERSTAND.
I JUST WANNA BE REAL CLEAR TO BE
FAIR TO MR FRAZIER.
MOVING ON LET'S MOVE ON TO A. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THAT'S AGENDA
ITEM SEVENTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ITEM
SEVENTEEN CHIU [inaudible]
CHIU I CRISTINA GARCIA.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I'D [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I'D SALAS.
SALAS NOT VOTING -- MISS GARCIA.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CAST YOUR VOTE
ON AGENDA ITEM SEVENTEEN THAT'S
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FRIEDMAN.
THE CRISTINA GARCIA HI. SIX
SEVEN EIGHT GOOD.
SELECT THE KIDS IS GOOD FOR THE
FIRST FOUR EIGHT FOUR FOUR
THAT'S EIGHT TO FOUR WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT.
STILL WORKING WE'LL GO TO AGENDA
ITEM.
EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX CORNER
HORVATH [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO.
CHOI NO CHOI NO TWO ARE CHIU I'D.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US EYES ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS I 791-023-1028 ON
THAT BILL TEND.
TO JUMP RIGHT INTO THREE THANK
YOU -- THEN WE ARE AT AGENDA
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEVINE
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY TWO DALY.
DALY NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I KALRA.
KALRA I THREE OF US WHOSE
RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS NOW. 678-910-24 CAN THE
BOARD THAT BILL.
SOME HELP WAS COME TO THE FINAL --
ACTION ITEM AND THAT WAS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M THAT WAS FOR AGENDA ITEM
[inaudible] 791-215-1619 TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE THAT WAS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
RIGHT -- WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAD
A VOTE THIS IS GOING BACK AND
FOR THOSE THAT WERE ABSENT.
CHIU RIGHT CHIU I THREE OF US HI
THREE OF US I BLANCA RUBIO FAR
LONGER RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOULD I FOURTEEN TO ZERO OKAY.
NOW.
YEAH.
YES -- SO FAR ACCORDING TO MY
EYE BUT IN CASE I MISSED IT I
THINK EVERYBODY.
WE'LL BE GOOD.
UP AND TELL UP FOR THE FIRST
FOUR ITEMS YOU WERE ALL.
A NUMBER OF YOU WERE STILL
ABSENT SO MOST EVERYBODY'S GOOD
WILL START AT ONE SALAS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT SALAS.
SALAS I TEND [inaudible]
TO ONE YES.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN DALLY
[inaudible]
DALY I KALRA [inaudible]
LARA KNOW.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I SALAS.
SALAS HI. SIX SEVEN EIGHT TWO
TWO THE PERSON [inaudible]
RIGHT.
YEAH.
NUMBER.
THREE AGENDA ITEM THREE A. B.
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR AB TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR KAMLAGER-DOVE.
DALY NO DALY NOW.
KALRA.
KALRA I ROBERT RIVAS -- HI
ROBERT RIVAS I 1-345-678-9249 TO
FORTY PASS.
NUMBER AGENDA ITEM FOR A. B..
TWELVE SIXTY PLEASE CALL ROLL
AGAIN.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I ELEVEN TO THREE
AGENDA ITEM.
FIVE AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I IS
[inaudible]
EIGHT TO FIVE OKAY AMBER
THIRTEEN AB -- TEN EIGHTY SIX NO
THAT'S HAS EVERYONE.
OKAY I THINK WITH COMPLETED ALL
OF THE THE ACTIONS ON BEFORE IS
HERE.
TODAY -- SO.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT.
THAT HAVE BEEN HEARD EXCEPT.
FOR THE NUMBER YOU HAVE ON HERE.
OKAY SO JUST FOR THE RECORD AND
FOR CLARITY ALL THE BILL'S MADE
IT OUT TODAY [inaudible]
EXCEPT.
FOR ITEM FOURTEEN MISTER
FRASIER'S ON MISTER FRASIER'S
DID RECEIVE A RECONSIDERATION.
WITH THAT SAID THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED